Ich musste mich selbst verbreiten, meine Training zu nutzen und den Situationen zu bequem machen.
Nein, es hat nur ein bisschen Konzentration gemacht.
Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 211. Ausgabe von CRE. Eine Serie, die jetzt hier in den letzten Ausgaben wilde Themenwechsel hinter sich hat und so geht's natürlich auch weiter. Heute möchte ich mich mal auf ein ja, einen Teil der Gesellschaft blicken, der uns irgendwie alle betrifft, der täglich über unseren Köpfen stattfindet und wo wir auch häufig genug mit drin sitzen. Kurz, es geht um die zivile Luftfahrt. Und um darüber das eine oder andere zu erfahren, begrüße ich Stefan. Stefan, du bist Pilot.
Ich bin Pilot, ja. Verkehrspilot, aber manche Leute auch.
Und zwar das große Eisen.
Das große Eisen, ja genau. Schweres Gerät sozusagen.
Und ja, das ist deine Welt. Wie lange bist du das schon?
Seit 89 fliege ich regelmäßig oder verdiene mein Geld damit. Angefangen mit kleinen Flugzeugen seit 85. Also ich bin ja seit, was sind das jetzt, 25, 26 Jahren im Geschäft. Ja, so ungefähr, ja im Flugstunden habe ich es ausgerechnet. Ein Jahr und, ich glaube ich habe es gesagt, ein Jahr und acht Monate war ich nicht auf der Erde.
Wow. Also sozusagen auch schon ein ordentliches Kontingent kosmischer Strahlung eingesammelt.
Ja genau, leider, leider. Also das, wir sprechen mit Ärzten, wenn es darum geht, ob man nochmal geröntgt wird, dann sage ich auch mal, bitte können wir das nicht vermeiden, ich habe schon genug. Ich habe auch ein Strahlenschutzkonto. Das heißt? Luftfahrtpersonal muss bei den zuständigen Behörden, jetzt frage ich jetzt nicht, wo das ist, die haben ein Strahlenschutzkonto, weil nach Jahren der Arbeit endlich mal erkannt wurde, dass das Personal halt Strahlen ausgesetzt wird und es wird ein theoretisches Modell, der basiert auf die Flüge, in welche Richtung man sie getan hat, ein theoretisches Modell erstellt, wie viel Strahlung ich angeblich bekommen habe. Das habe ich mal einem Röntgenarzt gezeigt, der hat gesagt, das ist ja gar nichts, das sind ja nur so und so Mediziner, das brauchst du keine Sorgen zu machen. Hat mich trotzdem nicht beruhigt.
Na gut, ich meine, so auf dem Level von Astronauten bist du wahrscheinlich nicht.
Nein, definitiv nicht. Und ich bin sowieso gering, weil ich in den letzten Jahren mehr in Europa unterwegs bin. Kollegen, die mehr die Langstrecke fliegen, was ich demnächst ja auch werde, da kommen wir bestimmt auch noch dazu, und mehr Nordatlantik fliegen, die bekommen eine deutlich größere Dosis ab.
Das heißt, da ist sozusagen noch mehr in Sicht für dich.
Ja, schön, da ist noch mehr in Sicht. Es gibt aber viele Kollegen, die haben auch dementsprechende Apps von Space Weather oder Newsletter gibt es, die man abonnieren kann, wo dann ein bisschen vorab gewarnt wird, wie das Space Weather, also die Strahlen, wie hoch die Dosis möglicherweise erhöht sein könnte.
Dann kann man doch eh nichts dagegen machen oder hat man da noch einen Aluhut auf?
Man kann nichts dagegen machen, aber man kann sagen, vielleicht fliege ich heute mal nicht so hoch.
Erzhaft?
Ja.
Aber die Freiheit hat man?
Ja, noch viel mehr Freiheiten, aber die natürlich, die hat man.
Was heißt dann nicht so hoch, also normalerweise ist man dann so in zehn, elf Kilometern unterwegs und…
Also ja, elf Kilometer, ja wer sagt, ich bin nur zum Fuß, aber elf Kilometer ist so eine gute Höhe und dann sagt man vielleicht fliege ich halt nur zehn Kilometer hoch, aber die letzten zwei Kilometer von elf auf elf auf zwölf, die sind schon deutlich spürbar dann im Konto, wobei das geht gar nicht rein in mein Strahlenschusskonto, sondern das wird immer nur so ein theoretischer Flug angenommen, weil keiner von uns führt ein Messgerät mit sich, also kein offizielles, deswegen ist alles nur Theorie.
Obwohl ja im Prinzip könnte man ja heutzutage, wenn ja ohnehin schon alle Flüge weitgehend mitgetrackt, einschließlich der Höhe. Ich weiß nicht, ob das auch über den Ozeanen auch so detailliert erfasst wird?
Über den Ozean nicht, da geht es an der Flugpläne und Hand der Zeiten, glaube ich.
Aber das Flugzeug selber müsste das ja eigentlich wissen. Also wenn einer weiß, dann ist es das Flugzeug, aber es schweißt wahrscheinlich die Daten nicht so ohne Weiteres aus.
Doch, schweißt die Daten sogar aus.
Dann kann man ja am Ende des Fluges noch einen USB-Stick reinstecken.
Also Flightradar 24 basieren ja genau auf den Daten, die das Flugzeug von alleine rausspuckt.
Aber die können über dem Ozean nicht einsammeln, die Daten.
Genau, weil da gibt es keine Empfangstationen. Und wenn auch die frisch gespeicherten danach noch mal nass geliefert? Nein, das nicht. Aber man weiß ja, mit welcher Höhe man in den nord-allandischen Raum reingeflogen ist. Da bin ich jetzt nicht sicher, ob es dann schon eine kleine Schnittschale gibt von den offiziellen Behörden, die natürlich die Flugsicherung, die dementsprechend den Luftraum dort kontrolliert, ob die auch ein Report, eine Schnittstelle haben. Aber ich glaube nicht. Aber man weiß aber, wann die losgeflogen sind, in welcher Höhe, in welcher Geschwindigkeit und man kennt die Einkunftszeit und dann weiß man irgendwann, wann sie auch wieder reinfliegen. Und dann, wenn Landfall ist, wenn man auf Land tritt, dann gibt es wieder viele Freiwillige, die die Signale auffangen und dann ins Netzwerk reinspeisen. Das ganze Flightrad 324 basiert ja auf freiwilliger Arbeit von vielen Leuten, die sich kleine Empfänger gebaut haben und eben diese Signale empfangen.
Und machen damit Business sozusagen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein großes Business ist. Machen damit Business, ja schon, ein bisschen schon. Machen auf Schlagzeilen, versuchen sie auch zu kriegen. Zum Flugzeug gibt es Codes, die man oben als Pilot einstellen kann, wenn man einen Notfall hat oder wenn man gerne Priorität haben möchte. Wenn ich diesen Code eintippe, dann dauert das glaube ich keine 20 Sekunden. Dann geht bei Flightradar24 ein Tweet raus, dass der Flug hat.
Irgendetwas braunes, das habe ich mehrfach mitbekommen in den letzten Krisen. Ich war immer sehr schnell dabei, das ist auch echt ein neues Gefühl. Aber bevor wir jetzt auf die ganzen Details des Fluges und der Fliegerei im Allgemeinen angehen, würde mich natürlich auch erst mal ein bisschen interessieren, wie du da den Weg überhaupt hingefunden hast. Also kommt jetzt die Story mit, dass du schon als kleines Kind immer die Augen am Himmel hattest?
Interessanterweise nicht. Bei mir ist das fast so vom Schmunzeln. Bei mir hat sich mein Vater beworben für mich. Ja, der hat mir so ein Zettel hingelegt, sagt hier, guck mal, da ist was ganz Tolles. Das wollte er wohl mal immer werden oder hat er auch erzählt oder geträumt davon. Dann hat er gesagt, vielleicht wird das ja mein Sohn. Er hat mir so ein Zettel hingeschrieben und gesagt, unterschreib das doch mal, das ist bestimmt gut für dich. Und ich so naja gut und hab es unterschrieben und dann bin ich irgendwann hingefahren und hab die Entschuldungstests alles gemacht und bin jetzt hier sozusagen. Aber es hat mich relativ schnell die Leidenschaft gepackt. Also das ging dann doch relativ zügig.
Aber vorher hast du überhaupt keinen Bezug dazu gehabt oder?
Nicht wirklich, nein. Außer, dass man auch mal geflogen ist mit den Eltern, die irgendwo in den Urlaub sind oder irgendwas. Aber sonst keinen Bezug.
Wo hättest du dich denn beworben, wenn Vater nicht auf die Idee gekommen wäre?
Ich war eingeschrieben in der Uni für Mathematik.
Okay, dann wär das was geworden.
Um Gottes Willen, nee, da wär nie was geworden. Ein bisschen programmiert hab ich auch früher damals, aber das hab ich schon wieder längst vergessen.
Superdad.
Ich war glaube ich irgendwie in Hamburg 1984 auf einem Chaos-Computer-Konkurs. Ja, da war ich. Mit Modems noch irgendwie und das ganze Programm mit Datenclose. Ah, ja, C64. Nee, da war ich noch nicht, aber...
Da waren wir schon auf der gleichen Veranstaltung wahrscheinlich.
Das kann sein, das kann sein. Aber ich bin dann irgendwie in eine andere Richtung gegangen. Bin da falsch abgebogen vielleicht oder richtig, keine Ahnung.
Ja, muss ja dann schon kurz vorher sozusagen diese ganze Laufbahn ins Auge gefasst haben.
Also bei mir konkret...
Wenn du 1985 fliegst, fängt man ja nicht eine Woche vorher an mit einer Ausbildung.
Nein, aber da hab ich noch privat geflogen. Also da fing es an...
Ach so, in dem Moment hattest du sozusagen schon...
Also die Geschichte war... Genau, wie Details... Also es war so, dass mein Abi neigte sich zu Ende. Und mein Vater, der hatte, war Privatpilot, hatte eine Privatpilot-Lizenz in Amerika, Worms. Und hatte mir die Gelegenheit gegeben, hier bewirb dich mal, das Schreiben kam zurück, weil noch zu jung hast du auch keine Bundeswehr. Du musst erst, wenn du die Bundeswehr hast, dann kannst du erst weitermachen. Und in der Zwischenzeit, weil ich ein halbes Jahr Pause hatte, hat er mich sozusagen nach Amerika geschickt, zu seinem Bruder dort, der auch gute Verbindung zur kleinen allgemeinen Luftfahrt hatte. Und dort hab ich praktisch ganz normal mit PPL, also das hattest du ja schon mal hier in deinem CRE, angefangen kleine Cessnas versuchen zu lernen zu fliegen und hab's auch geschafft. Und so bin ich praktisch dann und dann hab ich sofort in dem Moment Blut geleckt und dann fand ich auch toll, dass ich das unterschreiben durfte bei meinem Vater. Und während der Bundeswehr hab ich mich dann beworben bei einer Bremer Flugschule. Keiner sagte den Namen, von wem die betrieben wird, aber wir wissen es mittlerweile alle. Und hab die Einschränkungstests dort geschafft und hab dort von der Pike an wieder, obwohl ich praktisch schon Flugerfahrung mitbekommen hab, von der Pike an das Fliegen wieder gelernt. Und fertig mit Ausflug lernen müssen sozusagen. War aber schon mal ganz hilfreich. Das war sehr hilfreich, wobei der Angang ist extrem professionell. Viel strikter, viel schon ausgerechnet auf den späteren Job. Also bei der Allgemeinen Luftfahrt war eigentlich so genau präzise beschrieben, wann man was in welcher Flugphase genau tun muss. Und dort war von Anfang an darauf eingelegt, dass selbst die kleine Cessna wurde so geflogen wie später ein großer Jet, dass man die Handgriffe von Anfang an lernt. Und bis ich dann das drauf hatte, konnte ich genauso, oder konnten die anderen genauso gut fliegen wie ich auch. Also da war das rein haptische auf demselben Level relativ schnell.
Das heißt, diese ganze Pilotenausbildung ist von vornherein auf Protokolle, Abläufe, Systematiken.
In meiner Firma war das von vornherein eine solide Grundausbildung gemacht worden. Und wenn wir gerade über die Lizenzen reden, über den Werdegang, das hat man mittlerweile so gemacht, dass es reine Pilotlizenzen gibt, die wirklich nur darauf ausgelegt sind, später in einem Airliner mit einem mehr Mann, also mit mindestens zwei Mann Cockpit zu fliegen. Also die sind, die nennen sich auch ganz andere, haben einen anderen Namen, Multi-Pilot-Lizenz. Da fängt man zwar auch auf kleinen Flugzeugen an, aber das Ganze ist von vornherein so drauf trainiert, dass ich mit der Lizenz, wenn ich sie am Ende fertig habe, nur große Jets fliegen kann, nur in einem zwei Mann Cockpit. Wenn ich dann anfangen würde, ein kleines Flugzeuges zu fliegen, muss ich Zusatzkomponenten mir dazu machen. Das dürfte ich gar nicht. Und damals war das noch so, da hat man angefangen, auf kleinen Flugzeugen zu lernen, abschließen. Man war dann ein Privatpilot und dann war man ein kommerzieller CPL, ein kommerzieller Pilot, und dann hat man die LISI-Lizenz, dann irgendwann im Laufe der Karriere, gekriegt den Airliner Transport.
Also CPL heißt?
Commercial Pilot License. Genau, sehr englisch-lastig. Wenn ich auch gerne hier im Podcast mal Englisch rede, dann möge mir das sein.
Das wär nicht das erste Mal.
Genau.
Nee, ist ja klar. Ich meine, das ist ja vielleicht überhaupt, abgesehen jetzt vielleicht vom Astronauten, mehr noch eigentlich als das Astronautentum, würde ich sagen. Weil da spielt auch Russisch genauso eine große Rolle. Aber im Luftverkehr ist ja Englisch einfach die Linguafranca überhaupt.
Genau, Englisch ist das. Es gibt mehrere offizielle Luftfahrtsprachen. Also Französisch gehört dazu, Spanisch, Englisch, Russisch und auch Deutsch. Aber wir Deutschen haben uns entschlossen, im oberen Luftraum, wenn es darum geht, wo nur Leute, die wirklich für Geld fliegen sozusagen, dass dort nur Englisch gesprochen wird.
Wie deutsch ist eine offizielle Luftfahrtsprache?
Eigentlich ja.
Was heißt denn das dann?
Dass ich, dass man, das bedeutet eigentlich nur, dass ich, wenn ich nach Instrumentenflug regeln, im oberen Luftraum unterwegs bin, dass ich mit den Fluglotsen ganz offiziell eigentlich auch meine Verkehrsfreigaben, also die ganzen Gespräche, die ich mit den Fluglotsen führe, dass ich die auch in Deutsch führen dürfte theoretisch.
Wenn der das versteht.
Das sind in Deutschland auch alles Deutsche, ja.
Also immer vorausgesetzt, dass beide das können. Wäre es zulässig, kann einem keiner einen Strick draus geben.
Genau, aber Deutschland hat gesagt, und das finde ich sehr vernünftig, die haben gesagt, nee, wir sprechen alle Englisch, dann kann jeder jeden verstehen. Und so kann auch jeder Pilot, hört den Flugverkehr des anderen Piloten, die bei ihm in der Nähe sind, und kann sich dadurch auch sehr schnell ein Bild machen, wo ist der andere oder was geht da gerade los und was passiert da gerade.
Das ist sozusagen eigentlich nur auf dem Papier und findet nicht statt oder findet nur in Deutschland nicht statt. Lass mich raten, in Frankreich wird auch mal französisch geredet. Wir kennen ja unsere Nachbarn.
Ja genau, also das ist manchmal auch sehr, sehr, sehr störend. Also auch im Anflug selbst. Und im rein oberen Luftraum, da ist es eigentlich relativ entspannt, da wird wenig geredet, aber im Anflug, wo man eng gestaffelt wird von den Fluglotsen, um möglichst effektiv die Flughäfen aufzunutzen, und dann hört man Französisch und in einer kriegt eine Landefreigabe, eine Startfreigabe und du weißt immer gar nicht, war da jetzt auf derselben Bahn, wo ich jetzt auch gerade landen will, kriegt er jetzt auch die Startfreigabe. Ist das möglicherweise so ein Konflikt irgendwo? Passiert ja auch nichts. Aber es ist halt...
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch dazu, würde ich jetzt mal fast unterstellen, dass die französischen Piloten dann am Ende auch im Englischen nicht so reinhauen.
Nee, das wäre ja nur dann, wenn sie nur in der... Aber auch die fliegen ja irgendwann ja außerhalb Frankreichs.
Na klar, wenn die Praxis durchmischt ist, dann legt man vielleicht weniger Wert drauf. Ich weiß nicht. Würde ich jetzt von Deutschen auch so erwarten. Also wenn jemand, ein Deutscher, konsequent immer auf Englisch festgenagelt wird, dann ist, glaube ich, der Druck, das auch ordentlich zu tun. Größer, als wenn man so das Gefühl hat, man kommt die Hälfte der Zeit auch ohne weg.
Nee, das kriegen die auch gut hin. Also das will ich jetzt nicht unterstellen, nein.
Hat man denn überhaupt geprüft, sozusagen, auf seine sprachlichen Qualitäten? Also nicht nur, dass man die Worte kann, sondern auch so Pronunciation, Verständigung, Verständnis?
Hat lange gedauert, aber es wird jetzt gemacht. Die Amerikaner haben immer schon so ein bisschen, wenn einer, in Amerika haben viele Leute fliegen gelernt, ich ja auch. Und da hat man von vornherein so ein bisschen Englisch einfach lernen müssen, sonst kam man da überhaupt gar nicht zurecht. Und da gibt es auch eine Funklizenz. Das war mehr oder weniger nur, hat man gelesen. Und wenn man das lesen konnte, dann kann man ja auch sprechen. Und dann hat man das unterschrieben. Mittlerweile ist man dann doch soweit, dass es international immer das Problem ist, wenn man eine Regelung einsetzen will, die verbindlich für alle geht und die ja weltweit war, Luftverkehr ist weltweit, dann dauert es lange, bis das durchgesetzt wird. Und ich glaube, das hat 20 Jahre gedauert. Und jetzt gibt es einen Language Proficiency Test in verschiedenen Level, die eingeteilt sind. Und man muss halt gewiss, Level 4 wird bei mir vorausgesetzt, dass ich den habe. Ein Native Speaker, das wärst du vielleicht, der kriegt dann Level 5. Die haben es natürlich einfacher. Die müssen auch keine Wiederholungsprüfung ablegen. Ich muss jetzt alle drei Jahre eine Wiederholungsprüfung ablegen. Oder was war ja? Ne, drei Jahre eine Wiederholungsprüfung einlegen, dass ich Englisch sprechen kann. Ich hab sogar einen Sprachprüferlehrgang mal gemacht, um das zu unterscheiden, ob einer Level 4, 3 oder 2 hat. Aber wenn man davon aus... Ich hab Sprachhöherproben gehört von einem, der Level 4 hat. Das würden wir schon als furchtbar schlechtes Englisch empfinden. Also in der Regel sprechen wir alle deutlich besser Englisch. Das ist halt die Minimumanforderung, die man braucht. Das ist ein Wortschatz von, keine Ahnung, 4.000 Worte oder irgendwas. Das ist immer der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner.
Wie gesagt, Wortschatz ist ja das eine. Das andere ist halt einfach die, ich sag mal, unreflektierte Aussprache.
Aber um jetzt mal zum Thema zurückzukommen, die Franzosen können auch Englisch. Man hat das Gefühl, die haben meistens einen schweren Akzent. Aber wenn man auch Deutsche manchmal hört im Englischen, das ist auch furchtbar. Und auch Spanier, die sprechen auch gerne Spanisch mal im Funk. Die sind aber konsequenter im Anwenden von Englisch. Das finde ich ganz gut. In Russland, in manchen Gebieten, da gibt es manche Flughäfen, da gibt es keinen, der Englisch spricht. Die sprechen wirklich dann nur Russisch. Das wird mehr und mehr langsam, langsam besser.
Da gibt es keinen Englisch.
Ja, aber da fliegt dann auch kein Mensch von uns hin. Da gibt es keinen internationalen Luftverkehr. Und bei den Chinesen genauso. Es gibt also dort Provinzflughäfen, da fliegen zwar Fluggesellschaften hin, aber das sind halt nur Russische oder Chinesische, weil da spricht auch kein Mensch Englisch oder kaum. Andersrum angesagt, als wir anfingen nach Russland, mehr nach Novosibirsk, wo wir hingeflogen sind, hinzufliegen. Novosibirsk hatte englische Fluglotsen, aber auf der Strecke teilweise gab es keine englisch sprechenden Fluglotsen. Und dann haben wir einen ehemaligen Interflugpiloten mit drin gehabt im Ruhestand, der für uns dann den Funk gemacht hat. Natürlich auch gegen Saléa, klar, logisch.
Aber er war nicht im einlichen Sinne als Pilot, sondern sozusagen nur so als dritter Mann.
Der war als dritter Mann mit dabei und nur wegen dem Funkverkehr.
Wie lange hat sich die ganze Ausbildung dann letztlich in Anspruch genommen, bis du wirklich das große Eisen übernehmen durftest? Und was war das dann?
Zwei Jahre, bis ich auf dem Groß-Eisen saß, sozusagen. Und die Einweisung dauerte vielleicht auch noch mal so drei Monate. Also so zwei Jahre, drei Monate, vier Monate, bis man dann komplett fertig war und dann ohne irgendeinen Ausbilder, der nebeneinsitzt oder hinter einem sitzt, die Reise fortsetzen konnte. Zwei Jahre und ein paar Monate.
Echt, so von Null?
Von Null, ja. Aber das ist auch wirklich durchgehend dann. Also man hat dann keine Zeit nebenbei noch irgendwie, Job zu machen, Geld zu verdienen. Deswegen ist auch der finanzielle Aspekt bei einer Ausbildung auch zur heutigen Zeit immer sehr groß geschrieben, weil das alles relativ teuer ist.
Also teuer im Sinne von, dass man für diese Ausbildung bezahlen muss?
Ja, wenn man jetzt so gängigen Flugschulen gibt, je nachdem welche Schiene, welche Lizenz man haben möchte, also diesen MPL, Multipilot Listens von einem, von R, die werden von Flugschulen betrieben, die mit Fluggesellschaften kooperieren. Es geht irgendwo bei 70.000 los. Und wenn man eine Lizenz komplett fertig haben möchte, einen ATPL, wo auch schon, wo man nicht mehr diesen Linienflugteil mit drin hat, also diese andere Art von Lizenz, von der ich gesprochen habe, die es früher gab. Airline Transportpilot-Pleisung. Dann geht das bis zu 100.000, 110.000 Euro plus die Zeit, die man dafür aufwenden muss.
Die man selber sozusagen einbringen muss und wo sich jetzt auch keine Fluggesellschaft beteiligt und die man auch so nicht wiederkriegt?
Also bei der Bremer Flugstufe, wenn ich das nur sagen darf, da beteiligt sich schon die Fluggesellschaft mit dabei. Wenn man den gesamten Kostenpartner übernehmen würde, dann reden wir auch von 120.000, 125.000 Euro, die das irgendwie, den gesamten Projekt kostet. Das ist halt eine Ausbildung, Geld, das die Firma reinsteckt in sein eigenes Personal, um das dann sozusagen gut und sicher so hinzubiegen, wie sie es gerne haben, hätte. Genau, das kam in letzter Zeit noch mal ein bisschen viel in die Presse rein, weil diese Lizenzen haben halt, sind so ein bisschen, haben das Problem, dass man, dass die zusammen mit einer Fluggesellschaft, eine zugelassene Flugschule muss zusammen in einer zugelassenen Fluggesellschaft zusammenarbeiten, weil diese Lizenz, diese MPA-Lizenzen, Multi-Pilot-Lizenzen, die sind schneller und kostengünstiger zu kriegen. Allerdings muss man sie denn auch auf einer Airline beenden. Wenn die Airline aber gerade sagt, wir stellen euch nicht ein, dann habe ich zwei Jahre Ausbildung investiert und nicht unbedingt gleich bezahlt, aber investiert, aber kann meinen Job nicht zu Ende kriegen, weil ich in der Fluggesellschaft, weil die gerade sagen, wir stellen gerade keine Leute ein, kann es dann eine Ausbildung auch nicht zu Ende bringen.
Dann muss man warten oder?
Genau, warten.
Aber man kann schon irgendwann...
Ja, aber nur in der Fluggesellschaft, für die das gedacht war. Man kann ja nicht sagen, gut, dann gehe ich halt zu irgendeinem anderen. Das geht so einfach nicht.
Aber deine Ausbildung war schon eine, wo du im Prinzip am Ende hättest, überall hingeben können.
Genau, hätte ich überall hingeben können.
Okay.
Und solche Ausbildungen kann man auch noch machen, aber man muss dann halt ordentlich Geld mitbringen. Und dann steht man auf dem Markt und hat eine Lizenz. Man hat aber, ich habe praktisch das Wissen und die Lizenz, um mich im Flugzeug, um den Luftraum bewegen zu dürfen. Aber ich brauche immer noch eine Einweisung auf das spätere Flugzeugmuster. Das kostet auch nochmal Geld. Und wenn ich das nicht habe und auch keine Flugsturten, keine Erfahrung drauf, dann sind trotzdem die Einstellungsbedingungen relativ schwer. Oder wenig bezahlt, sodass man... Das Geld erst mal lange braucht, bis man das wieder reinkriegt.
Und war das schwierig? Also war diese Ausbildung schwierig? War das eine große Herausforderung? Also musste man da schwitzen? Oder ist es so, dass man irgendwie die Zeit hat und den Fleiß hat und nicht ganz auf den Kopf gefallen ist, dann passt das schon?
Also wir haben damals einen Einstellungstest gemacht, der relativ anspruchsvoll war. Das war über fünf Tage plus zwei Tage vorweg. Nochmal, ob man überhaupt in den fünf-Tages-Test reinkommen kann. Und da wurde sehr viel. Räumliches Verständnis, Mathematik, schnelles Denken, aber auch schon angefangen mit Psychologie. Was ist das denn einer? Ist das überhaupt teamfähig? Und so ein bisschen wurde das abgetestet. Damals wurde sogar noch ein Sporttest gemacht. Da musste ich schwimmen und tauchen und so was. Das wird alles schon lange nicht mehr gemacht. Da war vielleicht ein bisschen ein Militär angelehnt oder Bundeswehr. Ich weiß auch nicht warum. Und zum Abschluss wurde dann auch medizinisch überprüft, ob da auch alles in Ordnung ist. Man muss halt gesund sein. Es gibt gewisse Aspekte, die wurde getestet mit Licht, ob ich irgendwo latent heimlich ein Appletiker bin oder irgendwie sowas in Atem. Weil das sind so Ausfallkriterien, das geht nicht. Aber dieser Test war letztendlich nur dazu da, um festzustellen, schafft derjenige das auch. Also erst mal ist der psychologische Profil okay, passt, ist derjenige gesellschaftsfähig für uns. Und der andere Test, ich würde ihn mal eher so nennen, er war darauf ausgerechnet festzustellen, schafft derjenige das in den zwei Jahren, den ganzen Stoff zu verstehen. Und in der knappen Flugsturtenanzahl ist natürlich alles geschafft, ob er das geschafft hat, die Auswahlungen hinzukriegen. Nicht, dass wir denn noch mehr Zusatzsturten, Zusatzsturten reinstecken müssen in diesen jungen Mann oder Frau. Und am Ende wird das dann zu teuer. Worauf ich hinaus will, eigentlich kann das jeder. Man muss so unterschiedlich lang vielleicht brauchen, bis man die Skills oder das Wissen sich angeeignet hat.
Wie hoch war denn der Frauenanteil unter den Pilotenbewerbern damals?
Ich glaube, wir hatten, ich sag, damals war das irgendwie unter drei Prozent oder irgendwas. Mittlerweile ist es deutlich mehr, aber es war die Flugstufe vor zwei Jahren, hatte sie erst wieder geöffnet nach einer längeren Pause. Und da waren erst überhaupt Frauen sozusagen angenommen worden. Groß wurde das in der Presse gefeiert oder bekannt gegeben. Vorher war es halt nicht, nicht weil sie es nicht konnten, sondern weil man diesen ganzen Sachen wie Schwangerschafts-Motorshorts und alles, schätze ich mal, wollte man bestimmt damals auch aus dem Weg gehen.
Von welchem damals reden wir jetzt gerade?
Wir reden von bis 1981 war das so, dass man nur...
Was Frauenrechte betrifft, auch noch Dark Ages.
Ja, genau. Aber mittlerweile ist es total selbstverständlich und es ist überhaupt kein Thema mehr.
Aber ist jetzt auch noch nicht so, dass das jetzt so 50-50 wäre?
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Nein, das ist es nicht.
Wo ist es angekommen?
Aber wo ist es schon 50-50?
Na ja, ich weiß, aber es ist trotzdem immer interessant, zu sehen, wie es sich ändert.
Ich weiß nicht, wie hoch die Bewerbungsquoten sind oder so was, aber es ist deutlich mehr. Also bestimmt nicht 50, 50 Prozent. Also von den Neuanfängern und Bewerbern. Wie gesagt, Bewerben tun sich immer noch Leute. Momentan geht es aber nicht weiter.
Also so gefühlt, man trifft es ja eigentlich am laufenden Meter auf Piloten.
Ja, genau. Aber das denkt auch, die kommen aus der Generation, wo es nur ganz wenig Frauen gab. Wenn es 20 Prozent sind, würde ich das als viel empfinden.
Also man fliegt ja nie allein.
Ja, man fliegt nie allein.
Sondern in der Regel zu zweit.
In der Regel zu zweit, manchmal auch zu dritt.
Und da müsste sich ja im Prinzip diese Quote irgendwie wiederfinden.
Ja, ich habe aber ehrlich gesagt gerade keine Zahl im Kopf. Tut mir leid, aber das ist immer noch unter 10 Prozent. Aber wie gesagt, in den Auswahl, in Bewerbungen und irgendwas, es spielt überhaupt keine Rolle mehr. Jeder kann das. Ich habe nun, wie du auch weißt, Ausbilder getätigt. Und ich kenne keinen, der da irgendwie einen Unterschied gemacht hat. Ob das irgendwie noch so ein bisschen in den Köpfen drin steckt. Vielleicht auch noch ein Thema, wie Männer unter uns. Kann ich nicht unterschreiben, ist nicht so.
Was hast du denn dann, als das dann fertig war? Wo durftest du dich dann draufsetzen?
Genau, ein Karriereweg nochmal. Also der klassische Weg auch jetzt noch, wenn man neu in eine Firma reinkommt, wenn man auch als fertig ausgebildeter Pilot mit so und so vielen Flugstottern irgendwo neu anfängt, auf einem Muster oder auf einem, bei einer Firma ist so, dass man eigentlich zunächst der, gibt es verschiedene Begriffe dafür, der erste Offizier, der Co-Pilot, der zweite Mann, derjenige, der auf dem rechten Sitz ist, dass man da auf dem Sitz erst anfängt. Und so war das auch bei mir. Also ich war erster Offizier, Co-Pilot, zweiter Flugzeugführer, wie man das immer nennt, habe dort angefangen 737 zu fliegen für zwei Jahre. Bei uns in der Firma ist es immer noch so, dass 737 Boeing, CityJet sind tausend davon, die da produziert und immer noch rumfliegen und auch gleichzeitig in der Luft sind. Dann ist es so, dass wenn man ein anderes Flugzeug fliegen müsste, sind die generell ein bisschen nach Kriterien eingeteilt. Also die größeren Flugzeuge sind dann sogenannte Fördermuster, also war dann der Titel dafür, dass man ein nächstgrößeres Flugzeug mit mehr Verantwortung fliegt. Aber auch dort nimmt man zunächst auf den rechten Sitzplatz, ist dort erster Offizier pro Pilot. Der Zeitpunkt, wann man da reinkommen darf, ist in der Regel bei den Firmen auch noch so geregelt, dass man nach Zugehörigkeit, nach Seniorität, nach Dauer in der Firma, wie lange man da arbeitet, dass man dann die Möglichkeit kriegt. Also die Firma sagt dann, pass mal auf, wir brauchen fünf Co-Piloten, dann gucken sie, wer möchte denn, dann heben viele Leute die Arm, sagen, ich würde gerne fliegen, dann gucken sie, aber die ersten drei kommen, das sind die Ältesten, die dürfen jetzt rein. Die sind aber längst bei uns, nicht die Ältesten, die sind aber längst bei uns in der Firma, um dann keine Leistungsorientierung mit reinzubringen. Es soll gerecht ablaufen, aber unser ganzer Job soll nicht leistungsorientiert sein, damit das nicht auf einem sicheren Level bleibt und nicht irgendeiner sich besonders profiliert durch irgendwelche Maßnahmen, damit er dann irgendwie besser ist, weil er immer am wenigsten Sprit verbraucht, weil er wenigstens tankt oder weil er am kostengünstigsten fliegt und dadurch möglicherweise irgendwelche Risiken erzeugt, wird das komplett ausnivelliert und sagt so, du bist noch nicht dran.
Wir kommen alle noch mal dran.
Wir kommen alle noch mal dran, wenn Platz frei ist, sozusagen, wenn kein Wachstum da ist oder kein Bedarf ist, dann bleibt man auch möglicherweise lange da sitzen, wo man gerade sitzt. Also bei mir konkret war das so, ich bin nach zwei Jahren tatsächlich gewechselt, flog Airbus 300, 310. Die flogen als gemeinsames Muster, sind die geflogen. Vor der 737 ging ich auf den Airbus 300, 310er. Das ging nach fünf Jahren. Das war dann wann? Das war mit dem Golfkrieg I. Das war Ende 1991, da war der Airbus quasi neu. Was da relativ neu war, war der Airbus A320. Der Airbus 310, 300, der flog schon seit Mitte der 70er.
Ach, echt? So alt ist der schon?
Ja, der flog zunächst als Dreimann-Cockpit. Dann kam er noch mal.
370?
Ja, genau. Als Dreimann-Cockpit kam er zunächst raus, dann kam er als Zweimal-Cockpit umgebaut, als Dreizehner und der Airbus 300-600 landete sich dann. Da war der Flug-Ingenieur nicht mehr mit an Bord. Modernes Cockpit mit Glas und so. Glas-Cockpit, nehmen wir das hin.
Ich bin mal in dem zweiten A300, der je gebaut wurde, mal geflogen.
In Womit Comet, ne? Genau.
Den sie zum Parabel-Flieger umgebaut haben.
Ja, genau.
Hätte ich jetzt eigentlich besser wissen müssen. Wusste ich aber nicht. So ist es.
Ja, so ein altes Ding bist du geflogen.
Ja, das ist das best gewartetste Flugzeug in der Welt. Haben Sie aber jetzt auch ausgetan?
So, und dann nach fünf Jahren bin ich Airbus 340 geflogen für zweieinhalb Jahre. Und im Jahr 2000 war ich dann lang genug bei der Firma und da gab es eine Stelle frei, dass ich dann nach zehn, zehn und halben Jahren die Gelegenheit hatte, auf dem Linkensitz als richtiger Kapitän oder Flugzeugführer verantwortlicher zu sitzen. Und bin 16 Jahre lang 737 geflogen und jetzt schule ich gerade um auf der Airbus A380. Aber ich habe noch keine echten Flugstunden. Ich kann noch nicht sagen, wie sich das jetzt im echten los schafft. Aber im Simulator habe ich schon. Immerhin schon 15, 20 Flugstunden. Was ist anders?
737 ist ja noch so ein richtiger, das ist ja geradezu Mechanik im Vergleich zum A380, oder?
Ja, aber ich bin ja schon mal 340 geflogen. Das Prinzip ist das gleiche. Mit dem kleinen Side-Stick, der die Steuerbefehle an einem Computer gibt, einem Flight-Control-Computer und der dann für einen die Steuerflächen auslenkt und gleichzeitig noch eine Envelope Protection bietet, also einen Schutz, dass das Flugzeug nicht durch willentlichen Einfluss des Piloten oder durch Bewegung, durch Steuerbewege, Bewegung außerhalb des flugfähigen Zustands kommen kann, so die Theorie. Also wenn alles geht, wenn alles funktioniert sozusagen. Und das hat der A380 auch, aber noch mal weiter zur Perfektion getrieben. Also merkt ihr, mit jedem Generation mehr ist viel mehr eingebaut, was das Flugzeug redondanter, sicherer und teilweise auch noch komfortabler ist für die Flugzeuge.
Und das wurde so an dich herangetragen oder muss man sich dann melden?
Dass man auch hier war und Stellen frei und ich hatte die Gelegenheit und hab die beim Schaufeld gelaufen und hab mich darauf beworben.
Und wie lange musst du da jetzt noch üben? Bist du da, musst du dann wieder auf den rechten Platz oder schon auf den linken?
Ne, das ist interessanterweise natürlich inkonsequent. Nein, ich bin auf dem linken Platz dran. Aber er ist unter Aufsicht. Also ich fliege die ersten drei Monate mit einem anderen Kollegen, der auch eine Einweisung hat, an Ausbilder zu sein, um dann klopfen wir alles ab und werde wieder ordentlich befragt und geguckt, ob ich dann alles richtig mache. Ist sowieso, zwei Mal im Jahr hat man ein Prüfungsflug im Simulator. Das ist eine Prüfung, lebenslang. Da gab man so einen Dokumentarfilm darüber. Man wird das nicht und sitzt da drinnen und sagt, ich kann mich zurücklehnen. Du warst ja nun auch einmal mit im Simulator, dass man alle zwei Jahre, nee schon alle zwei Mal im Jahr, habe ich einen Prüfungsflug im Simulator plus noch mal ein bis mindestens drei mal im Jahr zusätzliche Simulatorflüge, wo ich einfach trainiert werde, wo bestimmte Aspekte nochmal versucht werden, rauszutrainieren. Meistens ist er an irgendwelchen aktuellen Sachen geknüpft oder Sachen, die man sagt, das müssen wir nochmal ein bisschen weiter vertiefen.
Genau, das ist jetzt auch schon, glaube ich, eine Weile her, das ist schon fast ein Jahr her, ne?
Eineinhalb Jahre her.
Ja, wir reden schon seit Ewigkeiten um einen Termin hier rum, um diese Sendung hier mal zu machen. Ich bin froh, dass es jetzt endlich soweit ist. Aber das war natürlich sehr interessant, also da mal drin zu sitzen und so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie eben so ein Flug an sich abläuft. Was ich darüber hinaus sehr interessant fand, war halt sozusagen auch diese Weiterbildungssituation als solche, weil wir haben ja jetzt nicht einfach nur Zeit verbracht und da quasi vor der großen Spielkonsole gesessen, sondern es war ja quasi im Rahmen der Weiterbildung anderer Piloten. Also das ist sozusagen, das gilt jetzt nicht nur für dich, sondern generell alle Piloten, selbst wenn sie irgendwie regelmäßig fliegen, müssen immer wieder in den Simulator rein. Um was dann zu trainieren?
Erstmal müssen sie zwar einmal im Jahr eine sogenannte Prüfung ablegen, die sich im Prinzip fast an den, also wenn ich eine Einweisung bekomme auf einem Flugzeug, wie ich jetzt bekomme auf das Muster, was ich jetzt fliege, endet das nachher mit einer großen Prüfung, ob ich denn alles, die wesentliche Aspekte kenne. Die sind vom Luftfahrtbundesamt oder von den Behörden vorgegeben. Das sind die schwersten Sachen, die ein Flugzeug auftreten kann als Notfall der Triebwerkausfall und beim Start, bei der Landung, Durchstart, Manöver mit einem fehlenden Triebwerk und noch Ausfall wichtiger, komponenten, technische, dass ich die beherrsche. Aber da geht es wirklich nur rein um den technischen, haptischen, prozeduralen Training, dass ich das beherrsche. Und diesen Test, den praktisch macht man zweimal im Jahr, immer wieder neu. Also die Piloten sind immer wieder getestet und geprüft und auch Theoretest gibt es auch noch dabei, einmal im Jahr. Und man versucht dann, die fit zu halten. Sogar ein Sprachtest jetzt alle drei Jahre.
Ja, das fand ich ganz putzig. Man sagt immer so, ja, wo fliegen wir denn heute mal hin? So, sucht sich irgendwie ein schönes Ziel aus.
Das ist da irgendwie alles. Ja, das war im Simulator natürlich. Da war das einfach so, zum Flughafen wesentlich mehr zu. Hier geht es ja wirklich nur um die Situation, die Technik, das Prozedurale.
Ja gut, aber jetzt schalten wir einfach mal ein Triebwerk aus. Ist das noch kaputt? Man merkte richtig einmal, in dem Fall, die Kollegen waren da Herr der Situation, hatte ich so den Eindruck. Also mir ist da nicht aufgefallen, dass da groß gerätselt wurde. Man merkte, dass das alles schon ziemlich tief eingebrannt ist und das jetzt nicht irgendwie wirklich neu war. Andererseits merkt man auch, oder merkte ich, was das für eine Bedeutung hat. Also wie groß der Stellenwert dieser Abläufe ist. Ich kenne das vor allem halt so von der Programmierung her. Mit Erfahrung und so, ein Fehler treten auf. Man guckt halt erst mal so einen Moment und verdreht die Augen. Mit Erfahrung nimmt man mehrere Signale parallel wahr und kann dann eben im Idealfall eine schnelle Einschätzung machen, was jetzt sozusagen die richtige Maßnahme wäre. Das ist natürlich im Flugzeug noch mal sehr viel wichtiger und da kann man sich jetzt auch nicht irgendwie erstmal einen Kaffee machen, sondern da muss sozusagen ja immer die richtige Antwort kommen, vor allem weil eine Fehlanalyse kann ja dann auch dramatische Folgen haben. Wenn man den falschen Schalter legt, dann kann es ja sozusagen noch das Problem verschärfen.
Ja, also nun wird gerade darauf Training sehr viel verlegt, dass man Sachen, die nicht mehr revisibel sind, wenn man sie eingeschaltet, dass man die also wirklich doppelt und dreifach überprüft, bevor man dann oder gemeinsam praktisch die Entscheidung auch sogar handgrifflich teilweise gemeinsam macht, bevor man irgendwelche Systeme da ausschaltet. Und dann wird bei uns auch sehr viel Training darauf ausgelegt und davon gibt es aber auch spezielle Simulator-Missions, die darauf angelegt sind, die Zusammenarbeit zu trainieren. Also auch da gibt es ja praktisch Werkzeuge, mit denen man in einem Team umgehen kann. Das sind natürlich weniger die Soft-Skills, die, wie ich mit einem Problem umgehen, wie ich die Kollegen im Cockpit mit einbeziehe in den Entscheidungsprozess und wie wir den Entscheidungsprozess optimieren. Weil da hat es leider aus Erfahrung halt viele Unfälle oder Vorfälle gegeben. Die auf die Fehlentscheidung eines Einzelnen hervorgeholt oder entstanden sind. Und da sitzen noch mehrere an Bord und die anderen haben es wahrscheinlich besser gewusst und konnten sich nicht einbringen, weil da eine eben die anderen sozusagen nicht zu Wort hat kommen lassen, um das mal als Beispiel zu nennen.
Wodurch bestimmt sich eigentlich, ob zwei oder drei Leute jetzt im Cockpit sitzen?
Also alle Flugzeuge, die in den letzten 25 Jahren gebaut worden sind, die sind zweimal in Cockpits. Die werden mit zwei Personen geflogen, brauchen noch zwei Personen von der Bedienung her. Und der dritte Mann, der gelinglich mit an Bord sitzt, das ist eine Verstärkung, die eingesetzt wird, wenn die Flüge sehr lang sind, über einen bestimmten Strecke oder Zeitraum gehen, sodass man im Flugzeug dann rotiert. Dass der eine mal den Sitz verlassen kann und dann sich eine Runde hinlegt. Die Flugzeuge haben meistens dann auch irgendwo so Kojen, wo man sich dann hinlegen kann und dann auch eine Pause hat von zwei, drei Stunden. Das ist auch vorgeschrieben, da gibt es ganz klare Regelungen. Und dieser dritte Mann, der ist dann zur Start- und Landung, ist jetzt aber mit im Cockpit dran, weil es dann die arbeitsintensivsten Flugphasen sind. Der hat in dem Sinne keine Funktion. Der setzt sich da und funkt oder bedient einen Hebel oder irgendwas. Der sitzt einfach nur mit dabei als zusätzliche Kapazität.
Ausnahmen wie den russischen Übersetzer vorhin. Aber es geht sozusagen einfach nur um Support. Er übernimmt irgendwelche Funktionen und entlastet den Rest?
Nee, er übernimmt keine Funktion. Die ganzen Prozeduren sind darauf abgestimmt, dass man zu zweit arbeitet. Wenn der Dritte mit reinkommt, selbst wenn er noch mit funken soll, oh komm hier mal, funke mal irgendwie mit aus Langweil. Das ist nicht erwünscht. Weil das würde ja, dieser fest eingespielten Prozess, das ist ja immer wieder wiederholt und immer genau gleich soll es ablaufen. Und wenn man dann auch jede Veränderung, die dann doch irgendwie auftritt, dass man die dann auch gleich bemerkt, der soll eigentlich nicht mehr dabei sein. Aber er kann sich natürlich auch einbringen, wenn er merkt, dass hier ist irgendwas oder da ist was kaputt gegangen. Und wenn er merkt, die anderen haben vielleicht, er könnte seine Idee natürlich auch noch mit reinbringen. Natürlich wird er dann benutzt, so ist es nicht, als Ressource.
Aber ich glaube, eine Information, die man sich auf jeden Fall hier nochmal klar machen sollte, ist, du hast es im Prinzip bei jedem Flug oder fast jedem Flug mit einem neuen Co-Piloten zu tun.
Oder Pilotin, um mal jetzt...
Ja, richtig.
Das ist jetzt im Sprachgebrauch so drin.
Genau, also auf jeden Fall, die Mannschaft stellt sich im Prinzip bei jedem Flug zusammen, bis man jetzt so eine explizite Rückflugsituation wahrscheinlich hat, wo man einfach den direkten Anschluss hat. Aber so jeder neue Tag und jedes neue Ziel bedeutet in der Regel irgendjemand.
Es hängt ganz stark davon ab, wie die Airline operiert. Wenn eine Fluggesellschaft nur von einem Standort aus sternförmig irgendwo hinfliegt und abends wieder zu Hause ist, dann ist es in der Tat so, dass je nachdem, wie viele Crews dort stationiert sind an dem einen Platz herum, dass man tatsächlich jeden Tag möglicherweise einen anderen hat. Den hat man vielleicht schon, diesen Monat schon zweimal gehabt, aber jedes Mal kommt man möglicherweise mit einem neuen zusammen. Andere Fluggesellschaften, da sind die Crews drei, vier, fünf Tage gemeinsam unterwegs, weil sie dann verschiedene Stops irgendwo haben, um dann morgens raus den Flieger dann zum Hub wieder zurückzubringen. Und da ist man vielleicht dann schon drei, vier, fünf Tage unterwegs mit denselben Kollegen. Aber generell ja, zumindest wenn man anfängt, ex-Deutschland jetzt auch, Langstrecke jetzt weit hinzufliegen, kann das sein, dass man mit dem Kollegen noch nie geflogen ist. Und trotzdem muss man halt so sagen, dass funktionieren soll wie ein Uhrwerk. Also die Prozeduren sind darauf abgestimmt, dass man gemeinsam miteinander auskommt. Und wenn ich von etwas ganz speziell rede, weiß er auch genau, was ich meine. Also das Wording auch, nicht nur die Prozeduren, sondern auch das Wording, alles ist letztendlich vorgegeben. Und manche Leute können ja sagen, ist das nicht langweilig oder ist das nicht zu strikt oder ist es nicht so einengend? Je mehr ich da drinnen bin, desto dankbarer bin ich dafür. Weil ich will das so haben. Ich will erwarten, was jetzt passiert. Weil Überraschungen will ich ja gar nicht in der Fliegerei. Ich möchte ja, dass es alles so abläuft.
Es muss alles richtig langweilig sein.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen übertrieben, natürlich. Aber ich will ja keine Aufregung haben. Es soll alles entspannt und ruhig ablaufen.
Ich finde es einfach faszinierend, dass man quasi einen Job hat, der auf der einen Seite so enorm hohe Anforderungen hat eigentlich, weil Fehler müssen vermieden werden, sind im Zweifelsfall, wenn sie auftreten, potentiell tödlich. Und zwar nicht nur für einen selbst. Und trotzdem hat man es immer wieder mit anderen Leuten zu tun. Man würde ja erwarten, so ja, hier bei uns in der Firma, das Team kennt sich seit zehn Jahren, sie sind voll aufeinander abgestimmt und so. Und hier tauscht sich das quasi fast täglich oder mindestens wöchentlich. Und trotzdem muss es genauso gut funktionieren.
Genau.
Dann sind wir wieder im Prinzip ganz am Anfang.
Grundausbildung.
Grundausbildung, Protokolle von Anfang an. Also einfach alles so schematisiert, strukturiert und dann eben auch so im Dialog. Was ja auch eine soziale Komponente hat, nehme ich an.
Also Eigenbrötler oder extreme Silberrücken, wie wir sie denn so nennen, die extrem dominant im Komponent sind, sind nicht erwünscht.
Also es schleifen die sich ab, wenn sie überhaupt auftreten. Also kann man so bleiben? Kommt man überhaupt dahin, wenn man so drauf ist?
Es ist meistens so, dass solche Leute, die nicht gerne im Team arbeiten oder extrem dominant sind oder wenig andere Leute hören, die machen dann am Ende auch Arbeitsfehler. Jetzt im Simulator vor allen Dingen, wenn es bei den Prüfungen rangeht. Und es ist oft so, dass man solche Leute dadurch zu einem anderen Verhalten motivieren kann. Ganz einfach, weil du sagst, so kannst du nicht weitermachen. Das geht nicht, weil du merkst, du machst Arbeitsfehler.
Weil man nicht mehr im Dialog ist. Ich selber glaube, man kann das schon hier seit 30 Jahren erwarten. Das ist eher interessant. Das heißt, diese Systematik, diese Arbeitsrepetition und dieses permanente sich selbst und andere überprüfen und eben auch im täglichen Dialog miteinander schleift einen dann sozusagen auch gleich entsprechend ab, wenn man so viele Kanten an der falschen Stelle aufreißt.
Es gibt natürlich verschiedene Charaktere. Wir sind alle Menschen und entsprechend gibt es manche solche mal solche. Das sind nicht alle gleich Geschmack.
Na gut, aber man kann dann sozusagen über diese Differenzen auch mal hinweggehen, solange das Arbeitsprokoll auch eingehalten wird. Das schafft ja dann auch, sagen wir mal, eine Sicherheit jenseits des... Dann kann man das wahrscheinlich einfach ausblenden, oder?
Ja, genau, also so sollte es sein, wollen wir so sagen. Also ich versuch's so beizubringen und versuch so zu sein.
Naja, ich mein, das ist ja... Piloten sind ja schon ein, wie soll ich sagen, so eine...
Pilotinnen auch, ne? Es fällt einem schwer, ne? Es fällt einem schwer. Du sitzt nun am männlichen Gehirn.
Okay, also diese Berufsgruppe hat ja schon einen besonderen Status. Ich meine, da war natürlich so dieser Mythos der frühen Zeit, klar, die Aufbruchszeit und überhaupt...
Die Arbeitsbelastung war auch früher deutlich höher, muss man sagen. Es gab... Ganz früher gab es auch kaum irgendwelche Arbeitszeitregelungen. Da sind die Leute wirklich auch stundenlang im Cockpit gewesen und da gab es keine Schulungen, was dieses, wie nennt es, CRM-Crew, Resource Management, also diese Soft Skills, diese Werkzeuge, mit denen man umzugehen hat, um ein Problem im Team zu lösen, das gab es vorher irgendwie alles gar nicht. Und es hat sich erst so im Laufe der ganzen Geschichte hat sich das herauskristallisiert und wurde dann immer stetig verbessert und ist mittlerweile ja nicht nur so, dass es jetzt große Firmen da schulen, sondern ist auch in die Regularien der Behörden mit reingeflossen, dass man solche Schulungen machen muss und haben muss. Und ein Lernprozess, der stetig immer stattfindet.
Kommen wir doch mal auf den Flugverkehr jenseits der Pilotenkanzel. Weil wir wollen ja jetzt hier nicht nur sozusagen über diese Perspektive reden, auch wenn deine Perspektive natürlich jetzt eine besonders, soll ich sagen, dass eine Position aus dem Cockpit heraus ist. Aber da blickt man natürlich vieles, also an vielen Prozessen eben auch aktiv beteiligt. Natürlich spielen auch noch andere Gruppen und Organisationen hier eine große Rolle. Um so einen Flug durchzuführen und Linienflüge im Besonderen ist ja eine extrem große personelle und technische Infrastruktur vorderlich und natürlich auch hier in den letzten Jahrzehnten aufgebaut worden. Das fängt natürlich mit den Flughäfen an. Und natürlich auch den Lotsen, die im Prinzip die Partner sind, um einfach das Ganze zu bewerkstelligen. Wie ist denn dieses Gesamtmodell aufgestellt, wenn man jetzt mal zumindest von der deutschen oder europäischen Situation ausgeht? Wer betreibt das sozusagen? Also von Flughäfen weiß man, dass sie weitgehend privat betrieben werden, in den meisten Fällen zumindest. Aber für das Lotsentum gilt das ja nicht in dem Sinne, oder?
Du weißt ja nicht, wie das in anderen Ländern sind, aber in Deutschland ist immer noch der Arbeitgeber. Für die Fluglotsen ist immer noch der Bund. Ich glaube, der Bund ja. Und die DFS wurde schon vor langer Zeit ausgegliedert. Weil bis vor 20 oder 15 Jahren wurden die Fluglotsen nach Beamtenvergütung bezahlt. Und das war wohl irgendwann nicht mehr zeitgemäß und entsprach nicht den Anforderungen, man hatte nicht mehr genügend Leute gekriegt für das Salär, die den Anforderungen genügen müssen, weil auch die müssen eine umfangreiche Schulung und Qualifikation hinlegen, damit sie da sind, wo sie sind und deswegen haben wir die DFS gegründet und dementsprechend auch, um auch andere Perspektiven für die Fluglotsen zu bieten. Aber mehrheitlich einkümmert ist immer noch der Bund, glaube ich. Stimmt das?
Genau, ein sogenanntes beliehendes Unternehmen und trotzdem Teil der Luftverkehrsverwaltung. Also vorher war es die BFS, also Bundesanscheid für Flugsicherung und jetzt ist das sozusagen so eine GmbH, aber die letzten Endes auch der staatlichen Struktur unterliegt. Da hört man ja immer mal wieder von den Fluglotsen, dass sie doch auch über hohe Belastungen zu klagen haben. Der Flugverkehr ist natürlich enorm angestiegen. Ich kann das nicht einschätzen.
Das ist natürlich auch jetzt nicht mein Thema. Ich kenne natürlich einige Fluglotsen und ich weiß, dass jeder Kollege seinen eigenen Arbeitsbereich hat. Luftraumsektionen, die er kontrolliert, die den ein- und ausfliegenden Verkehr sozusagen betreut, Luftverkehrsvergaben erteilt. Auch für diesen Bereich braucht er eine Zulassung. Also man kann einmal Fluglose werden und dann braucht man auch für den bestimmten Bereich eine Zulassung, dass man sich genau mit den regionalen Begebenheiten des Luftraums auskennt, also die Wegpunkte kennt und vielleicht auch Dinge, die am Boden sind oder so. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Wie gesagt, das ist überhaupt nicht mein Thema. Und ich glaube, man ist nur unterteilt in Radar-Lotser, also die am Radar-Bildschirm sind und welche, die am Tower sind, die den Flugverkehr an den Flughäfen Seuche kontrollieren. Das sind zwei verschiedene Qualifikationen, die da sind. Und auch, glaube ich...
Also Radar heißt sozusagen der gesamte Luftraum der zugeteilten Region und die anderen spezifisch der Verkehr des jeweiligen zugeteilten Flughafens.
Genau. Wobei, also ein Radar-Lotse, der wirklich nur Radar... Der sitzt in einem großen Raum, wo viele Radar-Bildschirme sind und kontrolliert von dort aus die Flugzeuge, die bei ihm auf dem Radarschirm erscheinen. Ein Flug-Lotse, ein Tower-Lotse, der hat einen Tower, hat auch einen Radarschirm, weil er natürlich auch im Nebel manchmal ist mit seinem Turm. Und der kontrolliert auch viel nach Sicht. Der überprüft, dass die Freigaben, die er gerade erteilt hat, du darfst auf die Startbahn rollen oder du darfst noch nicht auf die Startbahn rollen, dass die auch eingehalten werden und keiner irgendwie auf die Bahn rollt. Also die gucken auch viel raus.
Ja, macht schon Sinn, dass wir so einen exponierten Turm haben.
Ja, genau. Aber deswegen wird es auch immer dann, wenn Nebel ist, starker Nebel ist und die Fluglosen halt nicht so sehr auf Sicht arbeiten können, die die Staffelungswerte für den einzelnen Flugzeugen dann vergrößert werden müssen, weil alles doppelt und dreifach durch Systeme, automatische Systeme prüft wird, ob derjenige auch wirklich von der Startbahn gerollt ist und der nächste auch sicher reinrollen, landen kann in den sicheren Bereich der Scharten-Landebahn. Dann erhöhen sich meistens die Staffelungswerte zwischen den einzelnen Flugzeugen, wenn wirklich schlechtes Wetter ist, Nebel ist und dann arbeitet der Flughafen nicht mehr so effektiv. Dann gibt es meistens Verspätung.
Fluglotsen sind ja im Prinzip dann genau solche Mitstreiter wie Co-Piloten.
Nö, das nicht.
Na, mit denen muss man sich ja auch irgendwie verständigen. Der Co-Pilot muss sich ja auch mit dem auseinandersetzen. Na klar, ich meinte jetzt schon in dem Sinne einer bidirektionalen Beziehung, aber in diesem Systemflug ist es ja auch Teil des Protokolls und so, wie man eben mit seinem Nebeneinander die ganze Zeit ein Protokoll fährt, ein spezifisches, gibt es auch gegenüber den Fluglotsen.
Ja klar, da gibt es ganz standardisierte Phrasologien auch, wie man was erreichen möchte, wenn ich eine Sinkflugfreigabe bekomme oder haben möchte oder wie ich eine Freigabe bekomme, eine bestimmte Höhe zu halten oder irgendwas in der Art. Das sind alles standardisierte Phrasologien, die ich anwenden müsste oder sollte. Nicht weil ich sie sonst nicht verstehen kann oder sowas, sondern meistens, um selbst bei schlechten Funkverbindungen genau zu verstehen, was der Kollege von mir weiß. Also jeder kennt zum Beispiel so Wörter, die er vielleicht schon mal gehört hat, wenn man sagt nicht im Englischen nein, sondern man sagt neiner. Damit man das mit dem deutschen nein, was vielleicht eventuell auch irgendwie über den Äther rauschen könnte, damit man das mit dem nicht verwechselt.
Nein, also im Sinn neun.
Ja, also wenn ich sage descent to flight level 90, sage ich nicht 90, sondern 90. Damit das dann auch klar und deutlich erkennt wird. Genauso wie im Deutschen gäbe es das Vergleich, dass ich nicht sage fünf, sondern Fünif, um das Fünif irgendwie, um das selbst bei schlechten Funkverkehr, das Fünif besser rauszuhören. Also solche simplen Sachen gibt es, die man lernt anzuwenden. Das kommt genau daher auch, wenn ich Buchstaben dann klar und deutlich...
Das benutzt man auch am laufenden Meter.
Das benutzt man... Muss ich gerade überlegen? Bestimmt. Ich sag mal bestimmt. Also ich kenne es definitiv, ja. Also das ist... Ja, ja, genau. Also gerade Flug, es gibt Korridor- oder Flugwege, Flugstraßen, die sind mit Buchstaben und Zahlen benannt. Wenn ich da eine Freigabe kriege auf diesen oder eine Umänderung oder ich möge jetzt bitte anders fliegen und ich soll jetzt auf den Flugweg fliegen, dann krieg ich so einen Airway, wie er heißt, genannt. Da wird er mir genauso auch genannt, mit Buchstabenkommission.
Abba, Zulu, Five to Niner oder irgendwie so was.
Mit denen ich rede?
Relevant sind sozusagen für den Gesamtablauf, abgesehen davon, dass es natürlich hunderte und tausende Tätigkeiten im Flughafen gibt. Aber sagen wir mal jetzt so eine von diesen großen Gruppen, die man jetzt noch so ein bisschen im Kopf haben sollte, wenn es um das tägliche Miteinander geht.
Also am täglichen Miteinander, gelegentlich redet man, wenn der Flug anfängt, wollen wir mal da anfangen oder irgendwas in der Art, wenn der...
Ja, da wollte ich langsam so ein bisschen hinkommen. Ich wollte nur noch jetzt fragen, ob wir noch etwas vergessen haben sozusagen.
Also wir reden konkret mit, da rede ich auch mit dem Bodenpersonal, welches den Flieger unten belädt, welches den Flieger zum Abrollen bereit macht. Mit dem rede ich konkret direkt. Dann gibt es noch die Apron-Controller, die Vorfeldkontrolle, mit denen rede ich auch. Die geben mir die Freigaben, die Rollwege, welche abrollen zu haben und vielleicht gelegentlich nochmal mit dem Dispatcher, also mit dem, der den Flugplan erstellt hat, mit dem rede ich auch manchmal. Aber das wär so, es sei denn, ich hab noch irgendwelche zusätzlichen Sachen, da können wir später vielleicht noch aufkommen, Sachen, mit denen man, es gibt noch andere Leute, mit denen ich reden kann in der Luft sozusagen. Und natürlich ganz schwerwiegend auch natürlich die Flugleiter, der ist ein wesentlicher Teil der Kombination, findet auch mit denen statt. Weil mit denen muss man sich koordinieren.
Vielleicht bevor wir mal wirklich mal ins Flugzeug einsteigen, wird mich noch mal so ein bisschen interessieren, wie es organisatorisch noch aufgebaut ist. Also was wir glaube ich schon erwähnt hatten am Rande war so, es gibt halt ein Luftfahrtbundesamt, das sozusagen für das Flugverkehrswesen zuständig ist. Und ich weiß nicht, für was noch alles, Zulassungen auch? Also sind die auch sozusagen bei den...
Die für die Lizenzen, Zulassung der Flughäfen, Zulassung der Flugzeuge. Auch wenn ein Flugzeug neu gebaut wird in irgendeiner Art, hat das auch ein Wort mitzureden, überprüft, dass alle Vorschriften, alle Sachen, die in den Texten drin sind, Gesetzestexten, Konstruktionsanweisungen, alles, dass die eingehalten werden und verlangt auch Überprüfungen und überprüft einen auch regelmäßig, ob die ganzen Sachen genau ausgefüllt werden. Und auch Flugunfalluntersuche macht auch das Luftfahrtbundesamt eine Unterteilung von denen.
Das ist also recht groß, würde ich mal fast meinen, das LBA, oder? Also die haben auf jeden Fall eine Menge Aufgaben.
Die haben eine Menge Aufgaben auf jeden Fall, ja.
Und gibt es noch weitere Organisationen, die jetzt da relevant sind oder wird es danach schon europäisch?
Also danach wird es schon europäisch, glaube ich. Die Flugsicherung, das Luftfahrtbundesamt arbeitet oder ist natürlich auch, überprüft die Flugsicherung, dass die, meine ich zumindest, dass die auch ordnungsgemäß ihre Aufgaben ausführt. Auch dort die Lizenzen etc., alles, was dazu gehört, denke ich mir. Also so erwarte ich das, aber weiß ich jetzt nicht genau. Und genau, darüber ist dann das Luftfahrtbundesamt mit der EASA, das ist die nächste höchste Stufe, Europäer, also Europäische Luftfahrtamt, kann man das so sagen, mit denen sie nicht unterstellt sind, aber zumindest mit denen gemeinsame Regelungen für ganz Europa erstellen. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch die weltweite Organisation, die das koordiniert. Da kann man natürlich nicht sagen, dass es das weltweite Luftfahrtbundesamt ist, das irgendwie alles Befehle ergeben, Teile erkennen oder Gesetze erlassen kann. Die ergeben dann nur noch, teilen dann nur noch Empfehlungen. Das ist die ICAO, International Civil Aviation Organization, ist in Montreal. Und die erstellen die obersten Empfehlungen und Zusammenarbeiten. Die wurden, glaube ich, was steht das, 44 oder so gegründet. Und da hat man sich dann die Grundrechte, die jeder Flugzeugführer hat, welche Rechte und Pflichten hat, die sind da grundsätzlich mal aufgeschrieben worden. Und nach denen richtet sich das Ganze, der ganze Luftverkehr.
Das heißt, das sind auch so im Wesentlichen die beteiligten Organisationen, wenn es darum geht, sozusagen komplett neue Protokolle, Anweisungen, Best Practice, Vorschriften, Sicherheitsregelungen, all dieser ganzen Kram, da wird das standardisiert.
Da wird das mit der Anweisung standardisiert. Das ist natürlich auch immer nur der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner, wenn wir das so nennen, wie das immer ist. Je größer die Organisation, desto schwächer sind die Regeln. Aber da sind die wirklich die Grundprotokolle, wenn dargestellt. Also die simplesten Rechte und Pflichten sind dort niedergeschrieben. Rules of the Air ist auch so ein schönes Gesetzeswert, was wir alle kennen als Piloten. Die Regeln der Luftfahrt, das ist ganz banal, fast wie beim Schiff auch, rechts vor links. Und der Schwächere hat Vorfahrt, sagen wir mal so.
Es gibt rechts vor links?
Ja, rechts vor links gibt es.
Ernsthaft?
Ja.
Haben sich die Ängler nicht durchsetzen können? Wobei, die haben im Zweifelsfall auch rechts vor links. Man kann ja nicht auf der linken Seite fahren. Stimmt, das hat sich fast durcheinander gebracht.
Also solche Grundregeln, die sind mal da so ein bisschen erstellt worden.
Also wenn da ein Flugzeug von rechts kommt, dann bremst man sozusagen.
Das ist natürlich, das kannst du auf Jets in großen Höhen nicht wirklich übertragen. Das kannst du nicht anwenden, nein. Aber es gilt ja dann auch, es gilt trotzdem für uns auch, auch für die Großen, ist aber auch für die Kleinen, die nach Sicht fliegen. Also die nicht nach Instrumentenflugregeln, ich weiß nicht, ob sie da noch irgendwie reden möchten, sondern nach Sichtflugregeln fliegen. Ich gucke raus und wenn ich einen sehe, den weiche ich aus, dann weiß ich, wer von rechts kommt, der hat Vorfahrt, den muss ich ausweichen.
Okay, es ist schon mal gut, dass beide gleichzeitig anfangen auszukommen.
Genau, ein Motorflugzeug weicht einem Luftschiff aus oder ein Motorflugzeug weicht einem Segelflugzeug aus.
Das ist ja auch definiert, wohin man ausweicht. Also sozusagen wer auszuweichen hat, muss nach unten oder nach oben. Weil ich meine, wenn dann beide irgendwie doch Maßnahmen ergreifen, dann ist das auch blöd.
Na, jenne, der, der nicht Vorfahrt hat, der muss ja nicht ausweichen.
Ja gut, aber wenn er sozusagen merkt, dass, also ich meine, man würde ja dann auch.
Ich muss jetzt gerade mal überlegen, also zumindestens bei, wenn sich zwei entgegenkommen, es ist festgeschrieben, dass jeder weicht nach rechts aus. Das ist aber glaube ich beim Schiffen auch so.
Das könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Das macht Sinn, jeder weicht nach rechts aus.
Aber so ein oben unten bei, wenn rechts?
Also es gibt generell Staffelungswerte, die man einhalten muss. Also wenn einer über mir fliegt, dann sollte ich, sagen wir mal, ich hab bei Sichtflugregeln waren das irgendwie, dass wir lügen, mindestens 100, 150 Meter von ihm entfernt sein. Und das sollte ich dann auch einhalten. Und wie gesagt, wenn er Vorfahrt hat, von rechts kommt, dann braucht er ja nicht ausweichen. Dann muss ich halt runtergehen, wenn ich eh schon leicht unten bin, um ihn unterlegen und durchfliegen.
Aber so richtig exakt auf einer Linie ist man ja wahrscheinlich eh nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, nein. Aber das ist auch sehr, in der Real-Wise natürlich irgendwie, versuchen beide auch.
Also wenn man irgendwie tiefer ist, dann geht man mit dem Tennisheld noch tiefer.
Sozusagen, aber irgendwann ist der Boden, ne? Also hängt ja auch Flugzeug, das ist jetzt wirklich ein Detail, wenn ich jenlich wenig Flugzeug habe, was Tragflächen unter mir hat, also so ein Tiefdecker, wie sich das nennt, so ein kleiner Flugzeug, und ich weiche nach oben aus, dann sehe ich den unteren ja nicht mehr, weil die Tragflächen sind meine Wegverschwerden. Also das sind so Sachen, die würde ich da mit reinbringen, deswegen kann ich das nicht so pauschal sagen. Und im Jet mit AFA-Luftverkehr, wenn ich den im oberen Luftraum, kann man das extrem schwer abschätzen, ob der andere, der mir jetzt entgegenkommt, ob er ab Ende über mir oder unter mir durchgeht. Weil durch die Erdkrümmung und die Tatsache, dass ich ihn schon auf 40 km Entfernung vielleicht sehe, anhand seines Kontentschreibens, sieht er aus, als wenn er unter mir ist und am Ende fliegt er über mir rüber. Ja. Dafür sind halt die Fluglotsen da. Die sorgen dafür, dass jeder Flug seinen geschützten Luftraum hat, in dem kein anderer reinkommt. Dafür ist die Arbeit der Fluglotsen da.
Gut, dann lass uns doch mal ein bisschen fliegen.
Sucht euch mal Flughafen aus.
Ja genau, so ähnlich. Also, womit fängt das denn an? Wann, wie weit im Voraus weißt du eigentlich, dass du einen Einsatz hast? Wie weit ist das alles schon geplant? Stehen schon die nächsten drei Monate fest? Oder ergibt sich das irgendwie alles erst am Nachmittag vorher?
Wie weit vorausschauend geplant werden kann, hängt so ein bisschen ab mit, was im Flugzeugtyp das ist, wie die Einsatzgebiete sind. Ein Pfleger, der auf Kurzstrecke unterwegs ist, wo man die Firma selber vielleicht noch gar nicht weiß, setze ich den jetzt in zwei Monaten auf der Strecke ein? Oder brauche ich vielleicht doch ein größeres Flugzeug? Je kleiner das Flugzeug ist, so kurzfristiger sind möglicherweise die Planungen. Das wird dann oft aber um eine gewisse Stabilität in den Lebensqualität der Personen festzulegen, sind irgendwann gewisse Fristen eingeführt worden, wann ich denn spätestens weiß, und das hängt ein bisschen von der Firma ab, wo ich arbeite, wann ich denn spätestens weiß, was ich in den nächsten vier Wochen machen kann. Bei mir konkret ist es, 100 Prozent, ich kann nicht sagen, am 27. des Vormonats weiß ich, was ich nächsten Monat zu arbeiten habe. Es ist eigentlich am Urlaub eingeplant oder irgendwas in der Art. Und ich kann ein bisschen drauf Einfluss drauf nehmen, wann ich gerne ganz bestimmt frei haben möchte. Bei manchen Gesellschaften kann man sich dann auch noch gewisse Flüge wünschen oder irgendwas. Es kann aber auch sein bei Kurzstreckenfliegern, dass man erst am 15. oder am 10. des Vormonats weiß, welches Flugzeug überhaupt welche Strecke fliegt und dann kann man erst anfangen, die Leute dort oder sich planen zu lassen, die Planung zu erstellen, sodass man erst am 20. des Vormonats grob weiß, ok, an und dahin werde ich fliegen, aber nicht mal da genau was kann sein, dass ich da drin noch Sachen verschieben werde, aber z.B. weiß ich, dass ich dann da schon drei, vier Tage weg sein werde und am 27. weiß ich das meistens dann ganz genau. Bei Langstreckenfliegern, die eine bestimmte Route fliegen, da ist das meistens schon auf mehrere Monate hinaus festgelegt, dass die eine gewisse Strecke bedienen und dementsprechend ist da die Planung relativ langfristig. Aber auch da weiß ich vielleicht am 10. des Vormonats, was ich am Ende des nächsten Monats arbeiten werde. Aber richtig definitiv bei mir, meiner Firma, also am 27. kann ich sagen, ok, am nächsten Monat, am 10. habe ich einen Flug. Und dementsprechend bin ich dafür eingeteilt sozusagen. Und auch genauso das Cockpit und auch die Kabinenbesatzung bei uns.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen flugzeugbedingt, waren das vor allem jetzt bei dir Destinationen in Europa?
Mein zukünftiger Flieger, wie gesagt, den habe ich an euch geflogen, der fliegt weiter, fliegt nur Langstrecke und vor dem Flug 37, der flog halt nur Europa und dementsprechend.
Was hat das Ding für eine Reichweite?
Oh, einen Kilometer, das muss ich überlegen. Theoretisch wird ja auch viel geflogen, der kann bis New York, wenn er dementsprechend ausgestattet ist, die 737 gibt Strecken, die werden bis nach New York bedient. Aber eigentlich so optimiert ist er gebaut, Europäische, Nordafrika, Moskau, vielleicht noch ein bisschen weiter, Helsinki, Stockholm, Reykjavik, so was, die Ecke. Das ist Europa ein bisschen weiter, so drei, vier Stunden.
Also man kommt nach Nordafrika, man kommt nach Skandinavien, da ist irgendwie alles anfliegbar mit so einer 737. Und das waren dann auch diese typischen Orte. Na dann pick dir doch mal was raus, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie interessant oder uninteressant bestimmte Flughäfen sind. Darfst du jetzt einfach mal einen aussuchen, der vielleicht irgendwelche Aspekte am Ende noch aufzeigt, die auch nochmal ganz interessant sind, die vielleicht bei anderen nicht so aufkommen, aber muss jetzt auch nicht sein. Sag mal, wo geht's hin? Ich hab jetzt einen Freiflug gewonnen.
Okay, wo hin? Nehmen wir mal an, wir sind ja gerade in Hamburg, geht's von Hamburg nach Rom. Ich hab, wie gesagt, diesen Flug eingeteilt bekommen. Ich weiß schon ein paar Tage vorher, dass ich ihn fliegen wird. Muss jetzt einer bestimmten Meldezeit am Flughafen sein. Einfach nur damit die Firma weiß, kommt der irgendwie aus oder hat er sich auf dem Weg dort hinten beingebrochen?
Ja, wann geht der Flug jetzt?
Der Flug, sag mal, geht um zwölf los und ich muss eine Stunde, zehn vorher da sein.
Also das ist, sag mal mal, weniger als ich jetzt erwartet habe.
Also bei größeren Flugzeugen wird es dann mehr. Da wird es eine Stunde 40 oder so was.
Okay.
Von dem Zeitpunkt an geht auch die Dienstzeit zu, die Flugdienstzeit, wie lange ich arbeiten dann. Das ist auch sehr streng, genau, minutennah geregelt.
Das heißt, die Ankunft ist sozusagen schon auch dann der Beginn der Dienstzeit?
Der Ankunft ist die Meldezeit, weil mich anzumelden hat, ist der Beginn der Dienstzeit.
Wo meldet man sich dann an?
Man sagt der Firma Bescheid, ich bin da. Mittlerweile geht es über den Computer. Da steckst du einfach deinen Ausweis rein und der registriert, dass du da bist. So eine Schlechtkarte.
Wo geht es denn überhaupt rein? Also, wo alle anderen reingehen?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Also je nachdem, wenn die Fluggesellschaft dort ihre Station hat, wo man stationiert ist, wo auch der Umland anfängt, haben sie meistens ein Büro, ein Office oder ein Gebäude, einen Raum, wo man sich trifft. Je nachdem, wie der aufgebaute hier in Hamburg war, hier war hinter der Sicherheitskontrolle. Das heißt, ich musste erstmal durch, wie jeder Gast auch, durch eine Sicherheitskontrolle durch. Ich habe zwar eine Personalkontrolle benutzt, aber ich wurde genauso getestet wie die Passagiere auch. Eine Ausnahme habe ich, Flugbesatzzeugbesatzungen, die dürfen Flüssigkeit mitnehmen. Das ist ja bei Gästen nicht. Also ich darf eine Flasche mit Wasser mitnehmen.
Und Shampoo.
Shampoo auch. Einfach nur weil man sagt, das geht sonst nicht. Ich meine, die Leute sind fünf Tage auf der Reise oder an Bord, wo sie was zu trinken haben. Und nicht jeder kriegt das ja auch gestellt, sagen wir so. Die sollen ihr Wasser und ihr Essen mitnehmen, ihr Müsli oder was immer sie sich da angerührt haben. Das sollen die mitnehmen dürfen. Das geht ja auch nicht.
Wieso? Hat man nicht Vollverpflegung irgendwie an Bord?
Nein, hat man nicht.
Wirklich?
Nein. Also bei mir konkret so, ich kann mir Essen bestellen, aber es ist nicht gestellt, nein, auf jeden Fall keinen. Und es gibt manche Gesellschaften, das ist bei mir noch gut. Bei mir ist es luxuriös. Also da gibt es ja auch Essen an Bord teilweise. Und wenn was übrig bleibt, wenn ein Gast das nicht wollte oder wenn zu viel beladen worden ist, dann wird es in der Regel nicht weggeschmissen, sondern es findet sich schon ein Verwendungsfaktor für. Aber man kann nicht davon ausgehen, dass sich das an Bord Essen gibt. Nein, also ich konnte es nicht. Und ich habe mir was mitgenommen, zumal ich das auch irgendwann nicht mehr essen konnte oder sehen konnte. Das ist ein anderer Aspekt, ne?
Das täglich größeres Murmeltier, ne?
Genau, genau. Also und bei anderen Aspekten, man kann sich wie gesagt viele Gesellschaften bieten natürlich oder müssen es glaube ich auch arbeitsrechtlich anbieten, dass die Leute was zu essen haben. Aber das kostet einem trotzdem, kostet das was und je nachdem, wo man bei welcher fluggesellschaftlicher Arbeit sind diese Leere nicht unbedingt so großartig, insbesondere bei den Kabin-Mitgliedern. Die haben dann oft ihr ganzen Kühlschrank mitgenommen teilweise, wenn sie dann mehrere Tage unterwegs waren. Weil sie waren dann im Hotel und immer Hotel essen oder besonders irgendwo essen gehen. Das kostet Geld und das wollte man so möglich klein genug halten. Also man darf Sachen mitnehmen. Also ich darf, wenn ich im Einsatz bin, woraus ich es gesetzt habe, dann darf ich Flüssigkeit mitnehmen. Meine Zahnpasta mitnehmen, damit ich mir unterwegs die Zähne putze. Das darfst du ja auch, aber es dürfte auch eine große Tube mitnehmen. Also durch die Sicherheitskonto durch werde ich genauso geprüft, vorab. Damit ich denn auch überhaupt das Vorfeld als solches betreten darf, das gilt für jeden Flughafen-Mitarbeiter. Die werden einer, nennt sich das, zuverlässiger zur Überprüfung unterteilt. Da wird geguckt, das ist mit Führungszeugnis so ein bisschen so eine Überprüfung, ob derjenige irgendetwas aus seinem Kerbholz hat oder wie denn so sein Hintergrund ist. Wo die letzten Wohnsitze waren und so. Und dann darf er auch hinter dem Flughafenzaun sozusagen arbeiten. Das ist Voraussetzung. Und wir sind dann durch die Sicherheitskontrolle durch, haben uns dann zur Meldezeit sozusagen gemeinsam getroffen. Mit den anderen Kollegen, mit denen man seine Reise jetzt beginnt, sei das nun diesen Einflug oder die mehrere Flüge oder die ganze Woche, mit denen man unterwegs ist. Der erste Schritt, den man dann gemacht hat, wenn man angekommen ist, man hat sich den sogenannten Flugplan angeguckt. Das ist jetzt auf dieser kurzen Strecke Hamburg-Rom, ist das jetzt nicht so spektakulär.
Der Flugplan ist sozusagen die konkrete Planung, wo fliegt man jetzt eigentlich wirklich hin.
Der wird vorab erstellt, dafür gibt es Dispatch, also die Dispatcher. Auch das ist ein Beruf, den man erlernen kann und auch ein Zulassungskriterium unterworfen ist, wo man sich sehr viel mit Meteorologie und etc. alles aussetzt, Flugzeugtechnik. Man kriegt einen Flugplan gerechnet. In der Grundschulung haben wir auch mal gelernt, wie man das alles selber macht, aber das könnte ich jetzt nicht mehr. Das ist auch sehr computerisiert und in den kurzen Umdrehzeiten, die man hat, kann man das auch gar nicht zeitlich mehr bewerkstellten. Das haben wir alles mal gelernt sozusagen, aber jetzt kriegen wir elektronisch gerechnet. Dort ist der Flugweg drauf, wie wir ihn gerne fliegen würden. Wie dieser Flugplan eingereicht ist bei der Flugsicherung oder bei dem Europäischen Flugsicherungsverbund. Da wird praktisch ein Wunsch geäußert, dass der und der Flieger von Hamburg nach Rom fliegen möchte um deren Uhrzeit auf deren Strecke, in deren Flughöhe. Drei Stunden vor wird dieser Flugplan mittlerweile alles elektronisch übermittelt. Das passiert also schon lange, bevor ich am Flughafen bin. Dann wird geguckt, wie viele Leute wollen denn um den Zeitpunkt von Hamburg abfliegen, auf der Strecke fliegen, nach Rom fliegen? Gibt es da möglicherweise Konflikte, Überlastungen? Der Flughafen Rom hat vor schon gemeldet oder meldet dann zeitnah auch, jetzt wollen hier 60 Flieger anfliegen, ich kann aber nur 55. Dann müssen wir anfangen, Verspätungen oder sogenannte Slot-Zeiten, das hast du vielleicht schon mal gehört, den Begriff, die Fliege anfangen schon zu staffeln vorher. Das sind alles so Prozesse, die laufen vorher schon ab. Was wir, wenn wir dann ankommen, wir kriegen letztendlich die Tatsache geliefert. Wir haben jetzt hier einen Flugplan, der kann pünktlich losgehen, von der Planung her. Der ist noch nicht mit irgendeinem Slot, mit einer verspäteten Abflugzeit oder einer festen Abflugzeit ausgerüstet. Manchmal ja schon, aber zumindest so kriegen wir die Fakten präsentiert. Dort ist auch die Spritberechnung drauf, was ich Minimum am Sprit haben muss. Das ist auch ziemlich genau vorgeschrieben, welche Menge Sprit ich mindestens mit haben muss.
Also wie viele Sicherheitsreserven sozusagen drin sind.
Da kann man sehr viel in Details reingehen, was ich haben muss. Ich muss natürlich Sprit haben, um überhaupt nach oben zu kommen. Aber eine Fliegerei ist immer im Plan B oder Plan C vorgeschrieben, sodass ich auch immer zu einem Ausflughafen weiter fliegen muss und auch noch Warte, zusätzliche Reserven haben muss. Reserven für unvorhersehbare Ereignisse, also wenn ich dann eine Flughöhe nicht bekomme, um mehr Sprit verbrauche, weil ich nicht in der optimalen Flughöhe fliegen kann und so weiter. Das wird da alles so ein bisschen mit einkalkuliert schon. Aber da wird nur auf das Minimum gerechnet, den kriege ich präsentiert. Dann kriege ich den Wetterbericht auspräsentiert, wie das Wetter am Zielflughafen sein wird, am Ausweifflughafen, das Wetter unterwegs. Eine Wetterkarte ist vorgeschrieben auch, die ich gucken kann, sind da irgendwelche Gewitter unterwegs? Ist da irgendwas, was mich möglicherweise stören kann? Dann kriege ich eine Auflistung der sogenannten Notems, Notices to Airmen, da steht drin, ist irgendwas kaputt am Flughafen. Kann der Flughafen gewisse Anflugverfahren nicht anbieten? Ist da eine Landebahn geschlossen? Ist dort eine Parkposition kaputt, kann nicht bedient werden? Alles so, was so in der täglichen Operation alles so sein kann. Das lesen wir uns alle schön durch, gucken das an. Auf dem Flug nach Rom geht es am Ende nun doch relativ schnell. Und dann gucken wir nochmal den Flugplan an. Dann kriegen wir einen technischen Bericht des Flugzeuges. Ist bei dem Flugzeug alles okay? Ist da irgendwas kaputt? Ist da irgendwas, was uns hindert, nicht in der optimalen Höhe zu fliegen, weil wir niedriger fliegen müssen? Teil der Klimaanlage ist defekt. Ist ja alles mehrfach, mehrfach redundant an Bord ausgelegt. Aber wenn denn eine Komponent kaputt ist, heißt es nicht, dass jetzt der Flieger am Boden bleiben muss. Es kann sein, dass er sicher weiter fliegen kann, aber er darf nicht so hoch fliegen oder so was Banales. Kommt selten vor, aber es ist alles möglich. Da wird dann geguckt, ob da irgendwas ist, was uns hindert, den Flug so durchzuführen, wie er drauf steht. Es ist nicht so, dass man sagt, das wissen die Dispatcher, die haben das automatisch schon eingerechnet. Das passiert nicht unbedingt immer. Man muss schon mal ein bisschen Plausibilitätsüberprüfung machen. Dann gucken wir uns beiden an und überlegen, wie viel Sprit wir mitnehmen wollen. Das Minimum, was wir mitnehmen müssen. Dann kommt die Erfahrung rein und dann gucken wir aufs Wetter und sagen, komm an, zur Ankunftszeit sind Gewitter vorhergesagt. Das wollen wir ein bisschen mit einrechnen. Dann nehmen wir jetzt so und so viel extra Kraftstoff mit, um das bis zu ein bisschen umfliegen zu können. Oder das Gewitter, das kann man natürlich drauf gucken. Das spielt unheimlich viel mit Erfahrung rein. Und auch der Blick auf das Wetter, dass du sagst, das sind einzelne Gewitter. Wenn das Ding zieht durch und dann nach einer Stunde ist der Flughafen wieder frei, dann kann man wieder anfliegen. Also nehme ich eine Stunde extra mit, um da rum zu fliegen. Und dann gucke ich natürlich auch, wie ist der Flughafen alterniert. Oh, der hat ja das gleiche Wetter. Ich glaube, ich nehme mal den anderen Flughafen, der ein bisschen weiter weg ist. Die nehme ich mal als Ausfallflughafen. Nehme da nochmal auch extra für mit. Irgendwas in der Art, sodass wir damit reingehen.
Also der Flugplan wird erst mal vorgegeben, aber am Ende ist es vor allem wirklich eine Pilotenentscheidung.
Definitiv eine Pilotenentscheidung.
Man wägt halt alle Eventualitäten ab, bringt alle Berichte zusammen, die zwar irgendwie digital vorgemeldet, abgelegte, z.B. sind. Müsst ihr dann eure Entscheidung dann auch nochmal in irgendeiner Form digital abtreten oder sind das sozusagen nur noch lokale Entscheidungen?
Jetzt konkret bei uns war es so, wir haben unsere Spritwerte in den Computer reingehackt und in den, der dort vor Ort stand, sozusagen.
Also jetzt noch bei dem Büro der Fluggesellschaft.
Genau, bei dem Büro der Fluggesellschaft. Mittlerweile war das so, dass irgendwann haben wir diesen Flugcomputer mitgenommen, den haben wir praktisch dort nur als Netz angeschlossen, haben den als kleinen Laptop, haben wir den mittlerweile mit. Hier haben wir den mit dabei. Das ist die Variante, wie wir das gemacht haben. Es gibt unzählige Arten, wie ich jetzt zu dem Flugplan komme. Es gibt manche Gesellschaften, die laden sich die ganzen Flugpläne auf einen USB-Stick rauf oder irgendwas in einer Art und nehmen für den restlichen Tag die ganzen Flugpläne mit und entscheiden dann sozusagen, kriegen nicht immer neue Karten, sondern kriegen halt, basierend auf den Daten, die sie jetzt schon haben, machen sie dann diese Entscheidung und updaten die immer nur anhand von Informationen, die sie dann im Laufe des Fluges bekommen. Man kann sich auch unterwegs ja auch noch ein Wetter holen und alles so was. Also so lief das so grob ab. Es gibt wie gesagt viele Wege, die führen nach Rom, das passt jetzt. Aber letztendlich funktioniert das so. Der Pilot bekommt einen Flugplan vorweg, kriegt Informationen über Wetter, Wetterkarten und die Notems, technische Berichte des Flugzeuges und macht dann die Spritentscheidung. Ob er den Flugplan jetzt aktuell frisch bekommt oder ob der schon die mitgenommen hat für den Rückflug dann zum Beispiel, das ist jetzt irgendwie unerheblich, aber so läuft das im Prinzip ab. Es gibt auch manche Flughäfen, da hat man sich das entschieden, wenn man irgendwo über Nacht war, in einem kleinen Platz, wo es diese ganze elektronische Infrastruktur gar nicht gibt, dann kriege ich den Flugplan in Papier ausgedrückt im Cockpit und blättern wir nach, gucken nach, entscheiden das, gehen wir runter zum Tanker und denen sagen wir dann sechs Tonnen.
Okay, also das ist jetzt noch nicht so eine total durchdigitalisierte, standardisierte Geschichte. Es gibt den Trend natürlich dahin, alles Mögliche digital abzulegen, aber es gibt nach wie vor das Vollwerk, wie es früher war, mit ohne Internet und ohne Laptop etc.
Ja, wie der Flugplan rechnet wird. Ja, genau, aber so grob muss es sein. Ich muss auch.
Ja, auch diese Entscheidung. Ich meine, es ist ja am Ende dieses, wie viel Sprit haben wir dabei? Das ist ja sozusagen, das wollt ja nicht nur ihr wissen, sondern diese Informationen möchte man ja auch am Boden haben. Man sagt ja, wie viel soll getankt werden, aber das ist sozusagen ja auch etwas, was man hinterlegt.
Also aktuell ist es so, dass der Tanker, mittlerweile sind alle vernetzt natürlich, und der Tanker kommt mit seinem Tankwagen angefahren und tippt die Registrierung von dem Flugzeug an, wo er seinen Auftrag bekommen hat, fährt dahin, guckt drauf und sagt, aha, der Minimumsprit, der im Flugband drin ist, ist so und so viel, den tanke ich schon mal rein. Das ist extrem wichtig, wenn das um ganz große Flugzeuge geht.
Das dauert ja auch eine Weile.
Das dauert eine Weile, bis die ihre, keine Ahnung, 140 Tonnen Kraftstoff da reingepumpt haben, ist ja eine dreiviertel Stunde unterwegs mit seinem Tanker da.
Für so eine 737 sozusagen, also um die wirklich mal von leer bis voll, wie lange würde man da brauchen und wie voll sind die noch mal?
Also wenn, sagen wir mal richtig, der reine Pumpvergang, das dauert nur 16 Minuten. 17 Minuten ist ja voll. Ja, das geht relativ schnell. Er muss ja noch ranschließen, er muss den Wagen, wenn er fährt ja ran, dann braucht er noch mal 3-4 Minuten. Er muss positionieren, sein Wagen, die haben alle Protokolle. Hab ich einen Fluchtweg, das Tankfahrzeug braucht einen Fluchtweg. Das gibt einem noch mal so ein bisschen die Vorstellung, wie weit alles runtergebrochen wird auf Sicherheit und Protokolle, wie, welches Fahrzeug, in welchem Zustand an den Flugzeug ran zu fahren. Der Tanker hat ein Protokoll, dass er einen Fluchtweg haben muss, er muss erstmal das Flugzeug erden, geht hin mit so einem kleinen Erdungskabel, schließt es an, schließt das Erdungskabel am Boden an und dann erst kann er mit dem Tankschlauch oben Klappe abschließen, Tanksystem starten, Tanksystem des Flugzeugs starten und dann, also es dauert auch so 3-4 Minuten, bis er bereit ist, den Stoff reinzupumpen.
Erdung ist wichtig, damit es nicht irgendwelche statischen Entladungen gibt, die dann den Sprit entzünden können.
Genau, genau, das muss gemacht werden. Also letztendlich, um das zu wechseln, die Piloten entscheiden über die Menge am K-Stoff an Bord. Und er entscheidet auch über die Route. Also er kriegt... Das ist jetzt, Hamburg-Rom ist jetzt nicht so das Beispiel dafür, aber Langstrecken wird es dann auch schon interessanter. Da kriegt man auch einen Flugplan gerechnet, natürlich. Der, ähm, auch das Optimum da sein soll. Man möchte natürlich so wenig Kraftstoff wie möglich tanken müssen, weil je mehr ich tanke muss, desto, ähm, sei das auch nur...
So mehr wird auf Verbrauch.
Genau, weil jedes Gramm Gewicht, sei das nur der eigene Kraftstoff, produziert einen höheren Verbrauch. Und, ähm, da ist es aber auch so, dass man sagt, du hast mich jetzt hier mitten durch die Gewitter geplant, kannst du mir mal die, die, wenn es mir eine Viertelstunde kostet, aber plan mich mal bitte außenrum, das möchte ich da möglichlich nicht links fliegen. Das kann der Pilot. Und rein rechtlich darf da ihm keiner widersprechen. Also der Kommandant entscheidet über die Flugrote, oder die Piloten entscheiden über die Flugrote und die Menge, die über das Minimum hinausgeht.
Wie viel Luft ist denn eigentlich in den geplanten Abflugzeiten? Also wie viel Musik ist da drin? Wie viel kann man da sozusagen umplanen, ohne dass es eine unmittelbare Auswirkung auf den Gesamtplan hat?
Schön ist natürlich, wenn der Flugplan nicht, deshalb gibt's ein schönes Wort dafür, wenn er nicht kontrolliert ist von der Flugsicherung, was die Abflugzeit angeht. Dann kann ich praktisch, wenn ich sage, wir sind schon 20 Minuten hinter unserem Fahrplan und ich weiß, es dauert noch 40 Minuten, dann ruf ich bei dem Fluglotsen an und sag, pass mal auf, könnt ihr unseren Flugplan irgendwie offenhalten? Dann sagt er, ja geht, kein Problem, können wir machen. Also dass er nicht sagt, wie ich hab eine Ticketreservierung für einen Theater gehabt und komm nicht rechtzeitig rein und dann ist das Ticket verfallen, dann muss ich den ganzen neuen Flugplan nochmal erstellen, nochmal anreichen. Das können Sie also ein bisschen länger aufrechterhalten. Wenn der Flugplan aber so einen Slot hat, dann wird das manchmal so ein bisschen komplizierter. Slot bedeutet, das ist so eine fest vorgebende Startfenster, was ich einhalten muss. Man versucht damit schon so ein bisschen entweder die Abflüge oder auf einer bestimmten Strecke, wo man weiß, da kommen ganz viele Flugzeuge dennähe an, dass ich die schon versuche zu stafeln, dass ich ein so ein bisschen mehr Ruhe einbringe oder Warteschleifen vermeide. Im Falle von diesem Beispiel von Rom, da sage ich, in dieser Stunde wurden 60 Flugzeuge gelandet, ich kann aber nur, sagen wir mal, 40. Also sage ich, jeder soll jetzt nicht laut Flugplan losfliegen, sondern jeder soll einen Abstand von 4 Minuten losfliegen, so gestaffelt, und dann weiß ich, dann kann ich sie alles reinkriegen. Dann kommt zwar gibt es zwar Verzögerungen schon am Boden, meinetwegen beim Abflug, aber nicht unbedingt in der Luft mit Warteschleifen. Weil das ist teuer und das will man irgendwie vermeiden und ist nicht gut. Und es ist auch mehr Arbeitsbelastung für die Fluglosen, weil auch das ist Luftraum, der wiederum verbraucht wird. Wo die Fluglosen dann arbeiten müssen. Die Fluglosen geben dann in der Regel vor, wie viele Flugzeuge sie in einer Stunde verkraften können. Oder bearbeiten können.
Okay, also der Flugplan kommt, wird von den Piloten interpretiert, auf die Wetter und sonstigen Anforderungen angepasst. Und am Ende gibt man ein klares Signal, okay, tank mal so voll, mehr brauchen wir nicht.
Es kann auch sein, dass der Flughafen gar nicht anfliegbar ist, zum Beispiel. So vom Wetter her.
Ach so, dass man jetzt komplett umruten muss.
Ähm, umruten muss, ja. Man kriegt den Flugplan gerechnet und man stellt fest, dass der Ausweichflughafen, den man gewählt hat, oder der vom Flugplan gerechnet worden ist, dass der durch aktuelles Wetter, also was auch in der Vorhersage nicht drin war, dass der auf einmal nicht mehr als Ausweichflughafen zur Verfügung steht, weil das Wetter zu schlecht geworden ist dort. Ein Ausweichflughafen soll immer besseres Wetter oder muss bessere Wetterkriterien erfüllen als der Zielflughafen. Ich kann interessanterweise rein rechtlich zu einem Flughafen hinfliegen. Ich kann nach oben hinfliegen und ich guck drauf und ich stell fest, ach guck mal, der Wetterbericht sagt, das Wetter ist so schlecht. Jetzt ist es meistens Nebel, wenn ich sage, von schlecht. Ich meine nicht Gewitter oder irgendwie sowas. Das kann man irgendwie nicht so berechnen. Aber die sagen mir, da ist so dicht der Nebel, da kann ich gar nicht landen. Kann ich trotzdem losfliegen. Ich muss nur zwei Ausweichflughafen haben, nicht nur einen.
Aber einen muss man sozusagen immer haben. Also Flugplan zu X heißt auch immer, es gibt noch einen Y, der einfach Teil des Plans ist.
Ich rede jetzt nicht über Sinn und Zweck. Ob es Sinn macht, nach oben zu fliegen, wenn man weiß, man kann da gar nicht landen. Aber das ist so ein bisschen geschuldet der Tatsache, dass das eine ist die Vorhersage. Und Vorhersagen sind natürlich eigentlich nur eine Vorhersage. Und oftmals ist ja so, dass das Wetter am Ende doch ein bisschen besser ist oder am Ende man doch da anfliegen kann. Und deswegen würde man den Flug gleich nicht von vornherein absagen, wo man weiß, man könnte da hinkommen.
So, jetzt nochmal ein bisschen zusammen fliegen. Also jetzt haben wir quasi einen Flugplan erstellt. Wir haben genau gesagt, was getankt wird. Jetzt alle Wege führen nach Rom. Also haben wir jetzt sozusagen auch einen. Was wäre jetzt so ein potenzieller Ausweichflughafen?
Also wenn das Wetter toll ist, ist es vielleicht, man fliegt nach Rom, nach Fiume, Cimo. Und der andere Flughafen, Campasi heißt er glaube ich, der ist an der Küste, der ist gleich nebenan. Den würde man als Ausweichflughafen nehmen.
Okay, also jetzt nicht Neapel oder so, sondern sozusagen einfach der nächste große Verkehrsflughafen, der diese Maschine auch runterkriegt.
Genau, das sieht bei größeren Flugzeugen manchmal schon anders aus. A380 hat dann wahrscheinlich ganz andere Optionen. Da kann es teilweise sein, dass man, ich sag mal, das war das krasseste Beispiel, was ich gehört habe, Deli und der Ausweichflughafen war Bangkok.
Weil, geht nicht anders.
Weil der andere, der daneben ist, der man einfliegen konnte, der war vom Nebel so zu. Der nächste wäre dann in der Richtung gelegen, wäre das im Süden von England ging nicht. Weil das andere war Rangoon, Rangoon geht auch nicht. Also hat man dann gleich Bangkok genommen. Das möchte ich in dem Gas natürlich nicht zumuten.
So, jetzt gibt es natürlich noch diverse andere Refills, die da gemacht werden. So ein Flugzeug muss natürlich gereinigt werden, wenn es jetzt nicht gerade als erstes am Tag bereitgestellt wird. Es muss natürlich nachgeladen entsorgt werden. Da gibt es ja dann auch noch sanitäre Eingriff.
Aber der nächste Schritt wäre, nachdem wir uns die Kraftstoffe ausgesucht haben, wir würden dann, weil es ja der erste Flug, zusammen mit der Kabinenbesatzung ein Briefing machen.
Das heißt, man trifft sich komplett?
Man trifft sich komplett. Das ist auch wirklich vorgestiegen.
Kabinenbesatzung für eine 737 ist?
Es sind drei oder vier, je nachdem, welche Version man hat, drei oder vier Kollegen.
Plus die Piloten. Also insgesamt sechs Leute ungefähr. Und sozusagen das Team.
Genau, das Team. Und man trifft sich mit dem, man unterhält sich mit dem, man stellt sich vor sozusagen auch, bespricht noch mal feine Details. Pass mal auf, das Wetter wird sehr turbulent werden. Wir können die Anstaltzeichen nicht sofort ausmachen. Wir lassen sie später aus. Oder wenn ihr was Besonderes habt, dann bitte sagt mir gleich Bescheid, weil ich hätte gerne das so und so. So Feinheiten wie im Falle eines Vorfalls dort, werde ich das und das so machen. Also nicht, dass euch das wundert oder irgendwie so. Als Beispiel, was nenne ich mal ein Beispiel, es geht, manche Leute sagen, falls wir aus irgendwelchen Gründen, das ist wieder jetzt hier Notfallgespräch, wir müssen die Flieger evakuieren, manche Leute sagen, ich werde die Ausgänge benennen, über die wir aussteigen werden. Und andere sagen, ich werde das nicht benennen. So Feinheiten gibt es immer noch, die da so ein bisschen existieren. Das bespricht man vorher mit denen auch. Aber primär ist es mehr so Flugzeit, wie ist das Wetter heute, was macht ihr denn heute Abend? Das ist auch ein persönliches Gespräch. Wenn man gemeinsam über Nacht ist, in welchem Hotel sind wir da, wie sind die Crewwege, wie kommen wir da raus? Und so was in der Art. Hat man einen neuen Kollegen mit, braucht der eine besondere Einweisung? Oder hat der Fragen? Oder auch selbst Gespräche wie, das kann ja manchmal sein auf der psychologischen Ebene, du letztes Mal, ist mir das und das passiert. Wenn das noch mal passiert, was würden wir da machen mit dem Gast? Oder irgendwas wie Heldstuhl? Wie machen wir das mit Koffer, die nicht mehr oben reinpassen? So ganz menschliche, teilweise auch operationelle Dinge, die man besprechen muss.
Wo es dann mal mehr oder weniger Bedarf gibt?
Genau, wo es Gesprächsbedarf gibt zwischen Kabine und Kognit.
Und schätze mal gerade, wenn mal wieder ein Vorfall war?
Dann müssen wir das auch gerne mal besprochen und fokussieren, was war denn da passiert und erzähl doch mal. Es ist halt ein Team.
Aber auch das Flugbegleiterteam setzt sich jedes Mal wieder aus beliebigen Mitarbeitern zusammen. Gibt es da dann auch nochmal einen Chef der Crew, wie es einen ersten Piloten gibt?
Das ist von Fluggesellschaft zu Fluggesellschaft unterschiedlich. Manche machen das auch innerhalb der Crew. Wo der Älteste ist, ist der Chef. Bei uns gibt es bestimmte Chef-Stewards, die die Leitung des Teams haben. Und dann auch die Arbeit einteilen, wie, wann, wo an Bord was macht. Aber auch die haben ein ganz starkes Protokoll, nach dem sie richten. Das ist bei der 737 jetzt nicht so schwierig gewesen. Aber bei größeren Flugzeugen wird es umso diffiziler, welche Arbeitsposition sie haben und woran welche Tür sie sitzen. Und welche Notfall-Ausgangsfunktion diese Tür hat. Und wo ist das Notfall-Equipment? Und wie hätte ich denn gerne das so und so, dass es so gemacht wird. Also viel Service-Besprechung, aber auch noch mal Notfall-Protokoll. Dass der PERS das auch verantwortlich, dass er auch überprüft, ob die Kabinen-Kollegen ausreichendes Wissen haben. Also manche machen auch so einen kleinen Test, auch noch mal so ein bisschen befragt, noch mal ab. Und sehr viel auch noch mit Abfragen, ob die Kollegen... Manche sind teilweise medizinisch vorgebildet, wenn es um Erste Hilfe geht. Das ist ja auch immer ein großer Teil des Bege- dass Passagiere an Bord krank werden und Erste Hilfe benötigen und wie man damit umgeht. Menschen sind eine difficile Fracht.
Kann ich mir vorstellen. Sicherlich ist man da mit allerlei haarsträubenden Situationen konfrontiert über die Zeit.
Kabinenkollegen kriegen wir auch eine spezielle Schulung. Erste Hilfe, jetzt wir nicht so stark im Cockpit, weil wir am Ende doch nicht aus unserem Ausplatz rausgehen. Aber Kabinenkollegen kriegen eine Schulung, Erste Hilfe, Service natürlich, Notfall und auch sogenannte Unrulees. Also Passagiere, die durchdrehen. Ja, es ist eine Belastung für alle und auch für alle anderen Gäste.
Selten aber findet es statt.
Selten findet es statt, aber am anderen Seite doch relativ häufig. Also weltweit von allen Flügen, jetzt bestimmt gerade irgendwo eine Besatzung aus den vielen tausend Flügen, die in der Luft sind und kämpft gerade mit irgendeinem...
Idioten...
.Arschloch, genau. Der vielleicht auch nur durchgedreht und der auch nur... Viele von denen haben Flugangst, haben irgendwas eingeworfen vorweg, haben sich in den Scheiß eingeschmissen und kommen da total durchgedreht schon an Bord irgendwie und wenn die Reise dann losgeht, irgendwann fühlen sie sich beengt, können nicht raus und dann fangen sie an durchzudrehen. Das ist oftmals so was in der Art.
Das ist sicherlich nicht unbedingt für jeden immer so einfach, aber manche machen sich das natürlich auch nochmal extra schwer.
Und dann wird hier auch glücklicherweise Alkohol an Bord serviert.
Das ist ja auch nicht immer hilfreich. Aber besser hinsichtlich kann das auch entspannt wirken.
Kann entspannt wirken, aber manche von den Gästen, was Kriegner sind, kommen ja schon manchmal betrunken an Bord. Dann dürfen sie übrigens nicht an Bord gehen. Also bitte nicht, wer hier zuhört, nicht betrunken an Bord gehen. Wenn die Crew das mitkriegt, kann sie einen gleich wieder rausbefördern. Betrugene Gäste dürfen wir nicht.
Also offensichtlich betrunken.
Ja, kommen die Leute mit einem Gläschen Wein an Bord, haben sich irgendwo getrunken und so. Aber wenn einer richtig betrunken ist und wandt und da reingeht und es irgendwie schafft, vorne am Gate bei den Kollegen da vorbei zu kommen und ich hab mal einen gehabt, der hat es irgendwie geschafft. Und auf dem Flug nach Hamburg Düsseldorf und in Düsseldorf kam er nicht mehr alleine die Schreppe runter. Morgens um sieben. Aber das willst du ja nicht haben. Stell dir mal vor, irgendwas passiert und du musst diese Menschen ja am Ende dann da rauskriegen. Aber viele bringen sich dann auch ihren Schnaps heimlich mit. Es gibt ja Gott sei Dank einen großen Duty-Free. Da kann man sich ja dann ordentlich mit Alkohol eindecken. Nachdem man vor, dass ich als Kontrolle abgeben muss, den Schnaps, kann man ihn da wieder kaufen. Ich rede jetzt nicht über Sinn und Unsinn. Also das möchte ich jetzt nicht.
Gut, also Flugplan ist durch. Das Team trifft sich, macht ein Briefing und stimmt sich über all diese ganzen Aspekte und Möglichkeiten ab. Gegebenenfalls auf aktuelle Situationen ein. Da ist man aber noch im Flughafen-Gebäude.
Da ist man im Flughafen-Gebäude. Es kann auch sein, dass man die Kabinenbesatzung erst am Flug trifft. Das gibt es auch. Dass die Kabinenbesatzung aus irgendwelchen Gründen schon Einflug mit dem Flugzeug gemacht hat. Die Maschine, die jetzt von Hamburg nach Rom fliegen soll, um 12 Uhr, die Kollegen, die dort waren, die sind schon einmal aus Köln gekommen.
Nur das Pilotenteam wird getauscht?
Nur das Pilotenteam wird getauscht. Auch das gibt es, es gibt Rotationen ineinander. Dann macht man das halt an Bord. Dieses Briefing, alles, was dazu gehört. Aber das ist auch vorgeschrieben, dass man das macht. Das ist eine gute Sache und das sollte man auch machen.
Wie lange dauert das so?
5 Minuten vielleicht. Wenn es mehr, dann mal 10. Dann geht man an Bord. Wenn der Flieger dann hoffentlich schon da ist. Meistens ist er ja dann irgendwie unterwegs oder so. Wenn der Flieger neu frisch am Tag fliegt, wird ein großes Protokoll gemacht. Überprüfung, ob alles okay ist. Jede Klappe wird aufgemacht an Bord. Guckt, ob da alles drinne ist, was er rein soll und nicht, was er nicht rein soll. Der Flieger wird nochmal so richtig gründlich gecheckt. Wird nochmal geguckt im technischen Bordbuch, was die Kabine hat für ihre Equipment, was ich habe als Cockpit-Crew. Ob irgendwelche Fehler jetzt von der Vorbesatzung, die den Flieger dahin gebracht hat, eingetragen worden sind, aber noch nicht elektronisch bekannt sind. Ob da irgendwie Neuigkeiten in sich sind oder ob jetzt bei der Überprüfung der Systeme, was ich vor dem Start mache, ob da irgendwas auffällig ist oder defekt geworden ist, irgendeine Art, dass wir das, ob das ein Problem ist für den Flug oder ob wir damit fliegen können, nicht fliegen können, oder an welchen Bedingungen wir fliegen können. Kann sein, dass ich an Bord gehe und dann nochmal feststelle, ich muss nochmal nachtanken, ist alles schon passiert. Oder ich kriege jetzt frischen Wetterbericht rein, ziehe an Bord nochmal das aktuelle Wetter und stelle fest, ups, hier der Slot ist nochmal schlimmer geworden. Also meine Abflugszeit wurde nochmal um eine halbe Stunde nach hinten verschoben. Ich stehe gleich, lasse die Gäste aber schon einsteigen. Die APU hinten, das Hilfstriefwerk, was, Klimaanlage und sowas. Braucht auch Kraftstoff plus, warum ist das Wetter schlechter geworden? Oder warum ist das Slot schlechter geworden? Oha, das Wetter, die Gewitter sind jetzt schon da, die sollten doch erst in einer halben Stunde kommen. Also ich anfange, ok, jetzt muss ich nochmal nachtanken. Oder ich tank lieber nochmal sicher noch mal nach, lass den Tankwagen nochmal kommen, lass nochmal nachtanken. Mit Gästen an Bord gibt es auch ein Protokoll, was man einhalten muss. Manchmal muss die Feuerwehr informiert sein, die steht daneben. Je nach Flughäfen, die Flughäfen haben ihre eigene Regelung. Das sehen wir in unseren Unterlagen, wie das ist mit Flughäfen, wie die konkreten Flughäfen sind an dem Flughafen. Aber anders als so ein großes Schiff, was irgendwo in den Hafen einläuft, wo dann der Lotse an Bord geht und alle Besonderheiten erkehrt, müssen wir aus unseren Unterlagen herauslesen, was ist an diesem Flughafen jetzt besonders und anders und irgendwas in der Art.
Da hilft dann natürlich die Erfahrung, weil irgendwann hat man sie alle gesehen.
Und wenn es dann so speziell ist, dann manche Flughäfen brauchen auch eine Einweisung, um dahin zu fliegen.
Man muss sozusagen auch noch zugelassen sein für...
Ja, gewisse Flughäfen muss man zugelassen.
Warum? Weil die jetzt so geografisch problematisch sind?
Geografisch problematisch. Also konkret Innsbruck. Ich bin nach Innsbruck geflogen. Und Innsbruck braucht man eine Einweisung. Man muss dort vor...
Fett im Tal, dicke Berge drumherum.
Man muss einen speziellen Anflugweg wählen. Es gibt spezielle Anflugverfahren, wie ich da reinkomme. Es gibt lokale Wetterphänomen für Innsbruck jetzt konkret, die Flug sehr unangenehm oder störend machen lassen kann, wenn ich nicht weiß, was da passiert. Abwindeturvalenzen, wenn es Föhn gibt und der Wind über den Brenner kommt, dann wird es in Innsbruck sehr speziell. Und dann...
Das steht mir gerade eine sehr spezielle Situation vor.
Ja, es wird halt sehr wackelig, turbulent. Da muss man wissen, dass man das lieber nicht macht, sonst hat man nachher alle Leute gegen sich nach der Landung. Und... Genau, da muss man vorher entweder mal mit hingeflogen sein oder im Simulator noch am besten diesen Flughafen konkret trainiert haben. Es gibt auch für gewisse Strecken, da braucht man eine Einweisung für, selbst lange Strecken. Wenn ich die konkret längsgefliegen möchte als Kommandant, muss ich eine Einweisung auf dieser Strecke haben. Generell muss ich auch für jedes Gebiet eine Einweisung haben, wobei im großflächigen, räumigen Gebiet. Ich rede jetzt hier von Europa, ich rede von Fernost, ich rede von Südamerika, Nordamerika, ich rede von Afrika. Da braucht man eine generelle Area-Einweisung auch. Die sind auch vorgeschrieben, dass ich mich da irgendwie auskenne. Nicht, dass ich mich dahinsetze und einfach mal nach Afrika fliege und dann feststelle, hier ticken die Uhren ja alle anders.
Okay, also man kann nicht mal einfach für irgendwas eingeteilt werden, sondern schon bei der Zuteilung muss natürlich bedacht werden von der Personalplanung, dass man jetzt auch nur Leute nimmt, die dann auch dürfen und können.
Ja, also sollten sie machen.
Das sind eine knappe Ressource, so Piloten, die dann in Innsbruck landen können?
Das wurde, glaube ich, nur für drei Jahre betrieben und wir waren, glaube ich, sechs Leute, die das gemacht haben.
Die Verbindung jetzt, die Linienverbindung?
Ja, die diese Linie geflogen haben. Es wurde aber auch nur dreimal die Woche bedient, also es war dann da zu stellen. Aber auch Visas und sowas ist auch so ein Problem, was man natürlich haben muss, teilweise.
Das hat der Frage noch nicht über nachgedacht. Ich dachte, man hat da vielleicht so eine generelle Pauschale. Piloten dürfen immer ankommen.
Es sind nicht nur Piloten, auch die Kabinenbesatzungen.
Also das Team halt, ja. Ach, die müssen ja sozusagen auch alle wirklich persönlich ein Visum haben?
Je nach Land. Also für China muss ein Visum eingetragen sein, aber das wird mehr oder weniger nicht im Pass eingetragen, sondern das wird in China sozusagen eingetragen. Da wird der Flugvorhab gemeldet mit der Besatzung. Und die gucken dann gleich ihre Liste ab. Ja, die sind bei uns schon mal gemeldet worden, die haben ein Visum, die dürfen dahin fliegen. Das habe ich jetzt nicht im Pass drinne stehen. Für Amerika habe ich ein Visum im Pass drinne stehen, ein spezielles C1-Visum. Das weist mich als Co-Mitglied aus, mit dem kann ich da einfliegen. Ohne vor diese ganze Esther und diesen ganzen Quatsch da, sondern ich kann ad hoc ohne großartiges Bomborium eingetauscht werden und kann nach Amerika fliegen, USA fliegen.
Nur in der Rolle als Pilot?
Nur in der Rolle als Pilot.
Okay, also wenn du jetzt so normal als Gast bist, dann muss ich den ganzen Kram schlafen machen.
Ja, genau.
Beine breit und schön durchsuchen lassen.
Ja, genau. Wenn ich als Pilot in Amerika ausreibe, als Crew ausreise, dann müssen wir auch durch die Sicherheitskontrolle durch. Wie jeder andere Gast auch. Und je nach Land. Ich hab doch gesagt, ich darf Flüssigkeit mitnehmen. In England nicht. In England wird mir auch mein Wasserglas abgenommen, meine Wasserflasche. Aha, da ist Paranoia. Ich erwähne jetzt nicht, dass zur Sicherhausrüstung jedes Flugzeuges eine Notachs, eine Brecheisen und so Sachen zugehören. Da würde man ja auch erwarten. Ja, falls irgendetwas klemmt und ich irgendwo nach einer Landung oder ich kriege in der Luft die Cockpit-Tür verklemmt, die will ich ja irgendwie aufkriegen. Also habe ich eine Brechachs und einen Brecheisen, einen Kuhfuß gibt es an Bord. Der ist jetzt nicht für jeden zugänglich, aber trotzdem gibt es an Bord. Ich komme da ran, trotzdem wird mir aber mein kleines Taschenmesser abgenommen. Ich rede jetzt nicht über Sinn und Zweck. Das geht ja nur ums Gesetz sozusagen. Diese Notachs ist deshalb nicht gefährlich, weil sie ja bestandteil der Luftfahrzeug- Sicherheitsausrüstung ist. Deswegen ist es keine Notachs, sondern ein Sicherheitsausrüstungsgegenstand. Deswegen darf er ja auch mit an Bord genommen werden. Dann kann man sich juristisch daraus ziehen. Wir haben uns damit lange schon abgewöhnt. Das ist halt so. Wir sind jetzt an Bord.
Wir haben diese ganzen rechtlichen, das hatte ich noch gar nicht auf dem Zeig. Aber es ist ja logisch. Irgendwie kommen mal Leute angeflogen, kann ja jeder kommen. Aber zumindest ist es so halbwegs abgefedert und man muss jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit durch solche sinnlosen Prozesse gehen, wie sie jetzt schon für die Passagiere teilweise nur zumutbar sind. Sondern man hat also schnellere Zugang. Gut, das heißt, wir wollen ja eigentlich immer noch nach Rom. Genau. Jetzt haben wir also unseren Flugplan beisammen. Alles ist irgendwie ordentlich getankt. Man hat sich abgestimmt mit dem Team. Ist alles sauber. Das Klo ist geleert. All diese Dinge, die man gerne sichergestellt haben möchte, sind sozusagen getan. Jetzt hat es ja schon angesprochen, dass es dann natürlich auch nochmal so eine Checkliste gibt. Das meint man ja zu kennen, diesen Vorgang. Man kitzert irgendwo und geht eine lange Liste durch von Dingen. Was muss man denn alles überprüfen, um wirklich losfliegen zu können?
Das ist von Flugzeug-Typ recht unterschiedlich.
Das ist nicht unbedingt auf jedes einzelne Detail. Was ist bei den Flugzeugen üblicherweise noch mal explizit zu prüfen?
Grundsätzlich bereitet man den Flug bis zur Landung schon vorab vor. Mittlerweile haben selbst so ein alles Ding wie die 737, die hat ein FMS, ein Flugwegrechner, den kann ich vorab, den Flugplan, den ich ja vorher in Papierform hab, kann ich also eingeben dort. Die Strecke, die ich fliegen möchte, den gebe ich die Gewichte ein. Dann habe ich einen elektronischen Flugplan, den er mir in meinem Notifikationsdisplay vorab darstellen kann, eingegeben. Von dem Moment an weiß ich, weiß der Flugzeug, welche Route es später fliegen gehört. Ich habe alles vorweg programmiert.
Da ist ja dann sozusagen auch die Teilnehmer, also man weiß ja auch, wie viele Passagiere sind an Bord.
Das ist vorab schon, das Gewicht wird vorab schon in diesem Flughafen mit eingerechnet.
Man weiß ja nicht, was die wiegen.
Da werden schon Standgewichte genommen. Also wenn ein Gewicht, ein Passagier spontan mehr an Bord kommt, also wir haben, sagen wir mal, mit 120 gerechnet. Wir sind jetzt 121, weil einer ist noch last minute technisch gekommen. Der wird mit 100 Kilo berechnet. 100 Kilo, weil man sagt, er hat mit Handgepäck.
Ja, und was haben so 100 Kilo für eine Auswirkung auf so eine Spritplanung?
Sagen wir mal so, je nachdem wie die Flugzeit ist. Ich greife mal jetzt heraus. Das hat ja, glaube ich, eine Tonne mehr an Gewicht. Also zehn solche Gäste hätte einen Mehrverbrauch gehabt auf dem Weg nach Rom vielleicht von 60 Kilo Sprit. Das tue ich jetzt nicht so viel an, aber das hattest du in den Reserven locker mit drin. Also das war nicht das Problem, das von denen eine Tonne schwerer war. Aber rein regulativ ist es so, dass wenn wir mehr als zwei Tonnen plötzlich schwerer waren, müssten wir einen neuen Flugplan rechnen, um diese Gewichte mit rein zu bringen.
Also wenn dir so mal eben noch mal so eine Schulklasse mitkommen will, das lässt sich mal nicht so ohne weiteres abfedern.
Das heißt nicht ohne weiteres abfedern. Insbesondere dann kann ja mal sein, wenn der Flug regelmäßig geht, alle Stunde oder so was, und dann fällt ein Flug aus, dann wird natürlich der nächste Flug extrem voll. Und dass er dann auch schwerer wird und dementsprechend. Aber das wird dann meistens auch schon gleich mit in der Planung. Die Planung kann relativ schnell sein. Der Flugplan ist mittlerweile innerhalb von einer Minute gerechnet. Das geht ratzfatz. Weil die Strecke, als es so ist, bleibt die gleiche. Es hat sich ja nur das Gewicht des Flugzeuges verändert.
Was läuft man jetzt wirklich so rum und tritt mal einmal gegen alle Reifen?
Es ist so, dass einer bereitet den Flug, das ist meistens so geregelt, dass derjenige, der fliegt, also wie gesagt, es sind ja zwei Leute da vorne, er ist Offizier und Kapitän. Einer hat die Funktion immer, dass das Flugzeug physisch steuert. Sei das nun, dass er die Hand am Steuergriff nimmt und den Flieger damit lenkt oder den Autopiloten bedient. Und der andere arbeitet ihm zu und macht den Funkverkehr. Diese Rolle wechselt meistens immer abwechselnd. Der Erstoffizier kann rein von seiner Ausbildung her alles kann der Flugzeug genauso landen wie der Kapitän auch. Da besteht kein Unterschied. Es besteht manchmal so rechtliche Dinge, dass wenn es eine Landung bei sehr, sehr schlechten Sichtbedingungen unterhalb von 550 Metern Sicht ist, dann muss der Kapitän die Landung durchführen, die dann meist gar nicht von ihm selber, sondern vom Autopiloten gemacht wird, weil es auch so vorgeschrieben ist. Aber so ist es halt vorgeschrieben, dass dann der Erfahrenere sitzt und mit der Situation umgeht. Dann gibt es noch Firmenregelungen, die sagen, bei dem und dem Wetter soll der Kapitän das Flugzeug lenden. Das heißt nicht, dass der Co-Piloten das nicht auch konnte, aber das ist einfach, um den erfahrenen Menschen ein bisschen in die Hand zu geben. Das hat man vorher schon ausgelotet, übrigens auch schon beim Gespräch. Was willst du fliegen? Oh, ich hatte immer Lust hinzufliegen. Gut, dann fliegst du hin nach Rom. Oder logisch dann den Weg zurück zum Beispiel, wenn es dann wieder von Rom wieder zurückgeht. Derjenige, der den Route fliegt, bereitet meistens den Flug so computertechnisch vor, also füttert das FMS, den Avigationsrechner. Der andere geht dann einmal außen rum. Oder bei manchen Fluggesellschaften geht immer der Kapitän außen rum, um den Flieger herum und tritt mal, wie du sagst, einmal so überall gegen die Reifen.
Ernsthaft?
Nein, kann er machen, sieht cool aus, aber im Prinzip, guck da nur, ist alles heil. Vorher sollte man schon möglichst alle Pumpen angemacht haben. Alle Pumpen angemacht haben an einem Flieger, sind alles, was irgendwo Druck liefert, Kraftstoffpumpen an, Hydraulikpumpen sind an. Dann gehst du nämlich einmal außen rum.
Um zu gucken, ob nicht irgendeine Leckage ist oder so.
Mehr kannst du eigentlich auch nicht machen. Oder ist da irgendeiner? Das gibt es auch. Manche Panels sind zugeschraubt. Es kann auch sein, dass eine sich dann in den Wochen manchmal so ausfibriert hat. Aber dann kommt die Technik vorbei, schraubt die Schraube wieder rein. Oder so ein Panel kann ruhig eine Schraube fehlen, das fährt nicht gleich runter. Das ist alles sehr robust gebaut. Interessant sind die Reifen. Das guckt man sich immer an. Nämlich hat der Reifen eine Art Schnitt drin.
Das kann bei der letzten Landung schon passiert sein.
Genau, das kann bei der letzten Landung schon passiert sein. Wie sehen die Bremsen aus? Da sind so Pins drin, die sagen mir an, wie weit diese Bremse schon abgenutzt ist. So ein Führungsstift. Wenn ich sehe, die wird schon knapp, dann kann ich schon langsam mal überlegen oder vorplanen. Also diesen Flug kann ich noch machen. Da gibt es Tabellen, kann ich reingucken. Ich kann noch fliegen, aber ich weiß jetzt schon, wenn wir zurück aus Rom sind, kann ich die Bremse wechseln. Das darf ich nicht mehr machen. Da ist immer noch ein Puffer drin. Für die Zuhörer hier. Aber dann wird es schon vorsichtig.
Aber es gibt schon mal eine Indikation, dass man es schon mal machen kann und darf. Und dann fährt man gar nicht erst in die Reserve rein.
Genau. Reifen ist sehr interessant. Ob man sich da irgendwas eingetreten hat. Letztens hab ich da eine Schraube reingedreht. Die lag wahrscheinlich irgendwo rum. Und wir sind da reingefahren und Reifen wurde gewechselt. Das sind Klassiker, die da irgendwie passieren. Passiert nicht häufig, aber es passiert.
Wie oft findest du überhaupt was?
Ähm, das ist eine gute Frage. Aus dem Bauch sagen auch erst bei jedem 50. Flug. Ist denn irgendwas, wo irgendwas passieren muss. Oder wo zumindest eine vorbeikommt.
Das ist ja schon so selten, dass man schon so ein bisschen dazu tendiert zu sagen, ist ja eh nichts. Oder denkst du, wie gut ist das trainiert, diese Wachheit wirklich immer damit rechnen zu können?
Das ist schon gut trainiert. Also man sollte das wirklich machen. Das wird auch nicht ausgelassen. Es gehört mit dazu. Es ist Teil der Checkliste, dass man außen rumgeht und guckt, ob alles okay ist. Das Auslassen ist nicht drinne. Es passiert natürlich schon, dass die Gäste einsteigen, und wir können anlassen. Scheiße, ich war nicht außen rum. Mist, ich war nicht außen rum. Kacke. Also einmal außen rumgehen, gucken, ob alles okay ist. Und dann ist alles okay. Dann kannst du gleich losfahren. Aber wenn was nicht okay ist, heißt dann Verspätung.
Aus der Weifen und Bremsen schon mal was gefunden?
Kraftstoffleckage, zwei, dreimal. Das war dann leckt, lief raus, war irgendwas untig geworden. Und dann tropfte das so ein bisschen. Ölleckage, Hydraulik. Interessanterweise gibt es aber auch da Sachen, wo man guckt, wie viele Tropfen in der Minute gibt es da. Aha, bis acht Tropfen in der Minute sind okay. Für einen Flug, der weniger als zwei Stunden dauert. Das sind große Maschinen mit viel Technik. Und Sachen dran, das ist kein sauber gewischter... Das ist eine große Maschine mit Hydraulik, mit allen möglichen Sachen dran. Manchmal kommt man schon mit ölverschmierten Händen zurück.
Das ist so.
Ja, hört sich ein bisschen komisch an. Aber es ist überall Dreck dran. Man kann Gummiband abrieben. Wenn man irgendwas anfasst, wenn man irgendwo hängen bleibt, hat man gleich ein schwarzes Hemd. Und es kommt manchmal auch so ein bisschen... Hast du schon mal die Vorflügel und all diese ganzen Klappen, die da rausfahren, die sind ja auch hydraulisch betätigt. Und da sind hydraulische Stößel drinne. Und die sind nie 100% dicht. Da kann schon mal sein, dass ein Tropfen Öl so rausleckt und dann sich gesammelt hat in irgendeinem kleinen Löchlein. Und dann, wenn die Klappe dann wieder runterfährt, dann leckt das ein bisschen raus und wird dann so ein bisschen vom Wind nach hinten gezogen oder irgendwas. Das ist normal. Auch das Triebwerköl verbraucht, wie jeder Motor verbraucht Öl, verbraucht das Triebwerk auch Öl.
Aber da ist halt auch viel redundanzen in diesem ganzen System.
Ja, für die Zuhörer, das ist alles extrem redundant aufgebaut. Und wenn man da jetzt sagen würde, so ein Baggerfahrer gehen würde und sagte, ich muss jeden Tag drei Lüde Öl reinkippen, dann würde er wahrscheinlich rüber lachen, weil das für ihn völlig normal ist. Wir reden hier von acht Tropfen in einer Minute. Und das wäre dann okay für einen Zwei-Stunden-Flug. Mit anderen Worten ist da am Ende dann, ich sage mal so ein Schnapsglas Öl rausgelaufen. Und abends wird das dann gemacht, sozusagen. Dann wird dann dieses Leck behoben. Also so muss man sich das vorstellen.
Also in der Regel notiert man das dann und gibt das dem Technik-Team?
Genau. Man ignoriert das nicht. Das wollte ich schon. Das wird nicht ignoriert. Es gibt auch so klassische Eintragungen wie machte Motto, macht mir mal bitte den hinteren Teil des Rumpfes unten sauber. Da sind irgendwelche alten Schmierspuren dran. Ich kann nicht sehen, ob neue dazugekommen sind.
Aber es gibt ja auch so Sachen, die man jetzt als Blut gar nicht sehen kann. Was weiß ich. Also Risse im Flugzeug, Haarrisse und so weiter.
Wir sind aber regelmäßige Überprüfungen des Flugzeugs. Da gibt es verschiedene Checks, die gemacht werden müssen. Das Flugzeug selber wird von der Technik in regelmäßigen Intervallen überprüft. Alle so und so viele Stunden kommt der Check. Alle so und so viele Stunden oder Flugstunden oder Start und Landung kommt der. Check. Der Flugzeug wird komplett auseinandergenommen. Die kritischen Stellen, die am Flugzeug da sind, werden auf Haare zerpüft.
Also so richtig auseinandergenommen?
Nein, der Flug wird nicht abmontiert, aber meistens Landeklappen werden abgebaut, Fahrwerke ausgebaut, die ganzen Sitze kommen raus, Instrumente werden teilweise ausgebaut, sodass man alle Panels dahinter rankommen kann und die werden mit Sichtkontrollen geguckt. Es gibt auch so Lacken, die man aufsprühen kann, ob man dann Risse sehen kann. Röntgenkontrolle wird sehr viel gemacht. Mit mobilen Röntgenbisariten wird dann geguckt, ob es Risse drin haben. Der sogenannte Daycheck dauert mehrere Monate. Der wird das Struktur völlig auseinandergenommen und wieder zusammengebaut.
Und wahrscheinlich in dem Moment aber auch modernisiert. Das ist dann wahrscheinlich der Zeitpunkt, wo dann gegebenenfalls, kann ja sein, dass wir da wieder irgendwelche neuen Sicherheitsbestimmungen, Austausch von irgendwelchen Subsystemen erlauben oder zumindest sowas.
Genau, das kann gut passieren, ist aber nicht so häufig. Generell, auch wenn man sagt hier, ein schönes Beispiel ist, glaube ich, der Airbus 310, 300. Der hatte in seiner Elektronik drinne, der hatte auch schon Bildschirme. Das war der erste, der mit so einem Glas Cockpit kam. Und basierte sehr viel seine Software, der darauf hatte, auf EPROMs, wenn du das mal versagst. Ja, die programmierbaren ROMs, wo man halt einfach einen festen Speicher, wie man ein Brennbuss hat. Es gibt die noch, habe ich mir gesagt, dass ich gerade mit einem Twitter darüber geschattet habe. Aber das ist jetzt nicht mehr der technische Standard.
Nö, aber ein praktisches Teil. Da steckt man halt einfach in seinen EPROMer und dann kann man da was Neues reinfahren, steckt man wieder zurück und dann hat man die Daten.
Der Airbus wurde Anfang der 80er bis jetzt immer noch mit diesen EPROMs betrieben, weil der Flugzeug darauf zugelassen ist. Funktioniert, um die Zulassung zu ändern, also neue Testprogramme, Flüge etc. mit einem anderen FMS-System, was man anders programmierbar ist, wo man die Software anders reinkriegen kann, wird nicht mehr, es würde viel zu teuer werden, das Ding abzudehnen. Also fährt man teilweise noch mit sehr alter Technik darum, aber das funktioniert. Muss ja nicht schlecht sein. Und dementsprechend, wenn so ein Flugzeug in D-Jacket es wird jetzt nicht vorne auf einmal, oh das Kocker sieht ja jetzt modern aus, wir hatten jetzt mechanische Uhren drin, und jetzt haben wir einen Bildschirm, toll, das wird nicht passieren.
Weil es bleibt technisch immer noch das selbe System, weil ja darauf auch alle geeicht sind, aber es wird sozusagen alles, was dann wirklich brüchig geworden ist, Gummidichtung, all dieser Kram, die Sachen werden wahrscheinlich immer einfach so generell schon mal ausgetauscht.
Es gibt natürlich laufende Tauschen, irgendwelche Filter, Ölfilter, Luftfilter, Zonenfilter und sowas, sie werden teilweise, wir müssen im regelmäßigen Betrieb schon getauscht werden.
Genau, und es kann natürlich auch sein, dass die Fluggesellschaften was, was ich neue Vorstellungen davon haben will, der Sitz rein abteilen zu sein, toll.
Das ist das, also die Kabine wird garantiert abgerätet, die kriegt meistens ein hübsches oder ein besseres Design, aber da werden Pendels ausgetauscht, damit es halt neu aussieht.
So, was wird noch so gewartet?
Ganz besonders werden die Triebwerke gewartet. Das Flugzeug hat einen sogenannten eigenen Life-Cycle, wie viele Starts und Landungen es machen kann, ab so und so viele Cycles, damit immer ein Start und Landung mit bezeichnet, müssen die und die Überprüfungen gemacht werden. Unabhängig davon hat das Fahrwerk einen Life-Cycle, wo es überprüft werden muss. Und genauso die Lerneklappen, weil die kann man auch komplett abbauen, sind dann das eigene System sozusagen. Auch die haben einen eigenen Life-Cycle. Und ganz besonders natürlich die Triebwerke. Aber die Triebwerke werden nicht abgebaut, um dann, wie sie untersuchen, und dann wieder ranzubauen und festzustellen, war ja alles okay. Sondern die Triebwerke werden kontinuierlich beobachtet. Es ist so, dass das Flugzeug alle halbe Stunde, glaube ich, ist das eingestellt. Je nach Operator, Betreiber sendet das Flugzeug einen technischen Bericht über Arcas, über Flugfunk sozusagen, über digitalen Funk an die Bodenstation. Und läuft dann bei der Firmenzentrale oder bei dem technischen Support von den Triebwerken ein. Und wird dann überprüft, ob alles noch okay ist. Das wird praktisch kontinuierlich gemonitort. Wie ist die Drehzahl bei der Temperatur? Hat es den oder den Abgaswert? Und dadurch kann man schon über die Jahre, denn ich rede wirklich von Jahren, einen Trend verfolgen, wie weit das Triebwerk noch performt. Es werden regelmäßig mal so, auch alle so und so viele Flugstunden, Boroskopkontrollen gemacht. Also dann gehen sie rein mit so einem Boroskop und gucken nach, ob alles okay ist. Es wird Ölfilter, Ölproben genommen, ob da irgendwelche Metallteile drin sind und sowas in der Art. Aber generell kann das sein, dass das Triebwerk an dem Flugzeug über mehrere Jahre montiert ist und läuft und funktioniert. Mit denselben Schaufeln, mit dem allen. Uns wurden nur Komponenten ausgetauscht daran. Mal wegen Generator oder Ölpumpe oder Filter sowieso. Aber das Triebwerk selber bleibt relativ lang da. Manchmal wird es mittlerweile auch gewaschen. Mit heißem Wasser wird Wasser durchgepustelt. Dann wird es ein bisschen von schleimigen Sinterstoffen. Oder irgendwas, wenn es ein bisschen sauberer wird. Aber das ist so ganz wichtig. Das ist ganz gut. Aber es kann sein, dass so ein Triebwerk über zehn Jahre an so einem Flugzeug hängt. Und dort einmal einwandfrei funktioniert.
Das heißt, so ein Triebwerk ist einfach auch mit das Flugzeug sozusagen, das ist so der Kern.
Der Kern ist ein wesentlicher Bestandteil, das am besten sicherheitstechnisch überprüft wird natürlich. Also dann haben wir das Flieger überprüft.
Genau, wir gehen mal davon aus, dass alles okay ist.
Das eine ist außen rumgegangen, das andere hat, es werden noch andere Systeme hochgefahren, das wäre das Navigationssystem. Das Trägerts-Navigationssystem, das eigene, das Flugzeug wird hochgefahren, das braucht 10, 12 Minuten, bis es sich komplett initialisiert hat. Man sieht auf die Erddrehung Rotation, stellt es fest, welche Breitengrad ich bin, und es ist eine unabhängige Plattform, die mir sagt, wo ich mich gerade befinde. Egal, ob ich unabhängig von irgendwelchen Navigationsdaten, die ich habe. Es kann feststellen, in welche Richtung ich mich bewegt habe. Ausgehend von der Ursprungsposition kannst du mir sagen, wo ich gerade bin. Das ist wichtig über den Nordatlantik, weil da gibt es keinen anderen Flugfunk mehr. Mittlerweile gibt es GPS, aber trotzdem sind die Systeme immer noch wesentlicher Bestandteil.
Was werten die aus? Also ist das mit diesem Rohr da vorne?
Das ist die Geschwindigkeit, die das Flugzeug in der Luft misst. Das andere, die haben Laserkreise drin. Früher waren es echte physische Kreise, mittlerweile sind es Laserkreisesysteme. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon mal irgendwo besprochen hast. Die feststellen Beschleunigungskräfte und Rotationskräfte, die auf das Flugzeug eingewirkt haben. Daran kannst du feststellen, wie es sich irgendwo hinbewegt hat. Also musst du nach IAS gucken, Initial Reference System. Oder ADIRS ist die Airbus-Variante, die haben dann gleich ein Luftmessersystem mit da drin. Genau, ich gucke auch, so gut, dass du sagst, was ich nicht nur gucke, sind Reifen. Ich gucke auch mir, wenn ich außen rum gehe, die sogenannten PITO-Rohre an, wie sie heißen. Das sind die Luftgeschwindigkeitsmesser. Das sind so kleine, beheizte Rohre, die haben ein kleines Löchlein. Die messen den Staudruck.
Das zeigt nach vorne und da trifft quasi die Luft auf.
Da trifft die Luft auf und da wird der Luftdruck gemessen, der auf das Flugzeug wirkt. Und gleichzeitig wird der statische Luftdruck gemessen, der auf das Flugzeug wirkt. Und darauf kann man dann berechnen, wie schnell das Flugzeug jetzt sich gerade bewegt. Und die Geschwindigkeit durch die Luft ist maßgeblich für die Aerodynamik, wie das Flugzeug sich aerodynamisch verhält. Die Geschwindigkeit über Grund ist beeinflusst von dem Wind, mit dem ich mich bewege. Das einzig wirklich Wichtigste ist die Geschwindigkeit, die ich mich selber durch die Luft bewege. Daran weiß ich, wie gut ich gerade Auftrieb erzeuge, in welcher Fluglage ich mich befinde und welche Leistungsdaten ich gerade zu erwarten habe.
Die Situation kann komplett anders sein, wenn ich über der Erde dieselbe Geschwindigkeit habe. Kann es aber komplett unterschiedlich sein, je nachdem, ob starker Wind von vorne oder von hinten kommt.
Ja, das ist so ein Trainingsaspekt, was immer passiert, wenn mir diese Daten fehlen. Wenn das Flugzeug auch nicht mehr weiß, wie schnell es ist, wie kann ich denn weiterfliegen? Und da ist die Geschwindigkeit über Grund nicht unbedingt hilfreich. Kann man nur ein bisschen interpolieren, wie schnell bewege ich mich eigentlich. Aber das ist so ein Notfalltraining, was wir machen. Aber generell ist es wichtig, dass diese Pidos sauber sind. Es gibt auch Fälle, dass da Insekten draufgespießt worden sind oder reingeflohen sind und wenn das kleine Loch zu ist, dann hab ich keine validen Daten mehr. Dann geht das nicht mehr.
Aber es gibt mehr als eins.
Wir haben vier Stück an Bord. Also da gibt es mehrfach abgesichert und sind auch da, wie alles, Red und Dann vorhanden. Ich fahre den Flieger hoch, um das mal den Begriff so anzuwenden. Dann nehme ich eine Checklist in der Hand, dann überprüfe ich, ob ich alles korrekt hochgefahren habe, die Schalter alle in der richtigen Stellung sind. Mittlerweile wird hinten alles sauber gemacht. Die Gäste steigen ein. Wir bei der Flugsicherung fragen dann irgendwann, wenn es denn losgehen soll, möglichst am besten pünktlich. Fragen wir nach der Anlassfreigabe. Das ist vorgeschrieben, dass Jet-Flugzeuge immer fragen, wann sie die Triebwerke anlassen dürfen sozusagen. Dann kann der Fluglose immer nochmal ad hoc sagen, du, hier ist gerade hier besonders los, Flughafen wollen gerade viele abfliegen, in 10 Minuten habe ich Platz für dich frei. In 10 Minuten darfst du die Triebwerke anlassen. Kursformen anlassen der Triebwerke, nehme ich noch eine Checklist in der Hand. Die meistens, also die Before-Star-Checklist, gucke ich nochmal, ist alles gemacht, ist das Antikollusionswarnlicht an, dieses rote Blinklicht, was an jedem Flugzeug immer blinkt. Obwohl wir das alle natürlich so oft gemacht haben, dass alles irgendwie auswendig können, nehmen wir für alle diese Kleinigkeiten Checklisten in die Hand. Dann, um nichts zu vergessen. Dann rede ich mit meiner Bodenbesatzung unten. Die Bodencrew, die die Flieger vorbereitet hat, die den beladen hat, die ordnungsgemäß, die haben auch eine Einweisung, wie sie die Gepäcknetze zumachen müssen, wie sie die Frachttür zumachen müssen. Meistens rede ich dann auch mit einem Schlepperfahrer, einem Pushbackfahrer, der unten an meinem Flieger sich angekoppelt hat, hoffentlich rechtzeitig angekommen ist. Oftmals rollt man ja in eine Position rein, steckt mit der Nase drinne und man muss rückwärts wieder rausgeschoben werden.
Und rückwärts kann so ein Flugzeug nicht?
Es gibt Flugzeuge, die können das. Das sind meistens Flugzeuge mit Turboprops, also die große Propeller haben. Es gab früher Jets, die das machen durften, aber es wird immer mehr und mehr restriktiver an den Flughäfen gehandhabt, weil es irgendwie auch laut ist. Weil dieser Umkehrschub ist nicht so effektiv, das heißt, die müssen immer sehr viel Gas geben. Und beim Jet ganz besonders, es gab so Flughäfen in Amerika, da sind die mit so einer kleinen DC-8, die DC-9, die Kleine, haben sie mit Umkehrschub sind zurückgefahren. Das muss einen Höllen lachen. Da wird halt alles gewackelt, aber das macht man heute nicht mehr. Das ist einfach nicht mehr zeitgemäß.
Dafür gibt es diese kleinen super flatten Teile, die sich so quasi um das Vorderrad herumschlingen und da, weiß ich nicht, begreifen die das?
Es gibt zwei Varianten. Es gibt die mit der Stange, dass ich eine Schleppstange hab, die vorne reingehängt wird und an dem Schleppstangenfahrer selber. Der schiebt mich einfach rückwärts raus. Es gibt diejenigen, die fahren links und rechts um den Vorderrad rum, schieben von hinten und von vorne so einen Schlitten unter die Räder und heben dann das Buchrad an, sodass das Buchrad in der Luft ist. Dann können sie mich genauso zurückschieben, anheben und können mich rückwärts oder vorwärts ziehen. Das ist dann kein Problem. Das tun auch die mit der Stange selber. Wenn du zurückgeschoben wirst, sie drehen halt das Buchrad mit. Das muss man sich natürlich bewusst sagen. Also da gibt's, schreibe ich gerade ab, also wie gesagt, ich werde zurückgeschoben. Da muss ich mir auch eine Freigabe für holen bei dem Vorfeldkontrolle, weil wir beide können nicht nach hinten rausgucken im Cockpit. Das kann zwar die Bodencrew machen, aber auch die Bodencrew weiß nicht, ob gerade jemand in den nächsten einer Minute da jemand rausrollt. Und dementsprechend holst du da auch eine Freigabe. Meistens beim Zurückstoßen lässt man schon die Triebwerke an.
Also es gab ja dieses kleine Test-Triebwerk, um sozusagen überhaupt erst mal so die Grundversorgung zu machen. Aber wenn so ein Flugzeug steht, hat es doch auch eine eigene Stromversorgung oder nicht?
Nein, das ist die APU sozusagen. Die APU ist meistens im Heck des Flugzeuges untergebracht. Die versorgt den Flieger mit Strom und mit pneumatischer Luft für die Klimaanlage.
Das heißt, man kriegt nicht vom Flughafen noch mal einen Stecker und sagt, hier ist Strom?
Doch, aber man kann mit Strom die Triebwerke nicht anlassen. Man braucht Druckluft zum Anlassen der Triebwerke. Das sind Druckluftanlasser.
Das heißt, diese kleine Maschine, die kann man mit Strom starten?
Und die hat dann auch genügend Strom und Druckluft, um die großen Triebwerke zu starten.
Also das Ding ist sozusagen für die Grundversorgung, aber eben auch als Anlasser quasi für die großen Dinge erforderlich.
Genau, genau. Meistens ist es so, dass wenn man irgendwo reinrollt mit so einem kleineren Flugzeug, dass man an die Parkposition reinkommt. Und das erste, was die Kollegen vom Boden machen, ist, die stecken den Stromstecker, den du vermisst jetzt, den stecken sie rein, sodass man dann die Triebwerke ausschaltet und hat mal eine Stromversorgung. Das Flugzeug funktioniert einwandfrei weiter, weil man auch Lärm und alles reduzieren möchte. Allerdings kurz vorm Anlassen, man braucht nicht das Triebwerk. Wenn die Gäste einigsteigen und irgendwann da 130 Leute hinten drin sitzen, dann wird es sehr schnell stickig und sehr schnell warm. Dann möchte man auch eine Klimaanlage haben.
Und das wäre jetzt mit Stromanlagen nicht machbar?
Nein, die Klimaanlage funktioniert mit Luft. Das sind eher Cycle-Maschinen. Da wird mit Hilfe von Druckluft die Luft komprimiert. Dann wird sie in korporiertem Zustand abgekühlt und dann wieder entspannt. Dadurch kühlt sie sich weiter ab und kann dann als Klimaanlagenluft verwendet werden.
Das passiert alles auf dem Druck, den diese Turbine erzeugt?
Auf dem Druckluft, den die Turbine erzeugt. So funktionieren in der Regel die Klimaanlagen. Mittlerweile schon moderne Systeme, die funktionieren doch wieder elektrisch, aber das ist die allerletzte, neuesten Generation von Flugzeugen.
Aber diese kleine Maschine ist wichtig, gerade beim Start muss sie irgendwann einfach mal angelassen werden, sonst kriegt man die großen Dinge überhaupt gar nicht hin. Aber während man noch steht und erst mal aus der Parkposition raus muss, da sind jetzt die großen auch noch nicht an?
Nein, das kleine Ding kann natürlich auch kaputt sein. Ja, auch das kann kaputt sein. Und dann startet man mindestens ein Triebwerk an der Position, weil man bekommt nämlich die Druckluft zum Starten von einem speziellen Druckluft-Starterwagen.
Ah, es gibt da Starthilfe sozusagen.
Es gibt Starthilfe. Meistens ist da drinne eine sogenannte APU auch drin eingebaut. Die ist unheimlich laut. Meistens in so einem kleinen VW-Bus oder irgendwas ist so ein Ding eingebaut, produziert dann in so einem kleinen Schlauch, so fausgroß, dick ist der Durchmesser, liefert Druckluft für den Druckluft-Starter des Triebwerks.
Aber diese APU ist sozusagen für den Flug, wenn man erstmal die großen anhat, ist egal, weil dann liefern die für die Klimaanlage an, das ist sozusagen nur, damit man nicht die großen die ganze Zeit laufen lassen muss.
Genau.
Okay, aber das ist jetzt glaube ich auch nicht so häufig, dass diese APU kaputt geht, oder?
Nein, nicht so häufig, aber es passiert. Also ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, ich weiß nicht mehr wann das passiert ist, ich kann mich schon noch erinnern, dass es vor zwei Monaten war es mal wieder so weit, da war das Ding kaputt. Passiert. Man will ja trotzdem den Flugzeug irgendwie betreiben und dann macht man das. Es ist ja wie gesagt nur ärgerlich halt zum Anlassen.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht systemlich flugkritisch.
Nein, das ist nicht zu kritisch. Es ist natürlich ein Redundant, weil es hat einen Generator, also falls ein Generator kaputt gehen sollte, habe ich da hinten einen APU-Generator, der geht, mit dem kann ich diesen Generator dann ersetzen. Das ist natürlich eine schöne Sache. Die habe ich in dem Sinne dann verloren, aber es ist nicht etwas, was mich jetzt operationell am Ende einschränkt.
Wir sind ja im Prinzip noch so ein bisschen am Sammeln, was muss erfüllt sein, um wirklich ausrollen zu können?
Wie man aus der Praxis zurück?
Ja, also überhaupt erstmal losfahren zu dürfen. Aber du hast ja die Checkliste erwähnt, die bezieht sich ja jetzt nicht nur auf die Außensachen, sondern muss ja wahrscheinlich auch im Cockpit selber. Also die Funktion des Cockpits wird ja wahrscheinlich auch gecheckt.
Das hast du ja vorher schon gemacht. Das hast du mit dem Hochfahren des Flugzeugs. Das hast du alle Geräte soweit überprüft. Denn vorm Anlassen musst du die Klimalager ausschalten, damit du genügend Luft hast zum Anlassen. Und teilweise wird das auch durch eine Checkliste überprüft, die man auf Flugzeugtüren übt. Ob alle Lichter, die vorgeschrieben ist, drin sind, ob man den einen Transponder, ob man den eingeschaltet hat. Das ist dieses, was Flightradar 24 benutzt. Zur Position hat man das alles eingeschaltet, gewisse Komponenten, die vorgeschrieben sind vor dem Betrieb. Die hat man alles dann in die entsprechende Zustand gebracht, überprüft das mit der Checkliste. Man hat seine Beladungspapiere bekommen, auch ganz wichtig, hab ich ganz vergessen, wie viel Gewicht wir aktuell drin haben. Und alles, mit dem fördern wir auch noch mal unseren Bordcomputer.
Also das ganze Gepäck, was quasi eingeliefert wird, das wird auch explizit gewogen. Also da hat man wirklich eine konkrete Ansage, wie viel das ist.
Also bei uns wäre das bei Standard-Zielen nicht, aber wenn man mehr hat, also wenn es Container sind, die werden gewogen. Wenn man weiß, es gibt gewisse Flughäfen, ich sag mal jetzt mal so ein Flug nach Moskau, da haben die Leute immer irgendwie mehr Gepäck drin. Da sind die Koffer größer, weil die irgendwie mehr eingekauft haben. Da sind dann das durchschnittliche Gepäckgewicht höher eingerechnet als für einen Flug, der jetzt von Köln nach München geht.
Aber werden nicht sowieso alle Koffer heutzutage gewogen?
Die werden geräumt, aber nicht unbedingt gewogen.
Aber beim Einchecken doch.
Ich glaube, da werden sie aber nur gewogen, ob du denn zu viel hast wegen Gepäck. Achso, das wird nicht gespeichert? Also ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, nein. Das Flughäfensystem, denn seine Daten irgendwie übermittelt an das Lot und Wellersmuseum von englischen Airlines mit Protokollen über... Ne, vergiss es, das funktioniert nicht. Da denke ich zu Zukunft. Da denkst du zu Zukunft, sorry. Dieses Netzwerk, was du da am Kopf hast, wenn du das über... Dann wirst du umkippen, weil du denkst, was ist alles nicht wuchsend hier.
Na gut, das muss natürlich dann auch zuverlässig sein und so weiter, keine Frage. Ich würde mir das jetzt einfach mal so vorgestellt.
Und sei das nur, dass irgendein Datenschützer sagt, ne, das kann nicht sein, wir haben ja einen Namen und was damit schleppt dein Gewicht zusammen, ne, das können wir nicht machen. Ja, animisieren, ich weiß. Aber das wird nicht... Aber das Gepäck wird mittlerweile gerüncht. Das ist, war ja auch seit, ich glaube, das wird auch erst seit 15 Jahren irgendwas gemacht, dass das Gepäck auch gerüncht wird. Vorher hat man das Gepäck eingeladen und hat Stichproben gemacht. Mittlerweile wird jedes Gepäck auch genauso überprüft wie Handgepäck. Da darfst du allerdings deine Seife mit haben.
Ein Wunder. Okay, gut. Dann ist jetzt sozusagen alles gecheckt. Wir haben eine Vorstellung davon, wie das Gesamtgewicht nun tatsächlich ist. Letzte Möglichkeit, sozusagen die Tank-Situation nochmal zu passen.
Genau. Aber dann würdest du vorab schon eine Impfung bekommen. Aber es kann ja sein, dass jetzt heißt, wir sind doch drei Gäste nicht gekommen, dass du die sozusagen weißt, wie viele Gäste du an Bord hast. Das ist ja auch wichtig. Das muss ja auch nicht unbedingt mal sein, das ist ja auch immer so vollständig. Wieso wissen Sie nicht, welche Gäste an Bord waren, wie die mit dem Namen heißen? Ich meine ganz ehrlich, wie viele Leute, da hab ich schon Geschichten gehört, ich hab ein Ticket gekauft, möchtest du mit denen mal irgendwo fliegen? Das passiert ja dann oft, dass dann Leute sitzen, die das Ticket gar nicht gekauft haben, weil sie dann für einen Kumpel fliegen, weil der hat ja noch ein günstiges Ticket oder so was. Es ist zwar vorgeschrieben, dass man das irgendwie abgleicht, aber ob es dann auch wirklich immer alles funktioniert, weiß ich nicht. Aber was funktioniert, es wird genau gezählt, wer an Bord ist, wie viele Personen, ob es Kinder an Bord sind, das wird gezählt, oder ob es Babys sind, die an Bord sind. Die haben alle unterschiedliche Gewichte, werden die mit eingerechnet und das wird dann festgehalten und dann geht die Reise los.
Und ja auch speziellen Bedarf, also Kinder kann man ja auch so schön verschicken mittlerweile in Flugzeugen, finde ich ja auch ganz cool.
Du meinst als unbegleitete Kinder?
Als unbegleitete Kinder, genau.
Die kommen ja sogar als erstes an Bord meistens und werden auch als letztes wieder abgeholt oder von den Flugbegleiter-Kollegen auch namentlich an irgendeine andere Person übergeben und das wird genau festgehalten. Nicht, dass da irgendwie ein Kind an den Stiefvater oder an den geschiedenen Ex übergeben wird und der hätte das gar nicht abnehmen sollen. Gibt es all diese Dramen, gibt es da.
So, na dann kommen wir ja mal los. Was muss sozusagen der Flughafen noch signalisieren bevor es losgeht? Man muss ja dann sozusagen, also man hat ja seinen angemeldeten was haben wir gesagt? 12 Uhr fahren wir los. Worauf bezieht sich das 12 Uhr? Ist das sozusagen im Idealfall ist das der Moment, wo man ausrollt? Ist das der Moment, wo man startet? Wirklich oder?
Das Idealfall ist es der Moment, wo der Flieger sich zurückgestoßen wird oder anfängt die Triebwerke anzulassen, wenn er an einer Position steht, wo er nicht rausgeschoben werden muss und dann wo er direkt losfahren kann. Idealfall ist es der Moment, wo er losrollt. Die sogenannte Off-Block-Site, also dann, wo er von den Klötzen Off-Blocks runtergeht. Das sollte möglicherweise die planmäßige Abflugszeit sein. Das heißt, er wird aus der Parkposition zurückgestoßen. In der Zwischenzeit lassen wir die Triebwerke an. Die Triebwerke werden mit Druckluft angelassen. Nach dem Anlassen der Triebwerke wird geguckt, sind alle Systeme korrekt? Übernimmt arbeiten die Generatoren der Triebwerke, übernehmen sie die Stromversorgung? Wir fahren die Landeklappen schon aus, die Startklappen schon mal aus für den Start. Der Kollege unten macht den Schlepper, befreit ihn ab, guckt, ob alles frei ist, schließt sein Headset, macht alles ab, macht die Klappe außen zu, zieht den sogenannten Pin ab, mit dem man das Buch verwergt. Das habe ich ja erzählt, das bewegt sich, wenn ich die Stange oder den Schlepper unten habe und schiebe zurück, dann bewegt sich auch das Buchrad, weil er einfach zwangsläufig das Buchrad sich mitbewegt. Dazu muss die Steuerung, die ich habe, um das Buchrad zu steuern, deaktiviert sein. Die muss drucklos sein, sonst würden sie ja gegeneinander arbeiten. Hält mir dann, bereitet den Flieger zum Abbräulen vor, zeigt mir diesen Pin meistens in der Hand, mit so einer roten Fahne dran, dass er den Pin abgezogen hat, damit weiß ich, dass ich steuern kann. Und gibt mir das Freizeichen, dass nichts mehr um mich herum steht, dass er nicht noch von den Leuten einen Klotz in der Hand hat und den noch wegzieht oder irgendwas im Weg ist. Ich sehe es ja nicht. Das ist immer noch ein optisches Signal, was er mir gibt, Daumen hoch, ich winke aus dem Cockpit zurück. Der Kollege neben mir holt die Rollfreigabe. Der Flughafen sagt dann, bitte roll über den Weg. Meistens, weil auf den anderen Weg kommt einer einem entgegen. Dann gibt er die Rollfreigabe, dass du losrollen kannst. Dann rollen wir zur Startbahn.
Man muss sich da in so eine Warteschleife ein... Es gibt oft so eine Warteschlange von all den startenden Flugzeugen.
In Hamburg ist es jetzt nicht so. Da steht man vielleicht mal so 10 Minuten, das ist schon lange, wenn man an der Bahn steht. Andere Flughäfen wie London, es ist schon teilweise deutlich mehr. Da steht man dann auch schon mal 20, 25 Minuten, bis man da in der Reihe kriegt, weil die ganze Schlange sich so hintereinander schlängeln, sich immer mehr zur Startbahn vorarbeitet. Ja, das ist manchmal sehr viel. Ich glaube, die längste Rollzeit, die ich mal hatte, war in New York. Das war eine Stunde und 35.
War es wirklich vom Terminal weg?
Vom Terminal bis anderthalb Stunden gebraucht. Da wird es auch schon ernst, weil man steht da mit laufenden Triebwerken, dass man sich überlegt, gerade wenn es eine Viermod ist, lassen wir mal wieder zwei ausschalten. Das verbraucht mir hier zu viel. Das habe ich jetzt nicht so unbedingt mit einberechnet, wenn es so ein bisschen ungewöhnlich lang ist.
Krass. Aber wurde das ausgelöst durch schlechte Planungen?
Brauchen wir schlechte Planungen oder unvorherbare Sehne als Dinge. Also, dass zum Beispiel irgendwas, die planen damit ran, dass zum Beispiel, wenn eine Start- und Landebahn gleichzeitig benutzt wird als Start- und Landebahn, dass die Flugzeuge in dem und dem Abstand landen. Aber es kann dann auf einmal sein, dass einfach mal der andere Flieger schneller angeflogen ist, als man sich das so gedacht hat, oder normal ist, oder der Wind halt doch irgendwie ein bisschen anders war. Und dann ist der Abstand zwischen den beiden landenden Flugzeugen zu eng, sodass er dazwischen keinen starten lassen kann, der Fluglose. Und dann gibt es so Verzögerungen, wo man dann länger starten muss, und dann die nächste kommt schon angerollt und irgendwas. Das kann sein. Wenn das denn zu viel wird, dann ist es der Moment, wo die Fluglosen sagen, bitte noch nicht Triebwerke anlassen, warte noch mal, ich hab noch keinen Platz für dich. Eine andere Sache ist, die jetzt im Winter auftritt, weil ich aus dem Fenster gucke, ist Enteisung. Es kann sein, dass Schnee und Eis auf der Tragfläche waren. Hat geschneit, hat übernacht, hat der Flieger gestanden, hat Frost gegeben. Dann möchte ich den Flieger vorher enteist haben. Dann meistens ist es so mittlerweile, dass man diese Enteisungsvorgang direkt kurz vor an den Start macht. Weil diese Enteisungsflüssigkeiten, die man drauf tut, sind meistens so ein Glykol-, Alkohol-, Wassergemisch. Manchmal wird das wie Geläse, ein bisschen zähflüssig gemacht, damit es nicht sofort wieder runterfließt. Damit wird der Schnee und Eis entfernt und dann als Schutzschicht rübergezogen für den Schnee, der vielleicht gerade fällt. Und damit diese Vorhaltezeit dieser Flüssigkeiten jetzt nicht so riesig ist, also maximal je nachdem, vielleicht nur 20 Minuten. Genau, wenn man dann noch irgendwie das Anlässt, an der Position macht, oder man rollt dann zur Startbahn, das dauert dann zu lange. Also wird das oftmals direkt an der Startbahn gemacht. Und es ist auch schon vorgekommen, dass man dann am Ende doch noch zu lange gewartet hat und wieder zurückrollen musste und nochmal in den Eisen musste.
Deswegen verlagert man das sozusagen auf kurz vorher? Kurz vorher. In dieser Warteschlange nutzt man sozusagen einfach die Zeit doppelt und hat dann eben weniger Urlauf.
Und das sind auch so Sachen, was eigentlich der Pilot entscheidet, ob ein Eis wird oder nicht.
Warum machst du das dann abhängig?
Also nein, worauf ich hinaus will, ist, ich hab auch schon mal so Flugzeuge gesehen von irgendwelchen, ich weiß nicht, wo die herkamen, aber die sind gestartet, die hätten Schnee drauf und sind trotzdem gestartet. Das ist unmöglich, das kann ich nicht sehen, sowas. Aber da ist keiner dran, der sich vorstellt, du darfst nicht starten. Die machen es dann einfach.
Aber was ist denn die eigentliche Gefährdung?
Die eigentliche Gefährdung ist, dass die Aerodynamik der Tragflächen dadurch versaut wird, dass der Schnee anheftet. Ich hab mal sagen lassen, dass, wenn du nur so auf einer 737, wenn du da so zwei Hände voll grobe Steinsalz auf die Tragfläche tun würdest, diese kleinen Hoppelchen, die drauf sind, die reduzieren schon den Auftrieb um 15 Prozent. Und wenn da jetzt richtig Schnee drauf ist und Eis und irgendwas, dann wird der Auftrieb zerstört. Das willst du nicht haben. Auf den Auftrieb brauchst du. Auch da ist ein unheimlich Puffer drin. Da ist im Faktor, glaube ich, drei mit dabei. Also wenn das Flugzeug auf einmal dreimal so schwer ist, könnt ihr die Tragfläche immer noch tragen. Rein physisch und gewicht, aber auch rein von der Menge des erzeugten Auftriebs. Aber trotzdem wird es da keine Risiken eingehen. So, dann rollst du zur Startbahn. Dann meistens Frequenzwechsel zum Tower-Fluglotsen. Der hat den anfliegenden Verkehr kontrolliert. Stellt sich an die Startbahn ran. Melzt dich an. Guten Tag, ready for take-off? Ready for departure. Und dann wartet man, bis man in einer Reihe ist. Kurz vor der Startbahn gibt es meistens noch eine Checkliste, die man zu lesen hat. Gucken, habe ich jetzt die Landeklappen, alle die richtige Stellung aufgefahren, so wie wir das vorher berechnet haben. Startleistungen werden auch von der Crew berechnet, von der Pilotencrew anhand der aktuellen Wetterbedingungen. Ist die Bahn nass, ist die Bahn trocken? Haben wir Schnee, Eis, ist es irgendwie glatt? Wie schwer sind wir heute? Welche Landestartklappen-Stellung möchte ich gerne haben? Diese Berechnungen machen die beiden vorne. Man prüft nochmal, dass man alles richtig eingegeben hat, dass alles korrekt ist, liest die letzte Checkliste, stellt sich hin auf die Startbahn, wartet man, bis man die Startfreigabe hat. Dann geht die Reise los.
Man rollt erst mal auf die Startbahn rauf.
Manchmal hat man beides zusammen bekommen. Die Aufrollfreigabe, wie man das auf Deutsch hat, die Line-up-Clearance und die Take-off-Clearance zusammen. Dann heißt es einfach Clearance und Take-off. Dann rollt man auf die Bahn und fährt sofort los. Vom Protokoll ist es so, dass man... Meistens ist es so, dass der Kapitän die Startleistung setzt, also auch die Gashebel sozusagen führt. Also macht die Hebel nach vorne sozusagen. Der erste Offizier guckt, dass die Startleistung richtig ist. Wenn wir anfangen zu rollen, kommt dann die Kontrollübergabe statt. Wer denn jetzt diesen Flug durchführen soll, das habe ich erzählt. Wir haben uns vorher entschieden, wer denn heute den Flug durchführt. Sobald die Startleistung gesetzt ist, oder kurz vor, heißt es dann so, you have control, wenn der Co-Pilot fliegen soll. Oder wenn ich selber fliege, sage ich gar nichts, weil ich habe ja sowieso schon die Kontrolle gehabt am Boden. Und wir fangen an zu rollen, sozusagen.
Waren mal schnell das Abhängige, wer jetzt fliegen soll.
Das habe ich glaube ich am Anfang schon erzählt. Manche Flughäfen, manche Wetterbedingungen, da ist es zwingend vorgeschrieben, dass der Kapitän fliegt, weil das Wetter so schlecht ist oder schwieriger Wind ist oder schwieriger Anflug. Das sind halt sozusagen zwingende Gründe, wenn es keine gibt. Wie man Lust hat. Man ist das letzte Mal nach Rom geflogen, das ist jetzt zwei Jahre her, komm, dann fliegst du mal hin. Oder umgekehrt, man ist das letzte Mal nach Rom geflogen, das ist zwei Jahre.
Also das ist die Entscheidung für den kompletten Flug, nicht nur den Start.
Kompletten Flug, ja. Kompletten Flug. Bei einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit kommt noch mal so ein... Wie nennt sich das denn jetzt? Ob man bei Bewusstsein ist. Mensch, wie hat man da einen... Hör ich den Namen vergessen? Einen schönen Namen, der Schegg. Also ich sag irgendwann, sagen wir mal, 100 Knotts und derjenige, der fliegt, antwortet dann, checkt. Damit weiß ich, okay, der ist noch bei mir, der hat nicht jetzt in dem Moment, wo wir alle beide konzentriert sind und gucken, wie wir fliegen, hat er nicht... sind gerade ohnmächtig geworden oder irgendwas sowas. Weil jetzt alles ist auf Start gerichtet, wir gucken beide konzentriert, dass alle Parameter laufen. Da kann ich nicht gucken, geht es noch gut, sondern ich höre von ihm, checkt, alles klar, ich weiß, er ist noch da.
Also was bedeutet das 100 Knoten in dem Moment? Also ist das eine Frage nach, du stellst die Geschwindigkeit fest und lässt er das bestätigen und das reicht dann schon?
Genau, wenn er sagt, er hat dieselbe Anzeige, dann weiß ich, er ist ja erst noch da und er hat auch dieselbe Anzeige. Dann kann das sein, dass sein Gerät kaputt ist und auf einmal nur noch 80 Knoten anzeigt. Das wäre jetzt ziemlich doof. Dann müssen wir halt gucken, was wir damit machen. Ich habe natürlich eine Kleinigkeit, eine Wichtige vergessen, was wir vorher auch gemacht haben in der ganzen Flugwegvorbereitung. Wir haben uns intensiv darüber selber, wie wir das auf Deutsch nennen, gebrieft, wie denn der Abflug, wie unsere Abflugroute ist. Was genau, wohin man fliegt. Und vor allen Dingen noch viel wichtiger, was passiert, wenn es schief geht. Sprich, was passiert, wenn ein Triebwerk ausfällt. Das ist immer der Gau sozusagen, ein Triebwerk ausfällt. Kurz vor dem Start, vor dem Abheben, bzw. während des Abhebens oder nach dem Abheben. Was fliege ich dann? Dieser Plan ist vorher schon bis aufs Detail durchgedacht worden.
Und auch berechnet worden ist. Weil man ja dann nicht unbedingt die Zeit hat, sich noch einen zu machen.
Nein, dann überlegen, geht es jetzt rechts oder links ran, ist einfach nicht der richtige Zeit.
Und das hängt jetzt im Wesentlichen von dem Flughafen ab.
Das hängt im Wesentlichen von der Örtlichkeit ab und dem Wetter. Wenn die Bahn sehr glatt ist, wenn es sehr regnerisch hat, sehr stürmisch hat, dann bin ich vielleicht geneigt, die Entscheidung zu treffen. Also ich rede jetzt nicht nur von Triebwerkausfall, sondern allgemein irgendwelche Fehlfunktionen. Nehmen wir mal an, es ist sehr glatt, sehr windig draußen und wir starten und es kommt eine Warnlicht an von einem System, sagen wir mal, selbst sowas Krasses, dass ich sage, oh, mir ist gerade ein Reifen geplatzt. Dann werde ich möglicherweise, wenn ich sehr leicht bin, es ist sehr trocken, ich habe eine sehr lange Bahn von mir, werde ich sagen, wir brechen ab, sage Stopp, ziehe Gashebel zurück und wir bremsen. Wenn dasselbe mir passiert, wenn wir sehr schwer sind und wir sind auch schon relativ schwer und schnell, mir platzt ein Reifen und es ist gleichzeitig sehr windig und die Bahn ist nass und glatt, dann werde ich wahrscheinlich sagen, continue. Ich werde mit diesem Fehler jetzt weiter fliegen wollen und nicht abbrechen. Weil ein Reifen bedeutet eine Bremse weniger, der bremst ja nicht mehr der Reifen und zum Fliegen bin ich damit immer noch hervorragend geeignet und zum Startabbruch aber links nicht mehr, weil ich bin jetzt noch am Hälfte der Bahn und habe noch die Hälfte der Bahn vor mir und ich bin sehr schnell und es ist glatt und ich habe nur noch einen Teil der Bremse weniger, dann breche ich nicht ab. Solche Entscheidungen kann man vorher schon mal so ein bisschen ansprechen.
Wie viele Reifen hat denn das Flugzeug?
Die 737 hat vier Hauptfahrwerke Reifen, die vier Bremsen haben.
Also 16.
Also vier Hauptwerke Reifen mit einer Bremse, also vier Bremsen, Entschuldigung. Vier Bremsen. Vier Bremsen, ja.
Vier Reifen, also...
Also vier Reifen, also zwei Fahrwerke, ein linkes und ein rechts Fahrwerksbein, da ist ein Reifen dran und in diesem Reifen ist hier eine Bremse dran.
Also sind das nicht solche Doppelreifen?
Genau, Doppelreifen. So zwei Reifen auf einer Achse. Links und rechts vom Hauptbein.
Das sind doch schon mehr Reifen. Also ich meine, das sind wirklich so einzelne Reifen insgesamt. Wenn da jetzt einer platzt, sind da ja noch welche.
Da sind noch drei Stück, die gehen, ja. Also wahrscheinlich kann ich auch... kann abbremsen dann und kann auch normal die Bahn runterrollen, vielleicht auch noch weiterrollen, je nachdem, was dann alles mit diesem Reifen passiert ist, aber es ist möglich theoretisch das machen. Es ist jetzt noch keine große Bedrohung, die da irgendwie aufgetreten ist. Aber darüber sollte man sich so ein bisschen Gedanken machen. Das hat man auch vorher schon trainiert im Simulator, auch schon mehrfach diese kritischen Momente durchtrainiert. Und wenn ein Triebwerk kaputt geht, da habe ich auch eine bestimmte Geschwindigkeit, mit der ich mit zwei Triebwerken beschleunigen kann. Dann gibt es eine sogenannte Entscheidungsgeschwindigkeit. Das ist die V1, die sind nach Definition, warum die 1 als 1 heißt, weiß ich nicht. Das hat man sich immer mal überlegt. Wenn bis vor dieser Geschwindigkeit ein Triebwerk kaputt geht, kann ich den Start abbrechen und auf der Startbahn zum Stehen kommen. Wenn nach dieser Geschwindigkeit ein Triebwerk kaputt geht, muss ich den Start fortsetzen. Kann ich auch fortsetzen, auch das haben wir vorher berechnet. Auch wenn mir nur noch 50% der Leistung auf einmal zur Führung hat, weil ja ein Triebwerk komplett weg ist, kann ich trotzdem den Start fortsetzen. Ich kann aber nicht mehr abbremsen, weil ich zu schnell wäre, weil ich nicht mehr am Ende der Bahn zum Stehen komme.
Das heißt, man würde in was auch immer da ist irgendwie reinknallen?
Reinrutschen, über die Bahn hinausrutschen, das willst du nicht. Das ist ein Flugzeug, kein Startzeug. Deswegen sagst du, ich fliege jetzt weiter. Und ich kann aber dann nicht mehr den normalen Flugweg wählen, weil ich werde dann langsamer steigen müssen. Ich kann möglicherweise dann nicht über den Berg, der jetzt genau vor mir ist, übersteigen. Ich muss also an der Meile geradeaus und dann abbiegen. Normalerweise wäre ich abgeflohen, normalerweise rechtsrum. Jetzt muss ich aber linksrum biegen, um diesen Berg auszuweichen. Das habe ich vorher alles schon bebrieft und besprochen und abgeklopft, diese Pläne.
Da hat man in Hannover andere Bedingungen als in Innsbruck.
Hannover ist ziemlich... Ich sag mal, 90 Prozent der Flugpläne fliegst du geradeaus. Das haben wir so standardisiert, damit das dann simpel ist. Du hast auch in dem Moment ganz andere Ideen, aber da weißt du immer, geradeaus ist immer gut. Das hast du berechnet. Aber es gibt Flughäfen, da geht das halt nicht. Innsbruck wird garantiert dazu, aber auch andere Flugplätze wie San Francisco, Hongkong oder größere Flugplätze, da geht das halt nicht. Aber das ist jetzt auch kein großes Problem. Du fliegst halt nur ein bisschen anders. Du musst halt nur vorher darüber geredet haben. Das kannst du nicht machen, wenn es denn gerade passiert, weil da hast du echt keine Zeit für dann.
Ich habe mal so ein Doku gesehen über den alten Flughafen in Hongkong. Da hatte er so eine mega... Der war ja irgendwie nur noch so eine kleine Zunge ins Wasser. Mit so einer krassen 90-Grad-Kurve, die man dann, glaube ich, vor der Landung irgendwie noch durchführen musste. Da braucht man auch eine spezielle Ausbildung.
Das war auch so ein Flughafen, wo man eine Einweisung haben musste. Diesen GCR-Approach, wie er frühe ist. Aber auch das war nach Gesichtspunkten alles abgeklopft, vorberechnet und geguckt und dass das alles möglich ist. Die Physikwetter versucht ja nie irgendwie auszutricksen. Es ist ja auch jahrelang nie was passiert da bei diesem Anflug. Das muss man immer hochhalten. Es gibt einen ähnlichen Anflug immer noch. Das ist der Canasi-Approach in New York. Da fliegt man das Meer aus Slamschutzgrotten auch. Da fliegt man auch parallel an der Küste und dreht erst in den letzten 300-400 Metern auf die Landebahn ein. Da gibt es extra so Lieds in Leihlicht, Hotels, Marker, wo man dann direkt kurz vorrüber fliegt. So Visual-Marker. Es wird auch nur nach Sicht geflogen. Das gibt es immer noch.
Na gut, wir wollen jetzt erst mal hoch. Du hast es jetzt noch mal betont, das ist ja auch wichtig, dass das Teil der Vorbereitung ist. Das ist auch etwas, was ich, als wir in diesem Simulator waren, was mir überhaupt erst so richtig bewusst geworden ist. Weil man, wenn man da so leihenhaft oder einfach schlicht unaufmerksam und uninteressiert drauf schaut, dann sieht man, na ja, man fliegt da halt rein. So ein Pilot weiß man, wie man so ein Ding startet und landet. Das hat man dann halt irgendwann drauf. Und dazwischen kann man da die ganze Zeit sitzen und sich mit seinen Kollegen unterhalten. Dem ist mitnichten so, sondern im Wesentlichen geht eigentlich die ganze Zeit einschließlich der Vorbereitung bis zur Landung drauf, eigentlich permanent alle Sicherheitsoptionen zu re-evaluieren. Immer sozusagen dieses was wäre wenn Ding eigentlich immer schon vorberechnet zu haben, um dann eben im Wenn-Fall einfach sofort immer eine Lösung zu haben. Da muss man eigentlich permanent immer alles im Blick haben. Muss immer das Wetter, das Fluggeschehen.
Sonstige Ereignisse. Wobei man erstmal in der Luft ist und seine Reiseflug erreicht hat, dann geht der Pult schon deutlich runter. Jetzt ist schon eine relativ ruhige Phase eingetreten. Aber so weit sind wir ja noch. Das Schwierige ist, wenn man eigentlich in der Luft ist und die Landeklappen eingefahren hat, den Flieger auf normale Steigflug gebracht hat und schon in seine erste Richtung fliegt, dann beginnt die Phase der Entspannung langsam los. Dann ist immer noch viel zu tun, mal mit Fluglotsen noch reden, weil die Fluglotsen-Bereiche sind eingegeben nicht nur in Bereiche, was links und rechts angeht, sondern auch oben und unten sozusagen. Die haben dann Tortenstücke, eher Scheiben, wie immer, Diskoscheiben im Flughöhenbereich eingeteilt, sodass man sich dann Stück für Stück, freigabend, technisch, sich dann auf seiner Reiseflughöhe hochquatscht sozusagen, hochklären lässt. Wenn Wetter ist, natürlich vorher schon versucht, Wetter auszuweichen, im Sommer dann, wenn Gewitter kommen. Kann einem natürlich immer sein, dass irgendwas auf dem Weg liegt, was man nicht reinfliegen mag. Und wenn man in einer englischen Reiseflugge angekommen ist, dann ist es schon relativ entspannt. So 10%, 20% des Koppels laufen immer noch so, was wäre wenn? Was wäre jetzt, wenn ich schnell runter muss, weil auf irgendwelchen Gründen die Druckkabine versagt? Wo gehe ich dann hin? Kann ich hier so weit runter, wie ich kann? Über den Alpen ist es halt nicht so möglich, so weit runterzugehen, dass ich an einer Höhe bin, wo ich keinen Sauerstoff mehr brauche, sondern dann müsste ich doch eine andere Flugroute anwählen. Wenn ich dann mehr zum Zielflughafen hinkomme, dann geht dann schon der ganze Prozess, den wir eben gerade gesprochen haben, mit wie fliege ich an, genau wie ist der Anflug. Den fangen wir uns dann auch schon an, gegenseitig wieder zu briefen. Welchen Anflug erwarte ich? Wie sieht er aus? Was erwarte ich da und da? Welche Landeklappen benutze ich zur Landung? Ich glaube, beim meisten hat man so einen kleinen Spielraum, den man wählen kann, mit Vor- und Nachteilen gegenüber. Hängt ab, Bahnlänge, Wetter, wie ist das? Und natürlich auch die Tatsache, was passiert, wenn ich nicht, wenn ich durchstarten muss, Fehlanflug erfahren, wo fliege ich dann hin? Auch da bin ich wieder dicht am Boden. Die Sache ist dann recht dynamisch und dann kann ich nicht sagen, oh Mensch, stimmt ja, wie wollten wir jetzt eigentlich? Dann wollten wir links oder rechts rum. Dann muss ich halt vorher schon mir den Plan gefasst haben. Die Reiseflugphase ist dann schon relativ ruhig. Trotzdem, wenn du immer guckst, wie ist denn das Wetter so unterwegs, kann ich irgendwo, wenn ich irgendwie ausweichen muss, weil ich dann einen kranken Passagier auf einmal habe oder irgendwas in der Art, dass ich mir zeitnah Gedanken mache, wo ich denn irgendwie hin müsste. Aber das ist dann, das ist eine relativ entspannte Phase. Das muss man echt zugeben.
Okay, relativ entspannt, aber wenn ich irgendwie relativ entspannt bin, dann setze ich mir einen Kopfhörer auf und höre einen Podcast.
Ja, nee, das Podcast-Hören ist nicht möglich. Also selbst lesen. Manche Leute lesen dann so ein bisschen was im Cockpit, aber das ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht gesehen und nicht gern gesehen und widerspricht auch dem Vorschriften. Das muss man ganz klar sagen. Ich würde mir eine Zeitung nehmen und die da oben lesen. Ich könnte gar nicht konzentrierter dabei sein, das geht gar nicht.
Ist das dann langweilig?
Für viele Leute bestimmt. Das will ich ja gar nicht unterstellen. Aber ich kann mich immer sehr gut unterhalten. Und sonst nur bei einem Kollegen neben mir. Ich bin immer sehr gespannt. Man ist auch bei so kurzen Flügen... Frag mich bitte im einem Jahr gerne nochmal, wie das ist bei diesen langen Flügen. Vielleicht sieht es dann deutlich anders aus. Aber bei so kurzen Flügen ist es eigentlich immer sehr, sehr leidlich.
Also kurz, wir reden jetzt von so zwei Stunden bis drei Stunden.
Ja, genau. Was natürlich der Faktor noch hinzukommt, manchmal ist, wenn du müde wirst oder so was, dass du dann, wenn die Nacht durchfliegst, dass du mehr das Problem hast, wie schaffe ich Aufmerksamkeit, dass ich eben nicht, dass ich immer noch komplett dabei bin. Dass du da irgendwie anfängst, gar nicht mehr miteinander zu reden und dann irgendwie müde wirst. Das ist nicht ein Problem, sondern eine Sache, mit der man auch lernt, umgehen zu müssen.
Das heißt, die kommunikative Komponente ist dann sozusagen im Team auch wichtig.
Also ich finde sie wichtig. Ich hoffe, ich habe da immer einen, der mich ertranken kann, mich zu hören. Also ich gerne ihn zuhören.
Ist man denn in irgendeiner Form mit dem Geschehen in der Kabine verbunden? Aus dem Cockpit heraus? Oder ist das irgendwie komplett isoliert?
Also die Kabinenkollegen sind verpflichtet, regelmäßig mal zu gucken, ob wir noch da sind. Insbesondere auf Nachtflügen gibt es auch Anweisungen, dass sie anrufen sollen. Sind die noch komplett da? Oder haben sie sich da zu Tode gelangweilt? Oder sind müde geworden? Oder irgendwie sowas? Und man ist schon involviert, weil es ist ja auch manchmal wackelts. Oder es ist hinten zu kalt in der Kabine oder zu warm. Und dann müssen wir manchmal ein bisschen wärmer drehen oder kühler drehen. Bei größeren Flugzeugen machen sie das selber. Oder es wird uns auch mal was zu trinken angeboten. Oder man hat selber sich Essen mitgebracht und möchte sich das warm machen lassen. Oder man muss auf Toilette schlägt weg. Da muss man natürlich auch irgendwie rausgehen können aus dem Cockpit. Mittlerweile kommt immer ein zweiter Mann dahin zu. Die Sicherheit der Cockpit-Tür ist ja in den letzten Jahren auch wieder stark im Gespräch gewesen. Also wir sind immer zu zweit im Cockpit. Das ist so vorgeschrieben und auch gut so, dass man da vorne nie alleine ist.
Also wenn jemand aufs Klo muss, muss jemand anders?
Aus der Kabine rein. Genau. Und dort sozusagen, damit er immer zu zweit ist.
Das ist jetzt neuerdings so?
Das ist neuerdings so, ja genau. Das ist neuerdings so. Das ist eingeführt worden, ich glaube für alle europäischen Airlines jetzt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt schon ein Gesetz ist, aber zumindest wird es von den Airlines so gehandhabt. Es ist sinnvoll, ja. Leider ist es sinnvoll. Es ist aber auch sinnvoll, dass wir eine Cockpittür haben, die nicht zugänglich ist, wenn das Cockpit das nicht will, die nicht zugänglich ist von von der Pagiere-Raum an. Das ist wichtig, dass das da ist. Wenn die Cockpit das nicht will, man kommt ja rein. Wenn man will, im Notfall kommt man rein. Wenn die Cockpit-Crew handlungsunzfähig ist, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, kommt man ins Cockpit vorne rein. Durch speziellen Code und Warteschleifen, die man durchgehen muss. Dann kann ich rein ins Cockpit. Aber wenn die Cockpit-Crew nicht will, dass jemand reinkommt, dann sollte auch keiner reinkommen. Das kann ja sein, dass da böse Leute hinten rein, von hinten nach vorne reinkommen können. Das müssen nicht immer sein die Bösen, die wir jetzt auch in der Presse gerade hören, Terroristen. Das kann auch irgendwelche besoffenen Gäste sein, die da anfangen an die Cockpittür zu pöbeln oder irgendwas zu machen. Das hat man auch schon erlebt. Oder einer will auf einmal auf die Toilette gehen und nimmt die falsche Tür und zieht und rüttelt und klopft dran und bis er dann immer merkt, dass sie die falsche Tür hat.
Jetzt gab es gerade diesen dramatischen Fall mit dem Selbstmord-Piloten, der sich im Prinzip auch alleine einschließen lassen hat.
Das soll halt nicht mehr passieren, weil wir jetzt immer zu zweit vorne im Cockpit sind.
Das war sozusagen der Anlass dieser Änderung?
Das war der Anlass dieser Änderung, ja.
Aber auch schon so die 9-11-Attacken hatten ja im Prinzip so eine Auswirkung. Dadurch ist ja überhaupt erst mal so eine feste Tür Pflicht geworden, oder?
Dadurch ist diese feste Tür Pflicht geworden. Es gibt manche Fluggesellschaften, die hatten das auch vorher.
All.
Die sind aber nun extrem gepenigt gewesen, sagen wir mal so. Und die hatten das schon vorher, aber jetzt ist es weltweit so, dass jede Gesellschaft muss so eine gesicherte Kokotür haben. Wie gesagt, ich möchte sie auch nicht missen. Ich möchte, dass sie da ist. Nicht, weil ich Angst habe, dass mir jetzt die bösen Terroristen von hinten kommen, aber selbst dass so ein blöder Gast, der durchgedreht ist, aus irgendwelchen Flugangstgründen da vorne reinkommt und meint, wir sollen sofort landen und der wahrscheinlich auch keine Bedrohung ist, weil er einfach verwirrt ist. Aber auch selbst der soll da vorne nicht rein. Ich sag mal, so ein Banal, so ein Atomkraftwerk würde sich auch nicht irgendeinen reinlassen, um da irgendwelche Schnöpfchen rumzudrehen oder irgendwie sowas, oder?
Nee, das ist schon nachvollziehbar. Man wundert sich, warum das nicht sowieso schon besser abgesichert war, aber naja, so ist es halt.
Man lernt dann halt immer.
Die ganze Sicherheit ist ja da so ein Prozess.
Ja, genau. Und manche Sachen flaren auch vielleicht mangelnde Fantasie und so, dass man sich nicht vorstellen könnte, dass so was irgendwie passieren kann. Oder man das halt für wirklich für Einzeltaten bekommt. Aber wenn die halt dann zu sehr medium-wirksam, pressewirksam werden und man sagt, das geht nicht so, wir müssen dann doch was tun, die Gefahr ist dann da.
Oma, macht Captain Stefan dann seine Ansage an die Fluggäste?
Zur Begrüßung. Meistens zur Begrüßung begrüße ich dann die Gäste. Hoffentlich, dass sie mir zuhören. Ich wünsche ihnen einfach nur einen schönen Aufenthalt. Das ist mein Stil. Genau, jeder hat seinen eigenen Stil. Ich denke, wenn du morgens um 6 Uhr die Geschäftsreisenden von München nach Hamburg bringst, dann braucht man nicht so viel zu sagen. Wenn man die Urlaubsreisenden nach Mallorca bringt, kann man dann schon mal ein bisschen mehr zahlen. Insbesondere dann im Reiseflug ein bisschen mehr bringen, wenn das vielleicht wie erwünscht ist. Mallorca ist ein schlechtes Beispiel. Da fliegt schon jeder so oft hin. Die kennen das auch alle. Da brauchen wir denen auch nichts mehr zu erzählen. Ansage ist auch so ein Thema. Die größeren Flugzeuge, die Langstrecken fliegen, die haben mittlerweile ihre eigene Airshow, wo man ja sehen kann, wo der Flieger gibt. Also diese Streckenansage, wir fliegen heute jetzt und gucken sie mal links raus und so was. Das ist manchmal auch so ein bisschen obsolet, weil die Leute gucken auf den Bildschirm und sehen, was da ist. Ich denke aber, es ist für viele Leute zu wichtig, sie wissen immer die Stimme von dem Kollegen da vorne zu hören. Was ist das denn für einer? Und ein bisschen Vertrauen aufstellen. Diese Flugangst, das Thema ist bei vielen immer noch dabei.
Ja, ich meine, mittlerweile ist ja YouTube auch voll von hervorragenden Performances des Kabinenpersonals. Da wird ja gerappt und ein Show gemacht.
Genau, genau.
Bei Piloten ist der Druck noch nicht so groß da für eine Show-Einlage.
Und es sind ja auch genügend Videos von Leuten, die ja ihre Anflüge reinstellen und machen und tun.
Ach so, ja die Anflüge. Ja, das meinte ich so, aber ich dachte ja, wenn man sozusagen dann...
Die Ansagen dann....
eine Sange-Einlage, irgendwie das Pilot.
Ja, fitze das wirklich.
Soweit bist du noch nicht drauf an, wie gut das ist.
Also ich möchte mich nicht hören.
Also ich persönlich hätte jetzt, sagen wir mal, mit einer Prise Humor wenig Probleme, aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass es eine Menge Leute gibt, die das dann irgendwie im Zweifelsfall nicht verstehen. Und das schafft dann unter Umständen noch mehr Probleme, als es einem lieb sein kann.
Und wie gesagt, die Grenze zwischen Alman und seriös wirkend, ich bin Deutscher, ich kann nicht, ich muss mein Wissen abwirken, ich muss halt nur ein bisschen meinen Stil irgendwie pflegen. Also privat und Dienst ist Dienst. Das sind zwei verschiedene Stiefel.
Der deutsche Pilot hat gerade einen Witz gemacht, dass das Cockpit stürmen würde.
Genau, genau. Ja, also solche Scherzwörter darfst du ja in der Sicherheitskontrolle nicht sagen. Wenn du da sagst, was wollen sie, suchen sie meine Bombe hier oder was, dann wird man richtig kontrolliert, weil das wird ernst genommen. Es gibt, was ich noch sagen wollte, um Fliegerthema. Wenn du sagst Reiseflug, es gibt manche Strecken natürlich, die sind anspruchsvoller selbst auf dem Reiseflug. Also die Strecke über Nordatlantik und dann runter nach der Westküste Amerika, Los Angeles und so was. Da ist es halt schon sehr dünn besiedelt, teilweise die Gegend, die da ist. Dann wird die Auswahl der möglichen Ausfallflughäfen, die man ja immer irgendwo im Hinterkopf haben sollte, schon so ein bisschen diffiziler, was passiert.
Also zu jedem Zeitpunkt sozusagen.
Genau, zu jedem Zeitpunkt. Wann ist das? Man rechnet sich Zeitpunkte aus. Wann ist es der kürze Weg zu dem Flughafen? Oder muss ich jetzt umdrehen oder fliege ich jetzt geradeaus weiter, um zum nächsten zu kommen zum Beispiel? Dann sind Strecken, die nahe über hohen Bergen gehen, auch sehr interessant. Also Himalaya zum Beispiel. Oder das tibetianische Hochplateau, wenn man jetzt runterfliegt nach Hongkong oder ich weiß nicht, ob Shanghai auch da betroffen ist, ich glaube nicht, wenn man die Ecke längs fliegt, das Terrain ist da sehr hoch. Und wenn ich jetzt die Druckkabine versacht, muss ich auf eine niedrige Höhe sinken, damit die Sauerstoffversorgung der Gäste gewährleistet ist. Man hat ja diese kleinen gelben Masken, die da runterfallen, aber dieser Vorrat an Sauerstoff, der hält nicht ewig. Also wir vorne haben einen relativ langen Bedarf und wir kriegen auch 100 Prozent Sauerstoff, wenn wir es wollen. Wir haben so Masken, die ziehen sich sehr schnell auf, die habe ich innerhalb von 4-5 Sekunden aufgesetzt. Sie ziehen sich dann fest an mein Gesicht und bleiben dann drauf. Die Gäste kriegen immer so ein Gemisch aus angereicheter Sauerstoffluft mit Kabinenluft. Damit der Verbrauch nicht so hoch ist? Damit der Verbrauch nicht so hoch ist, dann müssen sie ihre Mengen an Flaschen oder System damit schnitten. Manche Flugzeuge haben chemische Sauerstoffgeneratoren an Bord. Das sind Kaliumpatronen mit anderen Sachen gefüllt. Die haben eine kleine Zündpille drin. Wenn die abgeschossen werden, werden die einmal angeschossen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein chemisches Prozess ist. Die werden einmal gezündet und dann brennen die ab. Die werden warm dabei und produzieren dabei Sauerstoff. Der hält aber nur. Die Patrone ist nach 25 Minuten leer. In der Zeit muss ich zusehen, dass ich dann von dem hohen Terrain, das ich in der Nähe von Tibet habe, runtergeflogen bin. Da wird das schon ein bisschen schwieriger. Da muss man schon genau überlegen, wie fliege ich denn aus der Ecke raus? Gibt es richtige Fluchtrouten?
Wie tief muss man denn sein?
Das ist unproblematisch. Ganz unproblematisch ist es in 10.000 Fuß. Ich kann aber für die Passagiere...
Also 3 Kilometer.
3 Kilometer Höhe. Ich kann zulassungsbedingt noch eine halbe Stunde, war das glaube ich, mit Gästen in 4 Kilometer Höhe fliegen oder 3,5, 3,8 Kilometer Höhe fliegen. Aber ich muss dann innerhalb einer halben Stunde dann runter sein auf 3 Kilometer Höhe. So und das ist... Da muss ich immer noch einen tolle Puffer haben, dass ich über die Berge rüberkomme. Also wenn ich in einem Gebiet fliege, wo 3000er sind, dann kann ich nur in 3,5.000 Lenses fliegen. Geht einfach nicht. Weil ich natürlich nicht über die Berge rüber fliegen muss. Also bei die Strecken, die über das tibetianische Hochland fliegen und ein bisschen dichter ran fliegen, die sind schon auch für uns der rechte Anspruchshol, weil wir da ständig mitplotten sind. Wo sind wir, wo muss ich hin, wenn was ist und so. Da einfach nur sitzen, Kaffee trinken und aus dem Fenster gucken, das ist nicht möglich. Nein, nein. Könnte man ein Computer auch alles vorberechnen und machen und tun und so. Aber so weit sind wir noch nicht.
Aber da läuft es darauf hinaus?
Ich glaube, wir hatten davor das Thema, ob man automatisch fliegen kann oder so. Das Ganze rein technisch kann man sagen, Ingenieure können Flugzeug bauen, was alleine ohne Piloten fliegt. Es gibt die Drohnen, die oben fliegen. Ich glaube, diese, wie man es nennen möchte, in Deutschland, die jetzt nicht zugelassen worden ist, wo die Bundesregierung so viel Geld reingeführt hat.
Euro-Programm.
Euro-Hawk hieß er. Das basiert auf einem Modell, das schon seit 1998 fliegt von den Amerikanern. Der kann völlig autonom fliegen, seine Route abfliegen. Start, Landung, macht das. Die meisten Drohnen sind ja am Ende doch von Piloten kontrolliert. Interessanterweise, die sitzen dann im Kontrollzentrum irgendwo in der Ferne oder in Rammstein und kontrollieren dann die Drohnen, fliegen die. Die fliegen selber, aber sie werden gesteuert von einem Piloten. Der hat auch richtig Flugstunden teilweise. Keine Lizenz meistens auch sogar. Und den könntest du praktisch da auch rausrechnen, sodass die es ganz alleine fliegt. Aber was du nicht erreichen kannst, ist die Renundanz. Das ist das, was die Ingenieure immer sagen. Selbst wenn sie anfangen zu sagen, Mensch, wir machen das so reden, und dann, dass nur ein Pilot drinne vorne sitzt, musst du am Ende doch ein redundantes System bauen, was Fehlbedienungen des Piloten verhindert, wenn der mal irgendwie einen Herzanfall kriegt. Also, die haben dann so Systeme überlegt, wo sie sagen, okay, da sitzt der eine drinne, und wenn er jetzt einen Herzanfall kriegt, wird er dann mit Gurten rangezogen an den Stuhl und bleibt stehen sitzen, dann wird er ja nichts anfasst mehr. Dann wird er nicht in seinem Anfall, außer, dass er irgendetwas ausschaltet. Also wird es wohl immer zwei Piloten geben, wenn man die dann auch ganz rausrechnen würde, dann müsste man das System so redundant bauen, so teuer werden lassen, dass man diesen Satz hab ich vor dem Podcast ja auch schon gesagt, dass es wahrscheinlich immer noch billiger ist, weil im Volksmund ja wahrscheinlich immer noch als überbezahlte Piloten da drinnen sitzen zu lassen, als diese Systeme einzubauen und dann fliegen lassen kann. Weil sonst würdest du nicht diese 99,999 Redundanz bzw. auch Operation Redundanz hinkriegen können. Es ist ja auch unheimlich viel in die Infrastruktur, in den Flughäfen, wo rolle ich, was und wie und mit reinkriegen.
Fahrzeuge fahren schon autonom, aber Zeugen wird es noch etwas länger dauern.
Genau, einfach weil man sie nicht so redundant hinkriegen bauen könnte, um diese ganzen Fälle hinzukriegen. Denn wie erzähle ich einen Autopiloten, dass er im Hudson River landen soll, wenn beide Triebwerke ausgefallen sind? Dass das die bessere Option war, als woanders hinzufliegen. Gerade in dem Moment.
Das sind die intuitiven Entscheidungen und die haben auch viel mit den gewonnenen Erfahrungswerten zu tun. Die bauen sich nur auf, wenn man als Pilot auch was zu tun hat. Also wenn man Aufgaben hat und dann dieses regelmäßige Check-In.
Ja genau.
Auch permanentes Awareness Training quasi.
Es ist auch schön zu sehen, wie gesagt, das ist ja immer ein Feedback-Kreis, der ständig und ständig läuft. Anhand von Untersuchungen und Vorfällen, die es ja gibt, dass man feststellt, woran lag es denn. Und im Zuge dieser ganzen Untersuchungen hat man festgestellt, es gab einige Upsets, also wo Flieger in einer nicht sehr schönen Fluglage am Ende gelandet sind. Also wo die Nase sehr hoch war oder wo der Flieger fast zu langsam geflogen ist. Und das lag dann doch, weil irgendwelche Systeme ausgefallen sind. Die Piloten von Hand fliegen mussten. Und diese schwierige Situation, die da auftrat, nicht sofort gecovert haben. Und das hat man vermehrt festgestellt in den letzten Jahren, also sich in den letzten Jahren so vor 15 Jahren so beginnt. Es war also der Zeitpunkt, wo die Airlines, insbesondere kleine Airlines, angefangen haben, maximale Gebrauch von Automatik immer sofort, Autopilot einschalten, fliegen mit dem Autopilot, der kann das besser, eh besser als du, wo sie grundsätzlich mit Recht haben, der kann das auch besser als ich, maximal draus schalten, das ist für den Flug sicherer. Das stimmt, sollte man vielleicht auch immer noch so machen, aber man hat festgestellt, dass dann die manuellen Flying Skills der Piloten nachgelassen haben und dann, wenn was schief geht, sie dann nicht adäquat mehr reagiert haben. Deswegen ist von der EASA, wieder von Obersten Bürde, auch die Empfehlung rauszukommen, manuelles Fliegen zu trainieren. Und nicht nur im Simulator, sondern auch den Passus so umzuändern, dass man sagt, okay, jede Airline hat da so ein Flugbetriebshandbuch, wo sie ihren Piloten vorschreibt, wie sie gerne möchte, dass die Flugzeuge flogen werden, nach welchen Regeln, wann sie das Fahrwerk spätestens ausgefahren haben sollten, wie schnell sie oder wann der Flug komplett stabilisiert sein soll im Anflug, also alle Landeklappen raus, alle Fahrwerke raus, die Geschwindigkeit rein, die Leistung stimmt und so. Wann das sein soll, dass ihr da diesen Passus mit reinschreibt. Und wenn das Wetter zulässt, die Flugzeugung zulässt und ihr euch in phasenliedriger Arbeitsbelastung fährt, fliegt gerne mit der Hand. Das wurde sozusagen wieder empfehlt, das euren Piloten, weil das wichtig ist für das Training.
Und wie viel Autopilot ist jetzt so bei dir üblicherweise am Werk?
99,5 Prozent aller Landungen sind von Hand gemacht, rein vom Piloten selber, wenn Nebel ist.
Also ich meine jetzt nicht nur die Landung.
Reiseflug geradeaus fliegen, das machen die wenigstens dann. Also sagen wir mal so bis 3 Kilometer Höhe fliegt man vielleicht und dann schaltet man den Autopilot ein, weil dann wird es irgendwie auch keine Herausforderung mehr. Das sind so ein bisschen wie Autobahn und Tempomat. Also du fliegst geradeaus und hältst die Richtung Höhe, das ist jetzt nicht so die Herausforderung.
Und beim Start macht man immer alles manuell?
Start ist grundsätzlich manuell. Ich sage jetzt nicht, dass der Autopilot das nicht kann, aber er könnte es schon. Aber da ist jetzt wieder diese rechtliche Aspekt, die Entscheidung, breche ich Start ab oder nicht, wo wir geredet haben mit dem Reifen. Das sind so Dinge, die kann das System noch nicht darstellen. Diese Entscheidung darf auch nur der Kommandant stellen, weil der derjenige mit Erfahrung ist. Und das ist der kritischste Moment überhaupt, ob ich den Start abbreche oder nicht. Das hat relativ starke Konsequenzen. Und deswegen fliegt dort nur mit der Hand. Und das macht auch nur der Kapitän, der die Entscheidung fällt. Und es wird auch nur dort von der Hand geflogen. Das macht kein Autopilot, der den Start durchführt.
Okay, aber wenn man erst mal bei drei Kilometern ist, dann ist man okay.
Dann jetzt zack, Autopilot rein. Und man macht ihn vielleicht auch schon früher rein, wenn man sehr müde ist, also nach der Langstrecke zurückkommt und schon 12 Stunden in dem Bock drinne sitzt, auch wenn man eine Pause hatte, aber trotzdem jetzt morgens.
Und hält der nur eine gerade Linie oder hat der im Prinzip auch diesen Flugplan drin?
Den Flugplan hast du vor dem Start eingegeben. Und du kannst den Autopilot auf dem Flugweg-Gerechner aufschalten. Und er fliegt dann automatisch die Route ab. Theoretisch, ich sag mal, das ist es. Also er kann jetzt schon das Ding komplett alleine durchfliegen. Was er natürlich nicht machen kann, er kann nicht mit dem Fluglotsen reden. Das gibt es zwar mittlerweile auch sehr häufig verwendet, also auch vorgeschrieben über den Nordatlantik, den digitalen Fluglotsenfunk sozusagen, CPDLC, wo du die Clearance über Datenfunk kriegst, auch über HF-Datenfunk teilweise oder über Satellit. Du kriegst dir die Clearance vorgegeben, aber die Kopplung zwischen Freigabe und Fluggerächer ist getrennt.
Zwischen Freigabe und?
Zwischen der Freigabe des Fluglotsens und dem autopiloten ist. Da ist eine Trennung dazwischen. Also es kann nicht der Hacker von unten kommen, die Clearance geben und der Flieger bietet ab. Das geht nicht. Es muss immer noch der Pilot drauf gucken und sagen, ja die nehme ich und die programmieren wir jetzt mal in den Flugwegrechner rein und confirmen sie mit einem anderen Knopf. Also die Systeme sind dann noch getrennt. Auch was die Trennung beim A380, wie ist das gelöst? Nur zur Beruhigung, da hast du natürlich ein Netzwerk drin. Die Avionics funktionieren auch teilweise auf Netzwerksystemen, die da laufen, ich weiß nicht, wie das Betriebssystem darunter läuft, aber es läuft und da hast du natürlich hinten das In-Flight-Entertainment-System, was natürlich mit dem Internet verbunden ist. Und da sind die Leute und locken sich mit ihren Geräten ins WLAN rein. Und es kommen auch Daten natürlich wie für diese Airshow, dieses Bild, wo fliege ich gerade längs und welche Temperatur, welche Flughöhe. Das sind ja Daten, die kommen vom Avionics-Teil, also von dem Netzwerk, was die Flugsteuerung angeht. Und wie stelle ich die Verbindung her dazwischen? Wie kriege ich die Daten da irgendwie hin? Muss also eine Verbindung sein, würde der Hacker sagen.
Wie komme ich rein? Das haben sie gelöst durch Dioden, durch Infrarot-Dioden, die diese Daten unidirektional reinsteuern. So habe ich mir das erklären lassen. Ich bin ja jetzt nicht der Techniker, aber das ist die Firewall, die dazwischen ist.
Verstehe, sozusagen eine physikalische Unmöglichkeit in die andere Richtung Daten zurückzusenden.
So ist es. Und genauso soll es auch in die andere Richtung gehen. Du hast natürlich auch teilweise Request, die von innen an Avionics gehen. Also sende mal hier ein Telex oder irgendwas, was der Kollege hinten irgendwie macht. Und auch das ist irgendwie so gelöst.
Ja, aber da wird es natürlich...
Ich glaube, da bin ich jetzt dünn und glatt aus, aber ich weiß auch, dass diese Strecke ist geregelt über so Diodensysteme.
Das ist dann sozusagen eine interessante physische Entkopplung. Aber wenn es im Prinzip Kommunikation in beide Richtungen gibt, dann kann es Schwächen aufweisen.
Ja, es kann Schwächen aufweisen, aber das ist schon... Es ist schon sehr... Da muss einen wirklich einen haben, der... Also, wenn dir das wirklich einen... Die Leute, die das geworgen haben...
Ich kenne jetzt schon ein paar, die bleiben sich jetzt schon die Hände.
Die Triple Sevenbenden, die hat, glaube ich, die hat diese Netzwerke auch getrennt, aber die laufen über diesem Kabel.
Irgendwie sowas. Ich kann da jetzt auch nichts bestätigen. Es ist ein heißes Thema in der Security-Szene. Und ich glaube, die Security-Szene hat da nur eine einzige Position. Entweder ist es total getrennt oder es ist alles im Argen.
Also, wie ich das jetzt wirklich verstanden habe, wie gesagt, ich bin ja auch gerade erst in dieser Grundschulung. Ich habe diesen Teil ganz stark mal drauf geblickt über diesen Network-Server-Teil, wie das aufgebaut ist. Und das wird extra immer wieder dioderwert.
Okay, also wenn man sagt, es gibt da Informationen, die sollen halt im Entertainment-System angezeigt werden. Es gibt sozusagen auch nur wirklich einen Kanal, der auch physikalisch sichergestellt ist, dass er nur in die eine Richtung kann. Dann bin ich dabei. Na gut, bevor wir über Sachen reden, die wir nicht ganz so genau bewerten können. Aber es ist grundsätzlich interessant, wir sind schon sehr nah dran am autonomen Betrieb.
Autonomen Betrieb. Wie gesagt, technisch ist das möglich. Also wenn Leute, die dann irgendwie anfangen, auf die beiden Menschen, die ja auch Fehler begehen, ist ja nicht so, die gehen ja auch Fehler, dass sie da anfangen rumzuhacken, ist es aber, die technisch-operationelle Zuverlässigkeit kriegst du mit Maschinen alleine noch nicht hin. Und auch die Tatsache, dass ein Mensch gerne möchte, dass der Päsadier gerne möchte, dass er noch vorne menschlich sitzt, egal was es ist, die wollen sich nicht gerne vom Computer steuern lassen, ist es so, dass die Sachen, die wir schon wirklich schwierig sind, ausweichen einer Wolke, wo du weißt, die wird gleich wackeln, die kann ich, die sehe ich, der gucke ich raus, weiß ich, fliege ich drum herum, die sieht so aus, das geht. Das alles so in Sensoren einpacken, das wird dann immer schwieriger.
Ja, und auch diese autonome Steuerung und vor allem die theoretische mögliche Steuerung von außen, die ja sozusagen auch nochmal ein Problem ist. Man findet ja leider immer wieder in diesen Debatten politische Beiträge, die so in die Richtung gehen mit, naja, wenn da jetzt sozusagen der Terrorist das Flugzeug übernommen hat, dann wäre ihm ja von außen den Hahn abdrehen und dann landen wir dieses Flugzeug und so. Das ist natürlich irgendwie absurd, weil in dem Moment, wo man solche Systeme schafft, wie das könnten, dann geht das komplett nach hinten los.
Und vor allem, wie gesagt, die Flugzeuge fliegen in Gebieten rum, wo du mit Glück vielleicht eine Satellitenverbindung hast. Und die aber auch nur mit mäßigem Raten runterfunkt, auch nur durch sehr spartanische Protokolle verbunden ist mit dem Aviation-System. Da gibt es natürlich eine Verbindung hoch, aber das ist nicht über das Internet oder irgendwas, sondern über ganz andere Protokolle, die es hoch rüber gesendet wird. Vielleicht kannst du... Ering vielleicht? Nee, Ering nicht, sondern Sita. Sita ist so ein Netzwerk, das gibt es schon lange vor Internet. Das war es schon.
S-I-T-A?
S-I-T-A, genau. Das ist das Telex-System der Airlines. Das wurde wann gebaut? Verlass mich lügen, Anfang der 50er oder irgendwas. Weil man halt schon weltweit flog und Bedarf hatte, Daten zu verschicken, Passagierdaten, Buchungsdaten, irgendwann Triebwerksdaten. Diese ganzen Triebwerksparameter, die werden ja schon seit den 80ern über Datenfunk sozusagen mitgeteilt. Und das ist schon ein System, das existiert weltweit schon über sehr, sehr lange Zeit. Und über diese Kanäle und Protokolle werden auch immer noch Triebwerksdaten etc. ausgetauscht. Also sich da rein zu hacken. Letztens war er nämlich im Kongress vor zwei Jahren, war nämlich ein Vortrag, wo einer da gehalten hat, was er dann alles auslesen konnte aus diesen Daten, weil er sich empfangen hat irgendwie. Aber rein ist er glaube ich nicht gekommen. Und wie gesagt, da kannst du auch nur Passagiere, da kannst du Daten abfangen, aber keine Kontrolle.
Das ist ja auch immer wieder so eine Diskussion, wenn jetzt Abstürze stattfinden. Entweder aus technischen Defekten, Pilotenfehler oder eben jetzt, wie wir es jetzt gerade vor kurzem hatten, eben mal wieder eine Bombe, die tatsächlich, oder so ist es sich derzeit in der Nachrichtenlage darstellt. Da muss man ganz zurückhalten sein, man weiß ja nichts genaues. So, dann kommt halt immer wieder die Frage auf, wie macht man die Analyse? Und es gab jetzt, was war denn das nochmal für ein Fall, wo es mal wieder nicht gelungen ist? Ah ja, genau, dieses verschwundene Flugzeug von den Allegiant Airlines.
Genau, 370, ja.
Was ja eine unglaubliche Suche nach, die ja immer noch nicht abgeschlossen ist. Das Ding ist ja nicht gefunden worden. Aber sagen wir mal, die ganzen Rahmendaten, wie man jetzt versucht hat, überhaupt Aufschluss darüber zu bekommen, fragt man sich natürlich so, warum senden Flugzeuge nicht eigentlich permanent ihre Position? A, ihre Position. Und B, natürlich auch die Frage nach der Black Box, warum sendet man nicht auch die ganze Zeit diese Black Box Daten? Dann muss man nicht danach auf 5000 Meter Tiefe tauchen und das Ding irgendwie aus so einem Wrack rausholen, wenn man die Daten eigentlich auch hätte gleich übertragen können.
Du musst natürlich um das... Also erstmal hat das Flugzeug ja immer seine Position mitgeteilt, bis es irgendeiner ausgeschaltet hat und dann weitergeflogen ist. Und dann konnten sie es anhand des Connection-Requests des Systems, haben sie es ja noch ungefähr weiterverfolgt. Deswegen wissen sie ja ungefähr grob, wo es denn sein könnte. So ist es ja ungefähr passiert. Aber wenn einer bewusst das System ausschaltet an Bord, wie wäre es mit einem nicht ausschaltbaren System? Mit welcher Stromversorgung willst du dieses nicht ausschaltbare System versorgen? Mit einer Batterie, die gewartet werden muss, mit der du wieder ein Sicherheitsprotokoll machen musst, das dir das nicht irgendwo abbraucht. Was ist, wenn da Feuer ist? Du musst eine Sicherung an das System dranbauen.
Also es gibt nichts Unabschaltbares?
Es gibt selten etwas, was du nicht abschalten kannst. Natürlich, Drehwerke kannst du abschalten und so. Eigentlich kannst du alles an Bord abschalten, auch die Batterien. Du kannst alles an Bord abschalten, weil du rein aus Sicherheit eine mögliche Energiequelle willst. Sei das eine Batterie, die du abschalten kannst, falls du die irgendwie abbrauchst, dass du die isolieren kannst, wenn die überladen wird. Du musst die ja laden, eine Batterie. Da gibt es bestimmt technische Lösungen, dass du es irgendwie anders machen kannst mit einem Generator, der dann ausfährt oder wenn der Strom weg ist. Da werden jetzt tausend Leute drüber schreiben und sagen, das kann man auch gar nicht. Solarpanele, ja. Aber generell willst du ja irgendwie was haben, wenn es irgendwo Probleme bereitet, dass du es isolieren kannst und die ja nicht im Problem bereitet im Flug. Dann könntest du das permanent senden. Das ist Datenstrom, der wahrscheinlich möglich ist, in belebten Gebieten zu senden. Aber spätestens dann, wenn du irgendwo im unbewohnten Teil, irgendwo mitten über dem Pazifik bist, selbst wenn du über ein Polar rüberfliegst, irgendwann kennst du auch, selbst wenn ein Satellit überall, kriegst du mit Inmarsat oder irgendetwas mit dem, die da kombiniert sind, kriegst du keinen Connect mehr. Also wenn du über einen Polarkreis fliegst, so die Frachtflüge, die nach Anchorage rübergehen, die fliegen über ein Polar, ist nichts. Da haben wir keinen Satellitenpunkt mehr, gar nichts. Und in manchen Gegenden ist es wahrscheinlich auch, dann musst du diesen Connect abschalten, China oder irgendwas, weil sie das nicht wollen. Ich weiß es nicht. Es könnte natürlich alles auf internationaler Ebene regnen, aber ich glaube, wir reden hier von relativ großer Infrastruktur, die du aufbauen musst, damit du wirklich einen störenden Empfang dieser Signale kriegst. Und dann ist wieder die Frage, was hat dir das gebracht? Du hast jetzt also Lifetime-Überwachung von allen Flugzeugen, wo sich wahrscheinlich viele Leute die Hände reiben, weil sie endlich alles Mögliche sehen, was da irgendwie passiert. Aber letztendlich, ich glaube, gab es weltweit von all den Schadeabstürzen, die passiert sind, drei Fälle oder irgendwas, wo man bis jetzt noch nicht an die Daten angekommen sind. Irgendwann hat man sie am Ende doch gefunden. Selbst von dem Flieger, der im Südanlandik abgestürzt ist, hat man nach zweieinhalb Jahren das Flugzeug gefunden und hat die Daten irgendwie rausgeholt. Das ist der Air France-Flieger. Genau, hat man am Ende das Flugzeug gefunden. Deswegen bin ich zuversichtlich, dass man das findet. Das ist jetzt sehr doof. Man wartet lange darauf, bis es kommt, aber man wird das finden und man wird die Daten auch recovern. Und das andere kostet auch einen Schwannengeld, bis man das irgendwie durchgesetzt hat. Die sind sichere Verbindungen und die dann auch noch so absichert, dass sie dann, wenn einer ein böses Enviwell trotzdem noch weiterfunkt. Und selbst wenn man, ich sag mal so, selbst wenn derjenige sagt, der soll mir Daten weiterliefern, ich kann ja die Datenquellen abschalten. Wenn ich sage, du willst nicht wissen, wo ich längs fliege, dann schalte ich halt das Navigationssystem aus. Und dann weiß der Flieger auch nicht mehr, wo er ist. Er kann trotzdem noch fliegen. Und fliegt längs. Also das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen abstort. Weil im Prinzip, ich denke mir, wissen auch viele schon eigentlich, was da an Bord passiert ist. Sie haben eine Vorstellung, sie haben keinen Beweis davon, was da passiert ist. Am Ende war es wahrscheinlich auch ein Suizid. Schätze ich mal, das ist meine Meinung. Das ist meine persönliche Meinung. Das ist nichts Offizielles. Aber ich denke mir, ja, das wird sein. Und da waren übrigens zwei an Bord. Bei was? Piloten, um das Thema wieder aufzugreifen mit der Tür. Und das ist jetzt meine persönliche Meinung. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das jetzt hier broadcasten sollten. Aber man weiß es halt nicht, man weiß es wirklich nicht. Vielleicht war es auch wirklich was anderes, was sehr unvorstellbar ist, was ich noch gar nicht vorstellen kann. Und deswegen suchen wir jetzt nach den Stimmrekorden. Wie lange halten die? Diese Air France hat man nach zwei Jahren oder anderthalb Jahren, hat man die noch intakt rausgefunden. Ich finde, die sind schon gut gekapselt.
Aber senden tun die halt nicht so lange?
Senden tun die nicht mehr lange. Die senden, hat einen Ultraschall-Ping, der sendet, glaube ich, 28 Tage oder irgendwas. Hat eine Energiequelle drin. Und hat auch ein Funksignal, aber unter Wasser ist es sofort wirkungslos. Und wenn die Antenne unter Wasser ist, geht nichts mehr, weil das ist eine Kurzwelle. Nicht Kurzwelle, sondern BHF, also Ultrakurzwelle. Und auch der Stimmrekorder, wenn der Flieger, wenn sich das jetzt ausgibt, noch sechs, sieben Stunden weitergeflogen ist, auch selbst in dem Stimmrekorder wird man auch keine Daten drauf haben, weil die zeichnen nur die letzten zwei Stunden auf. Das ist der Stimmrekorder. Und dann überschreiben wir die Daten. Also ich halte das vielleicht für eine schöne Idee, oder dass man das irgendwie anders lösen kann, dass man kurz vor dem Absturz so ein Datenpaket abwirft. Es gab auch mal solche Systeme. Da gibt es einen Patent drauf, einen abspringbaren Flight-Recorder, der dann, wenn er feststellt, dass etwas schief läuft. Dann die Notbuye, wie in den Filmen, wo die Notbuye ausgestoßen werden. Genau, so was. So ein Ding, der irgendwie ausgestoßen wird. Gibt es aber, wurde noch nicht implementiert, vielleicht auch zu teuer, oder dann fragt man sich auch, wozu? Brauchen wir das wirklich? Und dann stößt das Ding ab und landet irgendein auf den Kopf, und der verklagt dann, richtet unten wieder einen Schaden an.
Ja, na gut, das kann natürlich auch passieren. Aber was ist denn wünschenswerte Technik? Gibt es denn noch irgendwas?
Eine wünschenswerte Technik?
Sozusagen aus der Pilotenperspektive, wo du dir denkst, warum gibt es das nicht schon längst? Das ist eigentlich an alles gedacht. Eine kolossale Technik-Ansammlung, so ein Flugzeug, das ist wirklich einfach unfassbar.
Du meinst, was auf meiner Wishlist ist sozusagen? Ja. Meine Amazon-Wishlist. Eine Müdigkeit was tun. Das wäre das. Müdigkeit. Das wäre das einzige irgendwie. Ja genau. Das hilft beim Autofahren hervorragend. Nein, kein System ist perfekt. Der Flieger, auf den ich jetzt gerade lerne, der ist so unglaublich redundant. Da bin ich eigentlich sehr, sehr, sehr sicher, dass das irgendwie von der technischen Seite alles passiert. Man wünscht sich vielleicht manchmal mehr, dass man, wenn man irgendwo hinkommt, dass jeder eher so Flughafen, so Protokolle haben, mehr ausgeweidet, so was sie, wenn irgendein standardisiertes Notfallprotokoll, was man absenden kann, dann jeder weiß, der Flieger braucht jetzt das und das und das. Und das ist halt noch nicht so sehr richtig standardisiert, weil es irgendwie auch weltweit unterschiedliche Auffassungen gibt, wie was irgendwie abzulaufen hat. Also dann Komplikationen, das wäre schöner. Besseres Englisch, jetzt hab ich's, jetzt hab ich's. Das könnte man da sagen, dass alle Leute besser Englisch sprechen und besser mal besser mit denen reden kann. Das wäre so. Und das wäre so das Schönste, was ich irgendwo haben möchte. Jetzt müssen wir langsam mal landen.
Wir sind ja noch gar nicht unten. Ich wollte jetzt einfach mal das Gefühl, dass man auch nach Rom fliegt.
Okay, du wolltest endlich auch mal ankommen, ne?
Ja, genau, weil wir noch nicht richtig gelandet sind. Wir sind die ganze Zeit mal durch die Welt geflogen und hatten genug Zeit, diese ganzen sonstigen Aspekte zu machen. Aber runter kommen sie ja immer. So auch dieser Podcast. Deswegen, jetzt geht es sozusagen. Mich interessiert natürlich jetzt, was ändert sich jetzt an den Prozeduren, wenn man sich dem Ziel nähert?
Auch da wieder in Phasen orientiert sozusagen. Wenn ich mich begebe immer dichter ran an einem Flughafen, muss ich natürlich irgendwann anfangen, den Sinkflug zu beginnen. Das wird auch geplant sein. Also manche Flughäfen liegen halt komisch in einem Bergen oder irgendwas, wo man halt nicht schnell genug runter kann oder nicht früh genug runter kann, weil Hindernisse im Weg sind. Manche Flughäfen haben Anforderungen von der Flugsicherung her, dass man früher runter sein muss, dass man sich bewusst ist und weiß, okay, da steht meist natürlich auch eine Karte drinnen, aber der Flugsicherung möchte einen in 50 Kilometern in 10.000 Fuß haben, dass man nicht von dieser Entscheidung überrascht wird und sagt, hier ist schnell hier runter. Weil ein Flugzeug kann nicht unendlich schnell sinken. Ein Flugzeug ist auch gleich ein guter Segler. Wenn ich ganz schnell runter will, dann werde ich auch ganz schnell. Irgendwann werde ich zu schnell. Ich kann nur eine bestimmte Sinkrate überhaupt schaffen, um runterzukommen. Ich möchte am liebsten effizient.
Ist auch für die Passagiere nicht angenehm.
Man drückt auf die Ohren, wenn es sehr stark runter geht. Ich möchte natürlich aber auch effizient sinken. Am besten platzt man das so, dass man sich anguckt. Da hilft natürlich auch der Flugzeugrechner, dass man sagt, okay, der Wind ist so und so, ich habe starken Gegenwind und ich habe starken Rückenwind. Bei dem Punkt möchte ich gerne anfangen zu sinken. Da muss man die und die Hindernisse beachten. Das ist das, was wir uns gegenseitig briefen vor dem Anflug. Am liebsten möchte ich mit Leerlauf sinken, Triebwerke auf Leerlauf und dann praktisch nur runtersegeln, das wird das Optimale. Das wäre optimal, wenn ich das Energiemanagement so mache, dass ich kurz vor der Landung, wenn ich stabilisiert bin, Fahrwerk alles ausgefahren habe, dann wieder Gas gebe, um dann in diesem stabilisierten Landezustand dort anzukommen. Wir briefen uns auch vor das Wetter, wie das ist am Flughafen, wie unsere technischen Bedingungen nochmal sind. Da könnte man sagen, nach 2 Stunden Flugzeit weiß man noch, wie technisch dein Flieger okay ist, aber trotzdem briefen wir uns das nochmal. Wird interessant, wenn du länger unterwegs bist, wenn du in 12 Stunden unterwegs bist, dass du dir noch erinnerst, was war, nochmal kaputt am Anfang. Und dass du dir nochmal die Besonderheiten des Flughafens, gerade den technischen Zustand, wie du den Anflug genau durchführen möchtest, welche Anflugart das überhaupt wird, es gibt verschiedene Instrumente, Präzisions-, Nichtpräzisions-, Sichtanflüge. Und Landedistanz, dass du dir nochmal überprüfst und ausrechnest, dass du sagst, die Landelfbahn, die uns der Flugklasse zuweist, reicht aus bei dem Wetter, passt das alles. Und dir dein Fehlanflugsverfahren nochmal durchsprichst. Gegebenenfalls auch, wenn noch irgendwie was kaputt geht, ein Trierwerk ausgeht, wenn das irgendwie hinderniskritisch ist dort in einer Art. Und dann gibt es Checklisten zu lesen, die die Phasen abschließen sozusagen. Descent-Checklist oder Approach-Checklist. Und ganz kurz vorm Anflug vor der Landung gibt es die Landing-Checklist, wo dann überprüft wird, so habe ich denn jetzt wirklich alles ausgefahren, Fahrwerk, Landeklappen, ist das alles da. Und in der Zwischenzeit wird man von verschiedenen Fluglotsen wieder durchgereicht, bis man zum Schluss auf den Anflugfluglotsen kommt. Der schickt einem meistens mit Radarvektoren, also bei größeren Flugplätzen, da fliegen wir meistens auch noch hin, mit Radarvektoren auf den Endanflug des Flughafens hin. Der versucht, einem so möglichst wie eine Perlenkette aufzufädeln, wenn man sich das so vorstellen kann. Die machen das ständig nur, die fädeln einen, weisen einem Geschwindigkeiten zu, sodass man gleichmäßig in Abstand auf diesem Flughafen zufliegt. Irgendwann sagt er dann, you're cleared for approach, also du bist vom Anflug freigegeben. Dann übernimmt man wieder selber sozusagen die Navigation und fliegt an. Mit Navigation mal ich die Führung, welche Richtung ich steuer sozusagen. Irgendwann wird man an den Towerlotsen drüber geschickt und der Towerlotser gibt einen dann die Landefreigabe, wenn die Landebahn frei ist. Kann das sein, dass noch einer rüber rollt oder irgendwas kreuzt, quert oder...
Was für einen Abstand muss man denn zu anderen Flugzeugen so halten?
Das hängt davon ab, welche andere Flugzeuge voraus einem fliegen. Wenn ich da mit einer anderen 737 fliege, dann muss ich das jetzt in Kilometern sagen, habe ich einen Abstand im Anflug von zweieinhalb Meilen. Nautische Meilen rechnen wir. Also was ist das? Ungefähr 4,5 Kilometer oder so was. 3,7 sagt Google. Das müsste ich wissen. Ich dreh dir schon zu lang. Wenn du vor mir ein kleineres Flugzeug hinter einem größeren hinterherfliegst, dann wird der Abstand vergrößert, weil die Flugzeuge produzieren Wirbelschleppen bei der Landung, die hinter einem hinterherfliegen sozusagen, die können gefährlich sein für die Nachflugenden, je größer das Flugzeug ist, sodass dann teilweise bis zu 5 nautischen Meilen Abstand gehalten wird, wenn man da hinter fliegt, oder 6 Meilen auch hinter einem großen A380. Ich muss so eine 737 6 Meilen Abstand, glaube ich, dahinter dran halten. Und dazwischen können natürlich auch noch Flüge abfliegen und so weiter. Und dann geht das Prozess los. Man hat sich hoffentlich auch schon vorher überlegt, in welche Richtung ich denn abgerollt bin. Manche Leute besprechen, wir machen die Landung, wir machen die Landung und landen, und dann sind sie gelandet und jetzt? Nein, man muss natürlich auch wissen, wo dein Parkplatz vor ist, wie roll ich denn da hin, wie komme ich denn da hin. Dass man da keine Überraschung erlebt, man will keine Überraschung haben. Das muss halt vorher alles so ein bisschen durchgesprochen sein.
Das kriegt man von den Fluglotsen übermittelt oder wird das digital übertragen?
Nein, alles von den Fluglotsen. Also die Parkposition, wir bekommen teilweise Informationen schon vorab über Telex-Systeme hochgeschickt, Anschlussflüge für die Gäste, wie es dann weitergeht, Wetter können wir uns digital holen und sowas in der Art. Und das funktioniert also alles schon über Datenfunk. Aber die eigentlichen Freigaben dann am Ende, die sind dann über Stimmen, über Voice sozusagen. Ich weiß dann grob, wo ich hin muss, kann mir vorstellen, wie ich rolle, aber wie ich da am Ende hinrolle, das erzählt mir dann der Fluglotser. Weil er natürlich auch anderen Verkehr hat, der einem entgegenkommt, so ein Flugzeug kann er nicht immer umdrehen oder wenden oder rückwärts fahren oder sowas, das geht halt nicht. Deswegen wird auch da genaue Freigaben erteilt. Dann rollt man zur Parkposition, da gibt es halt mehrere Möglichkeiten, dass man eine Parkposition hat, die einfach eine freie Fläche ist, wo man sich draußen hinstellt. Und das ist nicht der Fluglose, die werden gerne verwechselt damit. Diese Einwinkler, die mit den Dingen, das ist kein Fluglose.
Nee klar, die sitzt ja oben vorm Computer.
Die sitzt am Tower.
Aber wie nennt man die Einwinkler?
Einwinkler, den Kartoffelkäferfahrzeug, der von der Bodenaufsicht, die haben auch einen Namen, schuldigung, wenn ihr alle zuhört, bitte jetzt nicht mich hauen. Marshala, also im Englischen heißt sie Marshala. Derjenige, der linkt dich ein, der guckt, dass du links und rechts alles frei ist. Ich kann das nicht so unbedingt absehen und vor allen Dingen, ich kann nicht genau sehen, welchen Punkt er mich anhalten lassen möchte. Er sagt dann so, fertig, macht einen Kreuzer mit seinen Kegeln und sagt mir, hier stehe ich so richtig. Dann gibt es zwei Optionen. Entweder geht meine APU, was ihr meistens ja geht, dann habe ich die APU vorgestartet, sodass ich eine Stromversorgung habe für mein Schiff, kann die Triebwerke ausstellen und wenn die Triebwerke ausgestellt sind, dieses rote Blinklicht, wenn ich das abgeschaltet habe, gibt es noch eine Liste, die ich lesen kann, ob ich denn wirklich als korrekt abgestellt habe. Und dann kommt die Boden-Crew, kommt dann selbstständig angefahren, wenn das Licht nicht mehr läuft, fährt die Treppen ran, die Gäste steigen aus, hoffentlich sind Busse da, so diese ganzen operationellen Quatschstellen, wie es losgeht, dass hoffentlich alles reibungslos funktioniert. Und die Gäste können dann aussteigen.
Also diese ganze Boden-Logistik ist sozusagen komplett die Aufgabe des Flughafens. Also da muss man jetzt nicht nochmal irgendwas rein kommunizieren, sondern man weiß einfach, man kommt, man ist angemeldet und dann muss das irgendwie laufen.
Auf Zuge von kartellrechtlichen Gründen oder sowas hat man, muss es immer mehrere Provider auch geben, die diesen Service an so einem Flughafen anbieten, glaube ich. Das gibt es auch so eine EU-Richtlinie oder irgendwas. Deswegen hat man oft mehrere Provider, die einem den Bodenservice anbieten, also die Treppen fahren und sowas. Manchmal kommt man irgendwo an und dann will man als Airline, hat man dann Unternehmen A dem am Vertrag, die einem die Koffer ausladen und die Treppen ranfahren. Und der kann gerade nicht. Und nebenan steht einer von Operator von Vertragsfirma B, der die Treppen mit der Bezeichnung B drauf hat, aber der darf sie jetzt nicht ranfahren, weil er mit meiner Fluglinie keinen Vertrag hat. Manchmal sind die absurden Situationen, da stehen die ganze Zeit an, da sind noch Treppen, wieso fällt der jetzt nicht ran? Ich sag, der hat, tut mir leid, das ist nicht eine andere Baustelle, das ist nicht meine Firma oder irgendwas in der Art.
Wunderwildes Kapitalismus.
Ja, so ist es nun immer.
Das ist alles total effizient. Der Markt wird es schon richten. Auch wenn man dann länger warten muss.
Ich will jetzt nichts dazu sagen. So, genau.
Ich hätte jetzt wirklich gedacht, das ist halt einfach mal eine Dienstleistung der Dienstleistungsfirma Flughafen. Und das ist halt einfach in der Landegebühr quasi mit enthalten und fettig.
Nee, also gerade bei kommerziellen Sachen wird das schon ein bisschen komplizierter. Ich weiß nicht, ich kenne die Verträge nicht, die diese Firma da hat, aber da wird auch teilweise dann abgerechnet. Ich weiß, bei der Fraport kann man sich das ganz genau im Internet angucken, was sie verlangen. Pro Flugzeug, pro Gewicht, pro Landegebühr kostet es das und das. Pro Abfertigung, pro Passagier kommt noch mal das Geld und pro Koffer noch mal das Geld noch drauf. Das sind die ganzen Gebühren. Das geht dann relativ schnell. So ein Jumbo anlanden und Gäste aussteigen lassen, sind mehrere tausend Euro fertig. Dann wird das dann abgehandelt. Manche Flughäfen sind teuer, manche günstiger. Manche haben bessere Infrastruktur. Dann gibt es noch die ganzen DFS-Kram. Der Flughafen als solches, der die Infrastruktur vorstellt und die Betriebsstufen auch haben muss für diese Nebel-Landung, diese, ähm, wohnen bei niedrigen Sichten, dass der die erfüllen kann. Das ist wieder eine andere Baustelle. Das ist wahrscheinlich der reine Flughafenbetreiber, nennen wir das mal.
Es gibt ja auch so, ähm, für die Landung auch noch so Unterstützungssysteme. So, ähm, also, weiß nicht, ob das jetzt in Innsbruck ist, aber sagen wir mal, gerade für schwer anzufliegende Flughäfen gibt es ja noch mal so zusätzliche Differential-GPS-Geschichten.
Also, was, ähm, der klassische Weg, einen Instrumentenanflug, also einen Anflug, einen Flughafen zu machen, nur nach Instrumenten bis zu einer bestimmten Höhe, wo ich dann rausgucke als Pilot und die Runway vor mir sehe, ist über, ähm, Ultrakurzwelle, ILS-Systeme nennt sich das, Instrumentenlandesystem. Und, ähm, man driftet natürlich jetzt mehr und mehr zu GPS-gesteuerten Gerichten und Geschehenen, und da ist das, das GLS nennt sich das mittlerweile. Ähm, frag mich jetzt bitte nicht nach den Abkürzungen, ich hab jetzt gerade im Kopf GLS-Systeme, Landesysteme, und das funktioniert in der Tat mit, ähm, GPS, mit Differential-GPS, wo denn ein Korrektursignal an den Empfänger des Flugzeuges gesendet hat, dass die Genauigkeit des Gerätes noch verbessern kann. Und für den Piloten ist das ganz doof gelöst, ähm, also ganz doof, man eh so, er wählt genau die gleiche Frequenz an wie vor bei einem ILS, dreht er sich die Frequenz von dem Kurzwellenfunk-Anempfänger ein, den er, der dafür benutzt. Und beim ILS ist es dieselbe Frequenz, die dreht er ein und darüber kommt dann, kommt dann die Differential-Signal. Es ist sehr easy und convenient für den Piloten gelöst.
GPS-Landesystem heißt GLS. Beziehungsweise auf Englisch heißt das eigentlich GBUS, also Ground Based Augmentation System.
Dann sind wir gelandet und meistens geht der Stress gleich los. Es gibt natürlich, wenn man an eine Parkposition kommt, wo ein Finger dran ist, diese Brücken, die rangefahren werden, da gibt es meistens so Doc-Systeme, wo ich so visuelle Marker habe, die mich orientieren, wann ich genau auf dem Kurs bin, genau in der Mitte dieser Parkposition und wann ich meinen Stopp habe. Da gucke ich raus und da steuere ich mit Bremsen und mit einem Handrad, mit dem ich das Bugrad steuere, fahre ich direkt ran und halte den Flieger an. Dann schalte ich die Treibwerke aus, bekomme hoffentlich Strom sowieso, aber lasse die APU meistens laufen am Anfang, bei größeren Flugzeugen umso mehr, um die Belüftung in der Kabine aufrechtzuerhalten und dann steigen die Gäste aus und dann wird praktisch schon der nächste Flug vorbereitet. Also bei diesen Kurzstreckenflügen geht die Tür auf und das erste, was reinkommt, ist der Flugplan für den Rückflug. Kommt durch die Tür rein, keine Zeit verlieren.
Wie viel Pause muss man haben?
Es gibt bei Flugzeug-Sachen keine Pausenregelung, wie bei LKW, wenn du das meinst. Es gibt nur eine maximale Begrenzung abhängig von der Anzahl der Starts und Landungen, die man macht, also der Anzahl der Flüge, die am Tag gelesen wird. Ich glaube, maximal möglich sind sechs laut Regeln, dass maximal sechs Flüge am Tag machen. Dann darf es aber auch nur maximal der Tag, die Dienstzeit, glaube ich, 12 Stunden sein oder irgendwas. Und dann kann es ja noch sein, dass man verlängern muss als Kommandant. Dazu ist auch der Kommandant da, diese Entscheidung zu treffen, zu sagen, okay, wir haben jetzt schweren Wind gehabt oder wir hatten eine Störung oder wir mussten hier lange warten. Und wenn ich jetzt nicht, je flügt die Zeit, nochmal um eine halbe Stunde verlängere, kommen wir gar nicht an. Und dann kann ich das nochmal entscheiden, nochmal länger zu machen. Aber das muss eine Entscheidung sein, die muss im Absprache mit der Crew getroffen worden sein. Wobei das eine Absprache ist, ist es eine Entscheidung, die der Kommandant fällt, abhängig von der Belastung, die vorher stattgefunden hat. Ja, das sind Einsatzzeiten, die hat auch dementsprechenden Ruhezeiten hinter dran. So ist es nicht. Gerade bei Langstrecke wird es dann sehr interessant, welche Zeitzonen man denn über das Flogen hat und wie lange man einen Aufenthalter hat und so was, wie lange ich denn da bleiben kann. Und wenn ich dann wieder zurückkomme, weil ich den nächsten Flug dann irgendwie machen kann. Und dann gibt es noch ein Minimum Zeit, die ich in der Woche frei haben muss. Also man muss in einer Woche mindestens 36 Stunden einmal frei haben, zum Beispiel als Gesamtruhezeit. Das ist praktisch das Wochenende, was man haben kann. Das gibt es so als Vorschrift. Das ist recht komplex das Thema, da können wir auch stundenlang reden, wenn du möchtest. Aber das ist noch präziser und minutennauer geregelt, als bei manchen anderen Betrieben wahrscheinlich, wo das vorgeschrieben ist. Deswegen sind diese Meldezeiten auch so wichtig, wann ich da sein soll. Aber da fängt die Uhr an zu ticken. Die Stechohr. Und das ist nicht nur wegen möglicher Bezahlung oder irgendwas, da gibt es ganz unterschiedliche Systeme, sondern einfach mehr wegen, wie lange kann der gute Mann oder die gute Frau da vorne noch sitzen oder hinten sitzen.
Aber was mich noch mal interessieren wird, ist natürlich die eigentliche Logistik, weil ich meine, man geht zur Arbeit und dann ist man auf einmal in Oslo. Und es wird ja nicht immer möglich sein, dass die Flüge so gelegt werden, dass man wirklich auch wieder da hinkommt, wo man wohnt. Ja, wie gesagt, da sitzt ja noch nicht mal unter Umständen von da, wo man wohnt.
Ja, also das wie gesagt hängt von dem Einsatzgebiet der Airline ab. Wenn es eine Airline ist, sagen wir mal, die sich nur darauf konzentriert, sternförmig für einen Punkt zu fliegen und wieder zurück und gar nicht irgendwelche Hubverbindungen zu anderen anbietet oder anbieten möchte, da fliegen die Leute vielleicht wirklich nur Punkt zu Punkt und sind abends immer da, wo sie abgeflohen sind, nämlich zu Hause. Aber es gibt auch manche Airlines, die betreiben Verbindungen in einen Hub rein, also sagen wir mal nach Frankfurt rein oder nach London rein und irgendwas, wo sie ihre Gäste auch morgens aus von Brest nach Paris bringen oder eben von Krakau morgens nach Frankfurt, damit sie dann von dort aus mit der Langstrecke weiter fliegen können. Diese Airlines haben natürlich Umläufe, die dann übernachten in den jeweiligen Stationen, weil dort, man ist jetzt so, dass zum Beispiel, wenn man fliegt, ich nehme mal das Beispiel Krakau, man fliegt nach Krakau hin, irgendwann mittags, steigt aus, ist im Hotel, hat seine Ruhezeit, man hat ja vielleicht schon früh morgens angefangen, vier Flüge gemacht, morgens um 5 muss man irgendwie da sein zur Arbeit, hört dann nachmittags um 2 irgendwie auf in Krakau, nachdem man vier Flüge gemacht hat, also einmal Hamburg-Rom, Rom, wieder Hamburg, Hamburg nach Nürnberg und dann Nürnberg-Krakau oder irgendwie sowas und ist dann in Krakau und irgendwann der Flieger, der dort steht, jetzt in Krakau, den man da hingebracht hat, wird von einer Crew übernommen, die aus dem Hotel kommt und fliegt denen dann den ganzen weiteren Tag zurück und irgendwann spät abends kommt eine Crew rein mit einem Flieger und stellt den abends ab in Krakau. So, geht dann ins Hotel, während die andere Crew, ich mit meiner Crew mittags angekommen bin, jetzt den kurzen Nachmittag oder irgendwas da in Krakau hatte, auch vorgeschrieben mindestens 10, 12 Stunden, was ich an Ruhezeit haben muss, und dann steh ich morgens wieder auf und fliege den Flieger von Krakau wieder dann zurück zum Hub, wo es dann hingehen soll, um die Gäste dort hinzubringen, dass sie dann weiter transportiert werden können.
Und die Airline hat dann wahrscheinlich immer so seine Hotels, die im Idealfall nicht so weit weg sind?
Ja, manchmal sind die uns zu weit weg, das ist je nachdem, wo das ist und welches Land es gibt. Die sind direkt am Flughafen, das finden wir als Crew furchtbar, weil da hast du irgendwie nichts, was du machen kannst. Auf der anderen Seite ist der Weg schön kurz. Dann hast du aber manche Hotels, die sind mitten in der Stadt, wo du Stunden hinfährst und du eh schon abends kaputt ankommst und eigentlich nur ins Bett möchtest. Und dann fährst du da erst mal noch eine dreiviertel Stunde mit so einem durseligen Bus durch Gegend rum, um dann da irgendwie hingebracht zu werden. Wobei man könnte sagen, ich hab's noch gut, weil es gibt manche Airlines, die sagen, also die ganz, ganz günstige Ecke, teilweise wo es dann heißt, du hast doch einen Führerschein, dann miete dir doch mal ein Auto. Man ist sehr kreativ, um die Kosten zu sparen. Also je nachdem. Ich möchte das gar nicht ausweiten, was es da alles für Möglichkeiten gibt, wo man Kosten sparen kann.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall so Teil dieser ganzen Logistik. Der Airline, das ist ja nicht ohne Herausforderungen, weil man muss ja dann auch mit Krankheiten und Lichterscheinen und so weiter wieder rechnen.
Genau, deswegen gibt es auch Bereitschaftsdienste. Jedes Co-Mitglied hat so viel Anteil seines Jobs, das besteht einfach nur aus Bereitschaft. Also dann ist man zu Hause und klingt möglicherweise das Telefon und sagt so, jetzt meistens so eine Stunde, in der Stunde bitte am Flughafen sein, Sie fliegen jetzt los, gekommen in fünf Tagen wieder. Oder irgendwas kann passieren.
Kriegt man überhaupt noch ein Privatleben irgendwie auf die Reihe?
Wollen wir mal so sagen, man hat sich damit arrangiert. Je nach Einsatzspektrum. Mal klappt es gut, mal weniger gut. Ich hab's bis jetzt toll toll geschafft, bis auf einmal Weihnachten immer zu Hause zu sein. Ich hab's irgendwie hingekriegt durch Wünsche, Planung, etc. Durch alles was. Aber es gibt manche Leute, die greifen oft ins Klo dann und kriegen einen dopen Plan gestrickt oder irgendwas. Man ist schon ein bisschen fremdbestimmt, das ist auf jeden Fall. Und das ist manchmal ein bisschen unglücklich, dass man Sachen dann verpasst, wo man gerne bei gewesen ist. Aber es gibt auch andere Jobs, wo das so ist. Das ist ja nicht nur eine Fliegereise.
Hat aber auch Vorteile.
Hat auch Vorteile, dass ich für mich, ich bin nicht am Wochenende gebunden. Ich kann auch in normalen Zeiten einen Arzttermin zu kriegen. Für mich ist das relativ leicht, weil dann komm ich halt, ich sage immer wann, wenn ich einen Arzttermin habe, sagen sie mir bitte, wann sie Zeit haben. Ich sage, wann ich Zeit habe. So geht es immer am besten. So hat man sich da engagiert. Man muss ja nicht irgendwelche Termine verlegen. Das hat natürlich auch Vorteile.
Schichtdienst halten. Ich meine, man sieht die Welt.
Okay.
Das ist vielleicht für dich schon gar nicht mehr so im Fokus, aber mag ja auch am Anfang ein besonderer Reiz sein.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Man sieht die Welt, das darf man natürlich nicht, wenn die Erlangen das irgendwie anbietet. Wenn du zum Beispiel in einer Gesellschaft, die nur sternförmig fliegt, da siehst du nur die Welt, aber immer nur in halben Stunden Hemden. Du hast natürlich das Gefühl, du warst mal in Italien. Du schaffst es vielleicht auch mal ganz kurz, ins Turmel reinzurennen und dir einen terenischen Cappuccino zu holen. Aber du warst nicht wirklich da. Das ist schon... Man hat die Luft von Rom ganz kurz geschnuppert.
Es gibt ja auch mal gewisse Vergünstigungen, wenn man so fliegt, oder?
Ja, gibt es natürlich nur in die eigene Airline. Wenn die eigene Airline diese Strecke nicht anbietet, wo man hin möchte, dann geht das auch nicht.
Na gut, aber immer hin.
Immer hin, klar, logisch. Es geht hin. Aber immer noch, wir denken, dass diese Vergünstigungen mittlerweile nicht mehr so günstig sind, wie man früher so dachte. Also das ist nicht mehr so günstig. Und man kriegt das dann nur, wenn Plätze frei sind. Die so genannte Standby-Reise. Und das kann man sich mit der Familie nicht leisten. Also meiner Meinung nach. Wenn ich geplant irgendwo in Urlaub fliegen will, mit Kind und Kegel, den kann ich nicht sagen, schade, wir fliegen jetzt heute doch nicht in Urlaub. Dann guck dir mal in die Kinder Gesichter an, wie sie dich dann angucken, was ist denn jetzt hier los?
Ja gut, Familie ist dann nochmal eine andere Sache, aber in gewisser Hinsicht ist das natürlich zumindest für eine bestimmte Phase ganz sportlich.
Genau, genau. Und je nachdem, wie straff das Flugprogramm ist, man kann jeden krank planen, sag ich immer so. Also wenn man so quer die eine Woche früh, dann die andere Woche spät oder Langstrecke so, ich kenne Leute, die sagen, ich bin jetzt schon 13-mal über der Landek diesen Monat geflogen, die wissen auch nicht mehr genau, wo sie genau sind. Und die haben die Nächte durcharbeitet. Auch wenn man dann im Reiseflug die Phase der Entspannung ist, man merkt immer, wenn der Flug zu Ende ist, man ist dann gelandet, dann merkt man, wie man so ganz langsam irgendwie runterkommen muss. Weil es am Ende dann doch eine kleine Herausforderung ist, dieses Gerät mit seinen 160 Stundenkilometer auf diese 40 Meter breiten oder 60 Meter breiten Betonstreifen zu setzen. Das ist dann schon eine Belastung, die merkt man meistens dann erst hinterher. Dass man sagt, hallo, freut ihr euch, schön geflogen, alles schön. Aber warum bin ich denn so müde?
Ich denke, das wird jetzt ein richtiges Thema werden mit dem A380 und den Langstreckenflügen. Das Ding ist ja sozusagen darauf abonniert, maximale Distanzen zurückzulegen. Das ist ja dann wahrscheinlich eher so von hier nach Dubai.
Das ist eine kleine Schrecke. Die Schrecken sind eher weiter und noch weiter. Singapur, Hongkong etc. Das ist noch mal ein Direktflug. Nicht direkt, Non-Stop. Direktflug ist kein Non-Stop. Vorsicht beim Buchen. Direktflug heißt ja nur, dass ich direkt dahin fliege, aber ob ich zwischendurch in Helsinki anhalte, Vorsicht. Du musst nicht umsteigen, aber man landet und startet. Du brauchst nicht umsteigen, sondern die Flugnummer bleibt da.
Also Non-Stop, richtig weit. Wie weit kommt das Ding so theoretisch? Was ist so die weiteste Strecke, die man damit tatsächlich Non-Stop fliegen könnte?
Das wird nicht betrieben, aber problemlos würde er auch von Frankfurt nach Bundesheeres kommen. Das ist so ziemlich das längste, was von Frankfurt angeboten wird. Es gibt längere Strecken. Ich glaube, am längsten momentan wird die 777. Die hat extrem lange Strecken. Chicago, Dubai, das sind so extrem oder noch weniger. Was war das gar nicht? Perth, Dubai oder irgendwas. Das sind extrem lange Strecken. Das sind dann alleine Flugzeit von 16 Stunden schon. Mit der Vorbereitung und Nachbereitungszeit. Das geht dann wirklich nur zu dritt. Oder manchmal ist es sogar zu viert. Und dass man sich austauschen muss, weil das schafft ein Mensch alleine nicht mehr. Das geht nicht. Der kann da nicht selbst diese elf Stunden alleine im Stuhl hocken. Das ist schon sehr, sehr schwierig. Das ist schon echt müde, wenn das dann vorbei ist. Auch wenn es wirklich Phasen gibt, wo man sehr ruhig ist. Aber das Gleiche macht man ja auch die Nacht durch. Da braucht man eine Pause.
Aber da hat man sozusagen eine ganz andere Belastung. Ich meine, man fliegt dann weit hin. Dann fliegt man ja nicht gleich am nächsten Morgen wieder zurück.
Nein, dann fliegt man morgen nicht zurück. Aber wenn man als Beispiel die Strecke Frankfurt nach New York fliegt, dann fliegt man am nächsten Tag zurück, ja auf jeden Fall. Dann ist man dort ungefähr 22 Stunden aufgeteilt und fliegt gleich zurück.
Hat das dann den Vorteil, dass man in diesen Jetlag dann gar nicht erst so richtig reinkommt, weil man eigentlich daran nie so richtig daran teilgenommen hat?
Das ist einfach, das machen wir nicht, um einen Vorteil zu haben, sondern das macht man, weil die Flugzeitregelung das hergeben. Und weil das optimale Planung ist, das zu machen.
Ich frage mich halt nur, ob diese Tag-Nacht-Änderung Zeit hat, an der Stelle einen fertig zu machen, als Pilot. Oder als Personal generell. Ich fliege über den Teich, bzw. wenn ich zurückfliege, bin ich danach vollkommen gegen die Uhr.
Weil mir das alles gewohnt war. Es gibt Regelungen einfach, dass du, wenn du eine Schrecke geflogen bist, das ist ein langschen Thema, wenn du nach Osten geflogen bist und wieder zurück, dass du dann mindestens 48 Stunden eine Heimatbasis haben musst, bevor du dann einen Flug nach Westen antrittst. Da gibt es so Regelungen, die da existieren, die auch vorgeschrieben sind, um eben eine Verwirrung des Körpers zu sehr zu vermeiden. Aber nochmal, du bist niemals so richtig lang, dass Jetlag für dich ein großes Problem wird. Du fliegst sowieso die Nacht durch. Weil der Hinflug nach New York als Beispiel ist vielleicht noch irgendwie tagsüber. Wenn du da landest nachmittags um, oder morgens nachmittags um zwei, ist für dich schon spät abends, aber irgendwie ist es noch ein Tag, den du hast. Aber spätestens der Rückflug dann ist immer nachts. Immer nachts durch. Und bei manchen Strecken fliegst du sowieso immer nachts durch. Also die Strecke nach Osten hin, werden gerne mal nachts hin und nachts rückbedient.
Aber da muss man ja auch seinen eigenen Tag-Nacht-Rhythmus auch flexibel anpassen.
Du musst dafür sorgen, dass du aus groß zur Arbeit kommst, ganz schlichtweg einfach. Und dass du natürlich im Layover nicht sagen kannst, ich mach dir einen super Ausflug und so was. Du willst auch fit für den Flug sein. Das heißt, du wirst dann, auch wenn du denkst, ich bin jetzt in New York, ich würde jetzt gerne hier super noch toll shoppen gehen oder irgendwas. Du weißt aber, um zwei wirst du vom Hotel abgeholt, geht der Rückflug los, dass du dich dann am besten vor, noch wenn du es schaffst, noch mal drei, vier Stunden vorhin zu hauen.
Also man lernt sozusagen auch so ein bisschen, sich runterzufahren.
Ja, klar. Man sollte das nicht mit irgendwelchen anderen Mitteln probieren. Es gibt ja immer so kuriose Tipps, so für Treffelas. Ja, musst du das und das und das nehmen? Das ist nicht gut. Ich muss mir das noch mal einlesen. Es gibt vielleicht für mich eine spezielle Schlaftechnik. Da kann ich nach Google nachreichen, wo man sich dann besser, schneller anpasst oder zumindest einigermaßen vorerholen kann, bevor man irgendwie gut auf so eine Reise geht, um nicht zu ermüdet anzutreten. Aber generell ist, dass die Zeit im Hotel hat, eine Ruhezeit. Und die sollte man auch zum Ruhen benutzen.
Jetzt haben wir, glaube ich, langsam alles durch. Was mich noch mal interessieren würde, ist, dass du diese ganze zivile Luftfahrt quasi seit 30 Jahren stark im Blick hast. Und was hat sich geändert in dieser Zeit?
Was sich geändert hat? Rein technisch sind die Flieger moderner geworden, redundanter geworden. Der Flieger jetzt, der A380, ist unglaublich redundant. Was da alles ausfallen kann. Und man hat operationell kaum Einschränkungen, was man machen kann. Das ist schon sehr beeindruckend. Flugsicherungstechnisch wird der Luftraum größer, den ein Flugklotze kontrolliert. Man kriegt mehr Directs. Dass ich sagen kann, du kannst jetzt von dem Punkt quer über ganz Frankreich direkt irgendwo hinfliegen. Das wird besser von der Koordinierung her. Technisch sind die Sicherheitssysteme verbessert worden. Früher gab es Systeme, die haben einen gewarnt, dass man jetzt, wenn man so weiter fliegt, gleich in den Boden fliegt. Aber das haben sie einen nur gewarnt aufgrund von Radar-Höhlenmessern. Der hat also runtergeguckt und gesagt, die Bodenanlegerungsrate ist zu hoch oder du fliegst mit Fahrwerk eingefahren und immer flacher. Das muss irgendwas hier stimmen. Dann hat er dich irgendwann angeschrien und gesagt, das stimmt nicht, geh weg, hau ab. Mittlerweile gibt es diese Systeme basiert auf einer Database. Die gucken also auch voraus. Der guckt nicht nur nach unten, wie tief der Boden ist, sondern er sagt auch, wenn du so weiter fliegst, fliegst du in den Berg. Er warnt dich direkt davor. Also die technischen Sicherheitssysteme sind besser geworden. Verkehrsanwarnungssysteme sind auch seit 15 Jahren eingebaut. Dass ich sehe, wenn ein anderes Flugzeug mir zu nahe kommt, basiert auf dieser Transpondergeschichte, wo dir auch Flightradar draufhört. Die Flugzeuge warnen sich gegenseitig und sagen, du bist für dich dran, geh weg oder flieg weg. Da hat sich deutliches an Verbesserung an Sicherheitssystemen verfahren. Die Schulung ist besser geworden. Mir dieses Zusammenarbeit, dieses Crew-Source-Management, da hat man sich viele Schwerpunkte darauf eingelegt. Es wird ständig versucht, das zu verbessern. Viele Sachen sind aber genauso noch... Hier der Datenfunk über Nordatlantik. Früher, als ich das geflogen bin, 340, da war das alles über Voice. Also alle die Kombination mit den Fluglosen waren über Voice. Da gibt es immer noch das sogenannte Track-System, Nordatlantik Track. Das sind so feste Straßen, die jeden Tag neu festgelegt werden anhand von Wind. Die wurden mitgeteilt mithilfe von Broadcast, also mit einer Frequenz, die hast du eingedreht. Da wurden die Punkte gesagt, hast du sie aufgehört, aufgeschrieben. Das war sehr viel manuelle Arbeit, Papier aufschreiben, tun und so. Mittlerweile gibt es die alle über Datenfunk. Die Freigaben gehen über Datenfunk, sodass du gar nicht mehr so viel anrufen musst. Kurzwelle ist auch weniger geworden. Der Funk über Kurzwelle über Nordatlantik, das ist nur noch der Backup, der funktionieren sollte. Ich weiß nicht, wer schon mal Kurzwellenfunk gemacht hat. Das ist furchtbar, das ist ein Gequietsche die ganze Zeit. Aber in anderen Ländern der Welt ist es noch ganggeber. Wenn ich über Afrika fliege, da gibt es teilweise immer noch dieses schreckliche Kurzwellengefunke, wo auf einer Frequenz Bombay, alle draufreden, vom Bombay bis Addis bis Nairobi, alle quatschen, hauen ihre Geschrei über diese Frequenz raus. Und wer am lautesten schreit und am meisten Sendeleistung hat, der kriegt seine Freigabe. Da wird auch wesentlich großzügiger gestaffelt. Und da fliegt er dann wirklich nur alle halbe Stunde oder alle 20 Minuten im Flugzeug längs. Also da wird einfach der Verkehr kontrolliert, wie man da reinfliegt in diesen Luftraum.
Aber so jenseits der unmittelbaren Pilotenbedürfnisse und vor allem auch der technischen Verbesserung, wie hat sich dieses, ich meine, der Luftverkehr ist ja enorm angestellt.
Genau.
Es ist billig geworden, teilweise absurd billig. Es ist eine Massenbewegung geworden. Der Luftverkehr explodiert, auch in den Zahlen. Es ist natürlich damit auch ein Umweltthema. Nicht nur wegen Lärm und sonstigen Belastungen. Es entzieht sich aber in gewisser Hinsicht auch so ein bisschen so einer regionalen Kontrolle, weil das einfach so ein internationales Ding ist. Was ist so dein Eindruck? Ist das irgendwie trotzdem auf einem guten Weg? Oder gibt es da einfach Tendenzen, die dich beunruhigen?
Wie muss man das so leben? Was einen Trend darzustellen ist natürlich, dass der Preisdruck auf die Gesellschaften enorm ist. Wie gesagt, die wird immer günstiger. Es wird auch da globaler sozusagen. Es brechen, so vertraute Strukturen brechen so langsam auf. Diese Sache, also ich wie ein Fossil, das schon seit 30 Jahren in einer Firma ist, das gibt es bestimmt irgendwann bald nicht mehr. Also der Aspekt der sozialen Sicherheit, auch dort wird immer weiter ein bisschen reduziert. Ich hoffe, das hat keinen Einfluss auf die Flugsicherheit, weil die Stimmung und das Training der Leute dadurch nicht mehr so konsistent gleich ist. Ich hoffe, das wird keinen Einfluss darauf haben. Die Regularien sind natürlich sehr streng und schreiben vor, was zu machen ist. Vielleicht bin ich da auch nur ein bisschen übervorsichtig. Zu beobachten ist, dass manche Gesellschaften diesen Kostendruck extrem an das Personal weitergeben und ganz exotische Arbeitsverträge schaffen. Das jetzt von dieser arbeitsrechtlichen Sache. Da gibt es Airlines, die ihr Personal, die ihre Crew in Bangkok stationiert haben, aber hier in Europa fliegen. Weil das dort das Personal so schön günstig ist. Wenn man denkt, wie kommen die denn hierher? Und wie sind die nicht schon müde, wenn sie hier sind? Da gibt es ganz kreative Sachen, die da raufkommen. Das ist so ein Aspekt, wo ich mir als Angestellter, und vielleicht, ich hoffe nur, dass das möglicherweise einen Einfluss auf die Luft hat. Was es auf jeden Fall wird, es wird immer mehr zu einem Massentransportmittel. Diese Arbeit, die dahintersteckt, die persönlichen Einsatz, die viele Leute leisten, diese Menge im Personal, die dabei ist, um im Hintergrund das ganze Training zu gewährleisten, das unterschätzen vielleicht die meisten. Ich schweife glaube ich ab gerade.
Nö, nicht unbedingt. Jetzt wohl nicht mehr, jetzt nachdem du das so ausführlich dargestellt hast.
Genau, das ist das, wo dir die Sache so hingeht. Wie gesagt, der Preisdruck und die Konkurrenzkampf untereinander der Gesellschaften, der ist schon seit Jahren dabei, den Markt so ein bisschen aufzuräumen. Und damit auch die Arbeitsbedingungen für das Personal und auch die Piloten und die Fluggeleiter schwierig zu machen. Interessanterweise aber ein irrer Bedarf da. Nur nicht unbedingt hier gerade in Europa. Gerade hier so ein bisschen wenig Bedarf. Wenn einer alle möglichen Lizenzen hat und gute Erfahrungen hat, in China findest du sofort einen Job, auch als Europäer. Als Contractor sozusagen.
Stefan, haben wir noch irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen? Ich kann es mir fast gar nicht vorstellen. Aber es ist alles noch im Rahmen. Was halt hier so ein Rahmen ist.
Als Disclaimer, ich habe bestimmt nicht immer alles richtig gesagt. Ich weiß nicht alles. Genau, und manche Leute haben bestimmt andere Meinungen. Kann man aber noch hinterherklären, die Fragen.
War auf jeden Fall ein umfangreicher Einblick sozusagen. Und das war ja hier Sinn der Sache, um einfach mal so ein bisschen zu checken, was gehört eigentlich alles dazu, um diesen ganzen Luftfahrtbetrieb, also diese zivile Luftfahrt im Besonderen aufrechtzuerhalten. Was kommt so auf die einzelnen Personen und Gruppen und speziell natürlich jetzt mit deinem Einblick auch auf die Piloten dazu. Wann bist du so weit mit dem A380?
Nächsten Monat.
Nächsten Monat? So richtig mit offiziell Linienflug und so? Okay, dann muss ich mir mal ein passendes Ticket buchen. Stefan, vielen Dank.
Ich bedanke mich.
Und ich bedanke mich auch, und zwar bei euch wie immer. Und ich hoffe, ihr hattet Spaß an dieser Sendung und an der ganzen folgenden Sendung. Ihr wisst ja, es geht bald wieder weiter irgendwann mit einem weiteren überraschenden Thema. Mir fällt ja eigentlich immer irgendwas ein.